hello everyone and welcome to Simply
learns YouTube channel today we'll be
taking you through the JavaScript full
course
this course is designed in such a way
that it will cover every important
aspect from Basics like what is
Javascript to some advanced level topics
like promises and a sync await in
JavaScript
by the end of this tutorial you will be
able to implement JavaScript in
different ways we'll start this video
with an introduction to JavaScript and
why one should learn JavaScript and
we'll move on and cover almost
everything related to JavaScript like
arrays Loops objects functions promises
and much more
towards the end we have specific
projects waiting for you guys we'll
create some games and a fully functional
e-commerce website to end this tutorial
so before we begin let me tell you guys
that we have regular updates on multiple
technology videos so if you are a tech
geek in a continuous hunt for the latest
technological friends then consider
getting subscribed to our YouTube
channel and press that Bell icon to
never miss any updates from Simply learn
so without any further Ado let's get
started JavaScript was developed in the
year 1995 by a person named Brendan Ike
Brendan was working for Netscape
Communications while he developed
JavaScript in 10 days
there were a few changes in the name of
JavaScript initially it was mocha which
was later changed to live script and
then it finally became JavaScript the
start of JavaScript wasn't that good as
so many developers who were using Java
at that time
they considered JavaScript as a language
for designers and known Engineers no one
ever knew that this small side scripting
language would have a great future today
more than 90 percent of the websites out
there they are using JavaScript somehow
many of you guys gets confused with Java
and JavaScript let me clear it for you
that both Java and JavaScript they are
different languages they have almost
nothing in common many people say that
JavaScript was named after Java as a
part of a marketing strategy to gain
wider acceptance and recognition in 1995
Java was a buzzword when JavaScript was
developed that's why they renamed
JavaScript after Java let's move on to
what is Javascript
have you guys ever been through a
website where you can see images that
slides automatically one such website is
Amazon the home page of Amazon where we
can see different types of ongoing sales
is an example of JavaScript
in Layman language JavaScript is a
lightweight scripting language used to
make web pages more interactive and more
likely earlier when JavaScript was
developed it was only a side scripting
language to do basic tasks like you can
add pop-ups in your web page or you can
make your web page more interactive
nothing more than that but now the whole
scenario has changed with the help of
JavaScript we can create applications as
well
if we talk about applications let's take
an example let's suppose we want to
create an app we can create it in
Android or in iOS but we have to learn
few different languages to create those
apps for Android we have to learn Java
and XML and Swift We have to learn for
iOS but with the help of JavaScript you
can create hybrid applications which can
work on any platform without any problem
Tech giants like Google PayPal Amazon
and YouTube they are using JavaScript
these days the evolution of JavaScript
in the past few years was unbelievable
suppose you want to create a single page
website every one of us is familiar with
Gmail let's suppose so Gmail is a single
page website which looks more like
desktop software than a website so Gmail
is based on angular.js it is a popular
framework by Google which is free of
cost and it is totally based on
JavaScript now let's go over some of the
features of JavaScript these features
are actually why it is considered that
using JavaScript is advantages over
other languages
so let's start some of these points
JavaScript is not a proper programming
language indeed it is a scripting
language
which works in the runtime environment
just like python so there are few other
languages like C plus plus and Java they
need a compiler to work but with
JavaScript you don't need a compiler
once you are done with the script it
will interpret and show you the output
in the browser directly next up is
lightweighted Javascript can provide
programming facility to some extent in
JavaScript you don't need to specify any
data type or return type which helps in
making development more quicker that's
why it is known as light weighted
JavaScript is both client-side as well
as server side technology client-side
technology runs on the user's computer
whereas the server side technology runs
on the web browser initially when
JavaScript was introduced it was
introduced as a client-side technology
but with the introduction of node.js in
2009 one can now work in the back end as
well
there is a way to validate the user's
Data before sending it to the web server
and we can do that with the help of
JavaScript the data will be checked for
correct form and value
all we have to do is start a loop give
it the condition
to check the data JavaScript is also
platform independent although originally
designed to work on browsers only but
now it is a platform independent
language which means once you are done
with the script you can use it on any
browser or platform without any problem
JavaScript is an object based scripting
language although many programmers do
not consider JavaScript as a true object
oriented programming language due to its
lack of class concept
it does support other features of object
oriented programming like it supports
encapsulation it supports polymorphism
and also it supports prototypal
inheritance
the last but not the least feature of
JavaScript is case sensitive so when it
comes to keywords identifiers names and
functions JavaScript differentiates
between capital and lower case letters
we have to keep this in mind while
programming
now I will quickly go over some of the
JavaScript applications where JavaScript
is currently being implemented first one
that comes to every person's mind is web
development it was also the main motive
behind developing JavaScript we have
Technologies like angular we have
node.js we can create beautiful web
pages also JavaScript can be used along
with HTML and CSS to make those static
looking web pages more engaging if we
talk about other applications of
JavaScript we can use it in app
development either mobile app or web app
like we took the example before that how
hybrid apps made with the help of
JavaScript can take over traditional
Android and iOS app one of the most
important and unique application of
JavaScript is in smart watches the
bangle.js is an open sourced Smartwatch
powered by JavaScript Gordon Williams
the man who is currently working on this
project it is said that this new open
sourced stack built around JavaScript
will replace the onboard firmware soon
the next application of JavaScript is
client-side validation as we discussed
earlier JavaScript is used to validate
the user data whether the user's input
is correct or Not by cross checking it
with the given condition like the user
wants to enter in your website and you
want it to be a user with at the rate
gmail.com in his email ID so you will
give that condition to JavaScript and it
will cross check it with the user's
information like when the user will try
to enter in your website it will check
that if at the rate gmail.com is there
or not in the user's email ID
so it can validate the user also apart
from that one more application of
JavaScript is game development
JavaScript can be used to make fully
fledged 2D or 3D games using different
libraries although most JavaScript game
development focuses on creating games
used in browsers only
till now we have an idea about what
JavaScript is its features and its
applications so if you want to learn
JavaScript you need to do some basic
things to make your learning experience
more smooth let's take a look at the
prerequisites to use JavaScript the
first one is the basic knowledge of HTML
and CSS to use JavaScript along with
HTML and CSS you first need to know how
HTML and CSS Works see HTML is used to
create the structure of a web page while
CSS is used to style that web page in
order to use these two with JavaScript
you need to have the basic knowledge of
HTML and CSS because if you want to
learn a new language first of all you
need to know why to use that technology
and to learn JavaScript more efficiently
you need to have the basic knowledge of
HTML and CSS it's better to have a web
browser that supports JavaScript like
Google Chrome or Mozilla Firefox or you
can use Safari as well if you are using
a MacBook you will need an operating
system like Windows Linux or Mac
operating system to learn JavaScript a
computer with minimum 512 MB of ram
would be enough for you to start
learning JavaScript but I will recommend
you a computer with 1GB of Ram or 4GB of
RAM for a better experience you can use
any text editor you have notepad which
is free and is already available for
Windows if you don't want to use notepad
you can use other free softwares like
sublime or you can use visual code in
this particular course we will be using
visual code and I'll tell you how to
install visual code and what are the
features of visual code also suppose you
do not have any prior knowledge about
JavaScript don't worry about it we will
take you through the whole course and we
will ensure that you can understand
JavaScript let's start this video with
some facts about JavaScript
JavaScript is the only programming
language that a browser can understand
25 years ago when developers were
thinking about a language that a browser
can understand
there were a few languages that were
present in the Market at that time just
like Java still there were some problems
with these languages that these
languages need a server to work with the
browser JavaScript on the other hand can
work directly with the browser you write
the code in the editor the browser will
go through it it will interpret it and
then runs the program
the popularity of JavaScript increased
with time
being a language which can do so many
tasks whether it be designing a
website's front end or going through any
website's backend JavaScript can do
anything by the end of 2018 over 95
percent of the internet was powered by
JavaScript means almost every website
out there is using JavaScript in some
way or another
do you guys know about stack Overflow
website for every programmer don't worry
you will get to know about it once you
start with the programming part stack
Overflow states that JavaScript is the
most popular programming language used
by the developers let me quickly run you
through the reasons why one should learn
JavaScript and then we'll briefly
elaborate each of these reasons
JavaScript has the most powerful
Frameworks JavaScript is constantly
growing and is a well-paid job
JavaScript is beginner friendly and it
has the largest community
JavaScript provides wide range of usage
as well let's move on further and see
why each of these reason is important
JavaScript has the most powerful
Frameworks for every task a user wants
to do like for designing a single page
website like you want to design a
website like Gmail you can use
angular.js if you want to design UI
components or user interfaces for single
page application you have react.js you
want to develop a mobile or a desktop
application let's suppose you have
view.js for that as well basically you
can do anything with powerful JavaScript
Frameworks next up is constant truth one
of the main reasons behind one should
learn JavaScript JavaScript is one of
the fastest growing languages and stands
among the top 10 languages used by the
developers with so much increase in
Mobile Market mobile web development has
seen an immense rise in need of
interactivity
which is Possible only with the help of
JavaScript that's why JavaScript is
continuously growing and there is no way
that JavaScript will go down shortly
the developers working in JavaScript are
well paid across the world anyone who
wants to be a web designer or a web
developer needs to learn JavaScript it
is a must have skill for being a good
web developer we will discuss it in
JavaScript jobs section
JavaScript is an easy to learn language
compared to many other programming
languages like Java Python and PHP
JavaScript provides easy entry points to
the world of programming the best thing
about JavaScript is that it comes
pre-installed on almost every web
browser so you don't need to set up any
environment to start development in
JavaScript which means you can start
coding right away JavaScript has the
largest community among all the
programming languages out there
Community size does matter when it comes
to programming language because the
larger the community size is the more
help you would be likely to get
currently JavaScript has the biggest
stack Overflow Community it has
overtaken Java in terms of community
size and is still growing at a rapid
Pace wide range of usage in my opinion
one of the most important reasons why
one should learn JavaScript by knowing
JavaScript you can build an entire
website from its backend to the front
end apart from that you can also build a
full slash mobile application for the
backend you don't need to learn other
programming languages node.js is enough
with a bit of knowledge about database
and apis there is nothing you can't do
with JavaScript when it comes to website
development
let's move on and discuss few jobs you
can take up after learning JavaScript
and we'll also discuss their average
salaries in USA and in India
so the first one is a full stack
developer a full stack developer is one
of the highest paid jobs in web
development sector a full stack
developer is equally proficient in
client-side as well as server side
development a full stack developer earns
around 9 lakh per annum which is quite a
decent amount of money for a person
living in India but if you are a full
stack developer in US you can earn up to
hundred thousand dollars per annum which
is a huge amount
front-end developer is the one who deals
with the front end of any website or
application it's obvious that a
front-end developer will not earn as
much as a full stack developer but the
amount of money a front-end developer
earns in a year is decent a JavaScript
developer works on the front end and
sometimes backend also a JavaScript
developer may be responsible for the
whole website or just a few aspects or
pages of different websites they earn
quite well when it comes to salary a JS
developer in US earns around 75 000 per
annum which when converted to Indian
rupees sums around 55 lakhs approx which
is a huge amount
designing a UI is an interesting job as
it needs creativity along with skills
it's always fun to design interfaces to
attract users one should need a lot of
creativity for this job the amount of
money a UI ux designer earns in India is
around 7 lakh per annum but it can go up
as much as 20 lakh per annum depends
upon the skills possessed and creativity
of the designer so choose your career
wisely let's start this video with the
introduction to Dom
Dom stands for document object model it
is an API for HTML and XML documents
which helps JavaScript to understand
what is their return inside the HTML
document API stands for application
programming interface to understand API
better let's take an example of a
restaurant
imagine yourself in the restaurant you
are sitting at the table with the menu
the chef in the kitchen is also part of
the system the waiter here works as a
messenger between you and the chef
that's what API does it works as a
moderator between JavaScript and the
HTML document
Dom defines the whole HTML document in a
hierarchical form to make it
understandable for JavaScript so that
other JavaScript functions can work over
it it represents the entire document in
the form of object and nodes whether it
be elements or text or anything stored
in the document the entire page content
can be accessed or manipulated by
JavaScript Dom is not used with
JavaScript only other languages like
python also uses dom dom was designed to
be used independently to begin with dom
there is nothing special you have to do
different browsers have different
implementation of the document object
model every browser uses Dom to make the
web page of the document accessible by
JavaScript let's move on and see what is
document object model with the help of
an example I believe you guys have the
basic knowledge of HTML and CSS a
prerequisite for this course let's start
things off with a basic HTML example
here we have a code that consists tags
like HTML head body heading tag Etc we
have the HTML tag here the opening HTML
tag and the closing HTML tag inside the
HTML tag we have the head tag which
contains the documents header part
inside the head tag there is a title tag
that contains the title of the web page
then comes the body tag which contains a
heading tag and two div tags with IDs as
div 1 and div2 a div tag defines a
particular section in the HTML document
the ID used within the div tag it is an
attribute basically that has to be
unique within the document to make the
element unique from other elements next
up we have a paragraph tag with a class
attribute within it CSS and JavaScript
uses classes to select and access
specific elements don't worry guys if
you have no idea about it let us first
see the output of this code before going
to the document object model of this
whole document so guys this is the
output of the previous code we just came
through here we can see the title of the
web page as well as heading after it
there were two different div tags used
in the code here is the output of both
the div tags the question here is where
are those ID and class attributes seen
in the out the answer to this question
is there's nothing on this web page that
can show both of them we can use them in
our CSS file or through JavaScript to
specify the containers in which they are
used so we have concluded how a normal
document works and how the browser
interprets the HTML cool but how
JavaScript uses this code is a bit
different that's where Dom comes into
play when the actual HTML document is
loaded in the browser another
representation of that document is
created known as document object model
here's the model you can see on your
screen
each of the tags used in HTML document
is correspondingly represented as object
in the doll like starting from the HTML
tag and covering all the other tags like
head title body and View mode the same
hierarchy as there was in the HTML
document goes with the document object
model also document to object model is
simply the same HTML document with
different representation the reason
behind this different representation is
that it's easy for JavaScript to
interpret this format
JavaScript can't understand tags but it
can understand these objects JavaScript
can easily manipulate these objects
using different functions which we will
see in future while working on these
function for example if you want to
access the text present inside the
heading tag you can do it by accessing
The Heading tag with JavaScript you can
also work on the style of this text with
the help of JavaScript as well
JavaScript uses the concept of nodes it
can access nodes of the document object
model there are many types of nodes
present in the Dom the basic three types
are element node attribute node and text
node the element node consists of all
the tags used in HTML document like the
head tag and the body tag the attribute
node contains the attributes used in
HTML document by now I hope you have
understood the concept of attributes so
JavaScript can access these attributes
as well and the user can work upon them
as per requirements
the text here in the HTML document that
is simply it can also be accessed with
the help of JavaScript it is the value
of that particular element
before installing vs code let's discuss
a few things about what is an IDE
so IDE stands for integrated development
environment it is a software application
basically it comprehends facilities to a
programmer for software development just
like photoshops makes it easier for us
to edit photos in the same way IDE makes
it easier for a programmer to write code
if you want to write code IDE will help
you write that and it will help you in
software development
there are a number of Ides present in
the market today we have Sublime we have
pycharm we have comodo we have notepad
and notepad plus plus as well but in
this particular course we will be using
visual studio code or vs code we can say
so let me run you through some of the
advantages that why we are using vs code
for this course so first of all vs code
is free to use as it is a open source
software so you can use it without any
cost
it supports multiple programming
languages there is nothing like you need
any web support or work on different
editors for different programming you
can use vs code for different languages
extensions are also one of the main
reasons behind using vs code see you
want to work on a programming language
it does not support all you have to do
is add an extension search for it and
you are good to go it will also not
affect the speed of the editor as it
runs as a different process it can also
detect code snippet whether it is
complete or not like you are using a
variable in your program and you forgot
to declare it vs code will do it for you
this property is known as intellisense
besides all these properties one main
key feature behind using vs code is it
is cross platform it is available for
Mac it is available for Linux and
windows as well I think there are enough
features we have discussed till now
there are many more features we will
discuss them while installing or while
working in vs code so for now let's move
on to the installation process the
installation process for vs code is
pretty simple just go to Google and
search for vs code
the next page which will open here you
can see that the first link available is
from their official website click on
that and you will go to their official
website here in the front you can see
the download this you can download this
table version from here only or if you
want to download it for you according to
your PC's specifications you can click
on the download button present at the
top right corner of your screen here you
can see that vs code is available for
different platforms it is available for
Windows for Linux and for Mac as well
you can download it from here as well so
if you want to download it for Windows
you can click here
it will take you to another page and it
will start downloading vs once the
download completes open the setup file
from your downloads and it will take you
to the license agreement page you have
to agree with all the terms and
conditions you can go through the full
license but then it will take a lot of
time to go through all this once you
click on it this window will open where
you have to select the location you want
your vs code to locate
any ID you install the default location
for all the editors is the same you can
click on browse and select any other
location if you want but for now I'll be
leaving it as it is and I'll click on
next now this will open and you will
click next from here now it will ask you
some questions like if you want to
create a desktop icon or not select all
of them and click on next now click on
install and it will install vs code for
you sit back and relax it will take time
so once you are done with the
installation process click on finish and
the visual studio code will start
automatically
so here we are you can see that we are
on the welcome page so let's start with
these icon present on the left side of
the editor this icon here is Explorer so
vs code works with the folders in your
system click on open folder
and just search any folder or you can
take any folder of your choice so here
in my PC I'll go to work and I'll
take JavaScript as my folder I'll select
it and see it will open the folder and I
already have a few programs written over
here like this
and I have a few more programs like this
and this you can open any program from
that folder by using this Explorer
option you can open any program present
in that folder so basically what it does
any program you make in Visual Studio
code you will save it in this folder
only so it will be easy for you to open
any program anytime next up we have the
search button to find any keyword or
word present in your code whatever you
write here it will show you where it is
present in your code or in your document
so let's suppose I write here simply
learn C it will show you simply learn in
your main screen so you have a shortcut
key for this also press Ctrl F from your
keyboard and write anything here like
it's written simply linear press enter
and it will show you the result the
third option here is for Version Control
if you want to use any Version Control
like you want to use git vs code has
very good integration with Git the next
button here is for debug or it will run
your program once you are done with
writing the code click here and run and
debug just open it with chrome you have
a shortcut for this as well press F5
from your keyboard and it will do the
same the next button here is for
extensions here you can find many
extensions given by the vs code
Community they are free to use for now
we will use these three extensions the
first one is HTML CSS support just click
on the search button write HTML CSS
support the first option click on that
and install that extension similarly you
have to install few modes you have to
install JavaScript and type script
nightly
and you have to install live server in
the same way I'll tell you the use of
live server in the next video when we
will be writing our first hello world
program let me end this video by giving
you a shortcut let's create a new file
here click here create a new file
this
close it create a new file we will name
it as new DOT HTML
so it's new DOT HTML here one thing you
have to keep in mind while saving a file
make sure to save that file with DOT
HTML extension here we are about to
start writing our first program so just
write
exclamation mark and press enter
it will do this see it will write the
basic HTML code which you will need in
almost every program from now on so you
don't have to write this code every time
just do it this way and start writing
main program we are using vs code Studio
as a text editor to write the script
here we have already discussed the
benefits as well as the features of vs
code in the previous video so as I have
already mentioned you must have a web
browser with JavaScript enabled in it so
if you are using Google Chrome it's
quite easy to enable JavaScript let me
take you through open Google Chrome go
to settings and just write JavaScript in
the search option go to site settings
and scroll down you will find here
JavaScript allow it if it's not allowed
in my case it's already allowed so I'm
good to go once you have downloaded the
editor and you are done with the
environment setup and all you can start
writing the program so let's go to es
code we will open a new file here and
save it with the name let's open a new
file and we will save it with name
first.html make sure to save your file
with DOT HTML extension as it will make
it easy for the computer to understand
that this particular file is an HTML
file so in the last video we installed
an extension named live server let me
tell you how to use it and what are the
benefits of using live server so let's
write a basic HTML program or just press
the exclamation key and press enter here
we are with the basic HTML program we
have not done anything yet just edit it
a little bit we'll add a heading tag and
inside the heading tag we will write a
heading let's suppose we are writing
hello so now right click on your desktop
and click on open with live server
but this will do it will open your
program in the browser see it's the
basic thing so let me tell you what its
benefits are it will open your program
in the browser and whatever changes you
are making in the programs will be
directly shown in the browser the moment
you save them see just use Google Chrome
or whatever browser you are using and in
the vs code side by side we'll be using
it side by side now let's suppose we'll
change something here let's add a word
here hello
world and the moment we save it it will
be reflected in your browser as well so
that's the benefit of using live server
we'll be using it during our whole code
so now we are done with that let's start
with the program so here we are with a
basic HTML code which has only tags in
it it will print that thing if I remove
this heading tag let me remove and
moment I save it it will print nothing
so guys let me give you a brief
introduction to these tags these HTML
tags are used to render HTML files
properties so that the browser can
differentiate between simple text and
HTML tags you can use as many tags
according to your requirements in our
first program we will write a single
line statement over the browser for that
we will need the script tag don't worry
if you don't know much about script Tech
let me tell you briefly about this text
functionality it is used to embed a
client-side script language remember
guys script tag is used to embed
JavaScript with HTML this is where HTML
and JavaScript comes together
it may contain the scripting statements
or Point towards the external script
through the SRC attribute we will see
the srci attribute as well we'll use the
script tag inside the body tag or we can
use it wherever we want to use it like
it's not necessary to use it inside the
body tag only we can use it anywhere in
a program so let's start with this
first
let's start the scripted
we are done with it now this cryptag we
have to type an attribute
the attribute is the type is it's a text
file
we are done with our script tag to write
on the web page we use a very basic
command the document.write
it is a JavaScript method using which
you can print anything on the browser
let's see what document.write can do
let's write here something
document dot right
and any text you want to write inside it
let's suppose hello world
um
welcome to
simply code
so guys we are done with this we have
written a text over here hello world
welcome to Simply code let's see what
will happen when we save it
press Ctrl s and the moment you save it
here it will be reflected on your
browser here you can see in our browser
it's written over here hello world
welcome to Simply code we can Define
JavaScript in an external file as well
let's see how we can do this how this
script tag will Point towards an
external Javascript file here what you
have to do you have written script just
before type use an attribute SRC and
give it the source of the file but till
now we don't have any Javascript file so
let's create a file bus name it as
crypt.js remember you have to save it
with DOT JS extension we are done with
it and we are good to go so here we will
write document
dot right
and any text you want to write here
hello world welcome to
simpler
we will save it the moment we will save
it here
there's something wrong I guess
okay we have not given the source code
of that JavaScript so here we have to
give the name of that file it was
script.js
moment we will save it see the text is
changed here initially it was Hello
World welcome to Simply code but now it
is Hello World welcome to Simply learn
this document.write is not interpreted
by the browser that's because this
script tag is now pointing towards an
external Javascript file anything you
will write inside this script tag will
not be considered now so we are done
with this script tag here we now have an
idea of how to embed JavaScript with
HTML and now let's see some of the
features of document.right so let's
suppose you are you have written this
text here let's erase it and see what
else it can do let's give it a task to
add two numbers let's suppose we have
given here 9 plus 3. let's see if it
works see it will give you the output
directly here document.write 9 plus 3 it
will give you at the output as 12.
similarly you will do any mathematical
task any calculation you want to do
let's suppose
7 multiply by
it
you can see here 12 56 Square let's give
it another one 9 multiply 5 minus let's
suppose 3 and save it 3 9 into 5 is 45
and if you minus 3 from 45 you'll get 42
here is the answer for s42 56 is for 7
into 8 7 multiplied by 8 and 12 is for 9
plus 3. so with that we are done with
how to embed with a JavaScript with HTML
let's move on to another Concept in
JavaScript that is console.log console
log is a function in JavaScript that
works the same as document dot right but
it will not print anything in the
browser let's give it a try let's
clear this and suppose we write here
console Dot Lock
and give it a command
save it and see there is nothing printed
on the browser let's write something in
the body tag we'll use a heading tag and
write something here let's go again and
go to body tag we'll use a heading tag
here as well
and write something here let's suppose
we write
play code save it see this is printed on
the browser to open your browser's
console go to browser right click here
and go to inspect element or you can use
Control Plus shift plus I which I
normally do here you can see the console
option see it has many options like
elements consoles courses Network and
many more but for now let's focus on
Console here you can see the text
printed here so what's the point of
doing this whenever we write a code we
usually have many variables and
functions and a lot of these kinds of
things we don't always know what to
expect as the output maybe we expect a
particular result but we might get
something else one way of debugging our
code is that we can pass a value to this
function here only and we can check the
result of that value out of the code
let's add two numbers here so if you
don't understand it basically what we
are doing for now we are writing a small
piece of code like the program is not
that big but later on when we are good
with JavaScript and we'll use JavaScript
as a primary language the size of the
program will go longer and longer so not
every time you are supposed to check the
output of your code by doing that only
so if you are using any variables or you
are using any functions you can check
the output here only if you have to use
that variable in that way or you have to
change something so you will get it here
only that's the use of console.log let's
add two numbers remove it a is equal to
5 and let these value is 8 suppose
okay we are done with these two numbers
and we will what we'll do we will write
console.log
we have given it the command to add a
and b let's see if it works here
see the value of a plus b is 13. you can
see it here in console the value is 13
you can see it here so here we can see
that the output is 13 you can do any
complex calculation here in the console
it will give you the correct answer you
can see here script.js column four the
number after the column is the line in
script dot JS here in our file we can
see that the console.log command is in
line number four so here it is written
that it is line number four here so if
you click on this
you can see the script.js opened in a
very small window and you can edit it
from here as well so this is not a
random line number to prove this let's
go on to our program and let's move this
to another line see now the console.log
is in line 11. save it and here you can
see this also changed to 11 so let's
make this more complex add another
variable C we'll add another variable
here let suppose we add C here we'll
give it a more complex equation let's
suppose let C equals to
the moment we save it it will give it
the answer oh no we are done with the
equation let's change it here also the
value of
C is
let's see if it works or not press Ctrl
s it's saved and the value of C is 7
let's see if this value is correct or
not the value of a was 5 5 into 3 is 15
15 plus 8 is 23 23 plus 4 is 27. 27 plus
a minus 25 value of a is 5 minus 25 is
minus 20 27 minus 20. the value of C is
7 see it's correct
check it yourself if you can do
something more interesting with this
control DOT log or you can do something
more interesting with document dot right
so console log allows us to debug our
code and we can use it if we are not
sure about the output in a lengthy
program before moving forward to
statements and comments here to take a
note while you are performing any
calculation let me show you see if you
are performing any calculation let's
copy it from here and paste it here
so yeah if you want to perform and let's
add two numbers like we want to add 45
and we will add let's say 5. we will
save it and here you can see the answer
is 50 here right so if you want to
perform any calculation you have to
write as it is you can't write any
calculation within inverted comma or
double inverted comma let's try this if
you want to write any calculation within
a single inverted comma the moment you
save it it will print it as 45 plus 5
what the browser will do the browser
will interpret it as text and print it
as it is so there will be no change so
keep that in mind take a note of it and
we are done with it right now so let's
move on to statements in JavaScript so
guys whenever you use any programming
language you give the computer
some instruction to perform any task or
activity that's common in all
programming languages present out there
like you are giving computers a few
instructions to do a particular task
these instruction you are giving to the
computer are known as statements you see
the code written over here this
document.write function is an
instructional statement given to the
computer to write something on the
browser like if you are writing hello
world inside this function it will print
it in the browser as it is and same for
addition subtraction multiplication and
whatever you are writing inside it it
will basically print it on browser like
let's suppose if we write here something
else
let's suppose we write here inside
double
inverted comma
welcome to Simply code we save it we are
basically giving it the instruction to
write this on the browser so what it
will do it will write it as it is on the
browser these are the instructions we
are giving to a machine to perform a
basic task or to perform a certain task
so if you are writing a whole program
for designing a website or for anything
you must be using more than one
statement you will use a lot of
statements in a single program
so all these statements are separated by
semicolons like here you can see after
every statement I have written a
semicolon it's necessary let me show you
an example see we'll remove this
statement and we'll copy this line and
paste it in the next line and write
something else here but we can say this
is our first program we will write like
suppose I have written it I'll give it
the semicolon here the moment I'll save
it see you can see here it's written
that hello world the first statement
statement is interpreted and written
over here then second it come to welcome
to Simply code see here you can see that
I have not written any semicolon but
it's still showing the output
so let me tell you something interesting
so if you remove the semicolon from any
of these statement here it will work
fine which means JavaScript will forgive
you for these small errors you do but
it's always a good practice to put a
semicolon after every statement because
while writing a whole program in future
you will use n number of statements and
let's see what happen if you try to
write more than one statement in a
single line without any semicolon let's
do this thing here write more than one
statement in a single line and I'll save
it see it won't work the moment I put a
semicolon here and save it it will work
fine
so that's why I am saying that it is a
good practice to use semicolon after
each statement
hope you guys are getting this let's
move on to comments so a comment is also
common for almost all programming
languages it's a line in programming
language which do not have any effect on
the output of the program
it stays there in the code but it does
not affect the output by any means a
comment may be a multi-line comment or a
single line comment as well to write a
single line comment we just use double
slash in front of that statement like
here if we see the output is Hello World
welcome to Simply code this is our first
program so to make this first statement
a comment what we'll do we'll use two
forward slashes in front of it and it
will become a comment so the moment we
will save it this hello world is
disappeared from the output
so this is how to use a single line
comment a comment won't affect your
program by any means let's move on to
multi-line commands to write a
multi-line comment you have to use
forward slash along with the asterisk
sign see if you want to make these two
line cells comments to end a comment we
will use asterisk sign with a forward
slash these two statements are comments
now so the moment you will save it
welcome to Simply code is also
disappeared from the output that's how
comment work they won't affect your
program's output but comments are very
useful in programming it's just a note
for the programmers to remember what
they did at that particular part of the
program suppose you write a program see
here the programs are not that large and
the coding is not that much but in
future when you write a program maybe
the program will be of more than 500
lines or more so suppose you write a
program with more than 500 lines and
come back 20 days later so at that time
you can't go through the whole code this
is where comments will help you in
JavaScript it will help you to remember
what you did at that particular part of
the program variables are named storage
that a program can manipulate as the
name suggests a variable is a value that
can change according to conditions
variables refers to those memory blocks
inside the computer where we can store
information let's suppose you want to
store any value inside your computer so
variable will represent the location of
that value
in simple terms variables are cups with
stuff inside them and you can use that
stuff later again and again according to
the way you want to before the
introduction of es6 or ecmascript we can
say which is the updated version of
JavaScript variables were declared using
a single keyword only which is where
we'll try to declare a few variables
here we'll see how where keyword works
so let's comment this thing first
so let's declare a few variables let's
suppose where a equals to 15 we will
declare
where B and the value of B will be 6 we
will declare where
C and the value of C would be a plus b
so here we have defined three variables
a b and c a is a variable with value 15
stored inside it and so is B the value
of B is 6 but C is a variable that will
contain the value of a plus b let's try
to print this on browser
document dot right
and we will print the value of C
save it and here you can see the value
of C is 21.
that's the correct answer so similarly
you can also print a and b as well let's
print a and b as well here
what we will do we'll copy this line
we'll paste it for a and
we'll update this here as well
so it won't create any confusion
so here you can see the value of C is 21
the value of a is 15 and the value of B
is 6. it shows the value of all the
three variables we declared but with the
introduction of es6 or ecmascript in
2015 two more ways were introduced to
declare a variable these are let end
const we shall discuss these two terms
in the later part of this session let me
show you how to declare a variable there
are a few things you have to keep in
mind while declaring a variable name
here we have seen we use three variables
a b and c that was an easy task to do
but giving a variable any name like
something other than a single alphabet
so you have to keep a few things in mind
while naming them start them with the
letter underscore or a dollar sign you
can't use any sign except underscore or
dollar so if you are giving a variable
name you can't use any other sign except
the underscore or the dollar sign you
can use these two signs on you can't use
any other sign
you can't use a number in the starting
apart from that let's suppose you want
to give it a name as 9be you can't do
that in JavaScript JavaScript won't
allow you this if you try to save it it
will throw you an error invalid or
unexpected token so you can't do this in
JavaScript there is no limit for the
length of the variable name but you
can't use reserved keywords in a
variable name like let's try to create a
variable with name as class class is a
reserved keyword in JavaScript we will
save it and see here throws an error
unexpected token class but you can use a
class with capital c let's save it and
here it will work fine why it works
because JavaScript variables are case
sensitive if we try to create a variable
with same name Let's see we try to
create a variable with where girl and
the another variable will be where girl
with capital G this time JavaScript will
treat these two variables differently
these two are different variables for
JavaScript as JavaScript is case
sensitive when it comes to variables
let's declare a few more variables let's
remove it we'll declare a few more
variable let's comment this part as well
it will declare a few more variables
suppose we declare a variable with
keyword where and we'll name this
variable as bikening where byte name
and press enter
if we leave this variable without
assigning it any value the by default
value will be undefined let's try to
print the value of this variable
right we will try to print the value of
byte name
save it here you can see the value it
shows is undefined so the by default
value of a variable if you do not assign
it any value will be undefined
let's try to give it a value let's
suppose we
try to give bike name
we use equals to operator to assign it a
value cosine let's suppose we'll assign
it Yamaha
semicolon and press Ctrl s to save this
and here you can see the output as
Yamaha you can also assign a value to
the variable during declaration as we
have done in the previous examples here
we have assigned the variables value at
the time of Declaration only let's move
on to let and const so we will discuss
let and Cones but first we will compare
let with where let is also used to
declare a variable just like where is
used but there is a limitation to use
let
is not accessible outside the Block in
which it is declared
so we will use let here only let byte
name equals and we will change this
value as well we'll change it to Hero
let's say save it and here you can see
the output as hero but if we try to put
this code inside a block let's suppose
we put this code inside this block a
pair of curly braces and we will again
try to access document dot right we'll
try to access bike name again from here
from outside the block we try to access
this save it and here you can see bike
name is not defined it is an error in
line 18. so what's happening here
basically you can't access a let
variable outside the scope you can't
access it from here but it will work
with where we try to replace let with
where and save it here you can see it
says hero and hero because first it will
interpret this method and then it will
interpret this as well in case of where
due to its limited scope let variables
are used when there is limited use only
like in for Loop or in while loop we
will learn these Loop in future let will
not allow you to redeclare any variable
let's understand this with an example
here's the code as well we have declared
where bike name and we'll remove this
and first we will try to do this with
where let's suppose where bike name
equals to TVs Control Plus s it says
hero and TVs so the variable name the
bike name is same in both cases here and
here as well these are same but with
where keyword you can do that let will
not allow you to do this if we use let
here in place of where we'll write
letters here as well and we will change
the value as well we will give it as
Kawasaki
and
let's suppose Suzuki here
save it
see bike name has already been declared
so that's what let won't allow you to do
you can repeat the same light variable
in different scope it won't create any
problem but it will not allow you to
redeclare any declared variable so let's
move on to const we use const when there
are values we don't want to change or
that will never change basically so the
keyword const is little misleading as it
defines a constant reference to a value
not the constant value we can't change
the Primitive value but we can change
the properties of constant objects let's
write another piece of code for const
keyword
so let's declare a variable const X is
equal to
5.
comma Y is equal to
7 let's say once
so here what we have done we declared a
variable X and a variable y with value
as 5 and 7 we declared this time with
const keyword and the variable Z which
is X Plus y we printed Z on the browser
and it shows the value as 12 which is X
Plus y 7 plus 5 is equal to 12. now what
we will do const will let you do this
but if you try to update the value of x
let's suppose we'll try to update the
value of x as x equals to X
Plus 10.
we'll print X this time
document dot right
X let's save this it will throw an error
assignments to a constant variable in
line 24 so here you want to update the
value of x you can't do this with const
keyword you can do this with let and
where as well but you can't do this with
const also cons won't allow you to
redeclare any variable just like let so
if you try to use const x again
equal to 10 save it
so here it says identifier X has already
been declared this thing you can do with
const the scope of const is the same as
lead it can be used within the block
where it is declared data types is an
essential Concept in every programming
language to work on any variable you
should know its type
it refers to the kind of data which is
being stored inside a variable the type
of variable is holding basically
every programming language has its own
set of data types which is unique in its
own way
we discussed earlier that JavaScript is
a lightweight scripting language because
we don't need to specify any data type
in JavaScript after all all the
variables in JavaScript are Loosely
packed or we can say JavaScript is a
dynamically typed scripting language we
shall discuss these properties later in
this video for now let me tell you about
different data types present in
JavaScript
so JavaScript data types are divided
into two categories primitive data types
and non-primitive data types primitive
data types are stored in stack whereas
non-primitive data types they are stored
in Heap I don't want you to go deep in
these two terms as if you are new to
programming so we'll leave it just keep
one thing in mind that primitive data
types are base data types whereas
non-primitive data types are objects or
we can say they are derived
primitive data types they are further
divided into five categories they are
divided as numbers strings Boolean
undefined and null non-primitive data
types or complex data types we can say
on the other hand they are divided into
two parts arrays and objects will have
separate videos on these topics for now
let's discuss primitive data types to
understand primitive data types much
better let's declare a few variable here
let's say we declare where X and give it
the value as 16. we'll declare where Y
and will give it value
we'll declare one more let's say where
flag
and the value will be true
here we can talk about those properties
of JavaScript which I mentioned earlier
JavaScript variables are Loosely packed
and JavaScript is dynamically typed
scripting language these two points
refer to the same thing here you can see
we have defined three variables X we
have defined variable X we have defined
variable Y and flag as well the values
for all three variables is different
from one another
see variable X is holding a value that
is 16 variable Y is holding a value
hello world which is a string so 16 is a
number hello world is a string and
variable flag is holding a value that
refers to a Boolean value in place of
true we can also write false here
so what's happening here here you can
see there is no data type if you are
coming from a C plus plus background or
a Java background this will be a little
bit weird for you guys because in C plus
plus and Java we used to do it like we
will define an integer let let me show
you
so how we will Define integer in C plus
plus or what we'll say we'll use int x
equals to 5
or something like that we already had a
data type for string as well we have
carrying C plus plus but here in
JavaScript we have no data type we are
only using the where keyword that's what
we call as Loosely typed
this line means that you don't have to
define the data type of the variable
what happens in JavaScript is whatever
the type of value you will pass to the
variable the data type will change
accordingly
so you don't need to worry about if you
are passing a number or if you are
passing in string
just relax just when you pass the value
to the variable it will be determined
automatically so these are the three
basic primitive data types present in
JavaScript which are number
Boolean value and string
so let's move on to the next one which
is undefined it will Define a variable p
and we'll leave it as it is so this
variable P has an undefined data type it
means that any variable which is already
declared but has no value inside it it
has an undefined data type
I'll tell you a basic operator the type
of operator
we'll go through the operators in later
videos but just try to understand the
basic need and use it with me for now
this operator will help you know the
type of value a variable is holding see
let's use it here we have declared a
variable P we'll check the type of P so
to use this operator you have to use it
with document dot right now
so we will do document.write and we'll
use two brackets
and inside it will write
type of and whatever like we want to
know the type of variable X let's
suppose we'll write here x
semicolon save it and you can see here
it says number this means that this
variable has a value which is a number
similarly we will check for all the
variables present here we'll check for
every variable we'll check for y will
check for flag and we'll check for p as
well let's copy this and
paste it three times and let's change
the value here from X to Y in this line
and from X to flag here
and here we'll change it to p
so we have done it we'll save it and see
here it says number first variable y it
says it's a string because you know
hello world is a string it's a sequence
of character for variable flag it says
Boolean so it's defined as true or false
and for variable P it's written here
undefined with this we are left with
only one primitive data type the null
data type there's a difference between a
null value and an undefined value
undefined means lack of value whereas
null means the absence of any value
suppose you are using null as the value
for any variable the type of operator
will return this variable as an object
but if you are not giving any value to
this variable you are leaving it after
declaration the type of operator will
return undefined here's an example for
this C we'll declare one more variable
here we'll declare where num let's name
this variable num and we will give it
the value as null we will use
document.write type of and we will check
with the help of type of operator that
what type of value the variable num is
holding so let's give here num
we are good to go press Ctrl s and C
here it says it's an object
so a null value will always be shown as
an object we'll talk about the complex
types or composite types in further
videos we'll have separate videos for
each of these types don't worry about it
type conversion as the name suggests
conversion of value from 1 to another in
the previous video we declared a few
variables we declared numbers strings
and Boolean as well in JavaScript you
can change the data type of any variable
from one to another you can change a
number to a string or a string to a
number let's see an example of type
conversion let's declare a variable here
let's suppose we are using a variable
let's say where num equals to and the
value will be 34 and will print it first
and we'll use type of operator to see
the data type of this variable
save it and see here it shows 34 and a
number I've already told you about the
use of console.log in this topic we'll
use console.law just for a change you
can use document.write as well there is
no problem with any method you are using
let's move ahead and we'll declare a few
more variables we'll declare a string
and a Boolean as well
let's suppose where Str equals to
hello
and we'll print it as well let's copy it
from here and paste it here
and we'll declare one more variable
let's say where Bool equals to
true
let's print these three variables first
see the output is pretty simple we can
see the value and data types as well see
34 is a number hello is a string and
true is a Boolean value
so let's convert this number to a string
first this number 34 this is a number
here right and we'll convert this number
to a string so how to do it that's
pretty simple all you have to do is
write a word here let's write here write
string with a capital s
and put 34 inside a bracket so here we
are done with it save it and see here
you can see 34 which was a number first
and now it's changed to a string
that's how you can change the data type
of any variable let's try to change a
Boolean value to a string now many of
you guys gets confused with Boolean so
Boolean is nothing if something is true
then set it to true and if something is
not true like if it's false then set it
to false see if we talk about a real
life example say if you know how to
drive create a variable drive and set it
to true and if you don't know how to
write set the variable to false that's
pretty simple that's what Boolean is
let's change a Boolean variable to a
string we have to follow the same steps
as we did for numbers but we did we'll
write here string and put true inside
brackets
we are done with it save it and check
the output here you can see the type
change from Boolean to string like
string function we can also change a
string value to a number
so how to do it let's take a variable
let's say where str1 will take let's say
we are giving it a numeric value let's
say eight nine six eight
and what we'll do we'll write a console
log and will print it basically
str1 and will right here as well
save it and here you can see 8968 is a
string so how to change this string to a
number that's also a simple task all you
have to do is write here number with
capital n and put this value inside
brackets
save it and see here you can see 8968
changed to a number it was a Stringer
layer and now it's a number so if it's a
number now let's update this number and
we will see if we are adding something
to 8968 the value will change or not
let's update str1 what we'll do we'll
write str1 equals to str1
plus let's add a number say oh
so the output should be 8970 and the
type of operator will give the value as
number let's see what's the output now
save it and see here you can see the
output changed to 8970 but if you add an
alphabet or a character in the value
then the output will be different here
we will copy this whole code
and we'll paste it here
we'll change the value of str1 equals to
str2 and we'll use an alphabet along
with this number let's suppose it's 8968
a so a is in alphabet and what we'll do
we'll comment this line and we'll go
here and change the value str1
here we are done with it save it here
you can see it says Nan it means that
it's not a number it won't treat this
string as a number because it consists
of both numeric value as well as
character
now let's try to convert a Boolean value
to a number in the case of a Boolean
variable the scenario is a bit different
let's try this
let's declare a variable let's say we
are using where
Bool 2. and the value will be true
what we'll do we'll print the value here
you can see true and the data type of
true is Boolean so let's try to change
this Boolean value to a number that's
pretty simple task write here number and
put true inside brackets
save it and here you can see it says one
in case of Boolean variable
the value of true is 1 and the value of
false is 0. remember this guys keep this
thing in mind if you are changing a
Boolean variable to a number then the
value of true will be changed to 1 and
the value of false will be changed to 0.
now let's have a look at percent and
parse float as well after which I'll
tell you one more interesting function
let's move on to past tense first here
I'll declare a variable let's suppose I
am declaring a variable let's say where
and we'll name this variable as number
the value will be a string let's suppose
it's 56.
it will print it console.log
here you can see that the output is
showing 56 is a string so the data type
here is string because I have used here
single inverted comma so it will take 56
as a string
now let's suppose I want to parse this
as an integer or say I want to change it
to a number I can use percent as well
apart from number if you want to use
number that's fine but apart from number
if you want to use percent you can use
it
let's see what happens if you use
parsint use percent and put 56 inside a
bracket
save it and see here it changed the
string to a number 56 was a string
earlier right and now it's a number just
like percent we have parse float as well
parse float will do the same thing but
what if you are using a decimal number
here let's see if you are using 56.343
save it
but percent will do it will give you
let's change 56 first let's suppose we
are using 65 now save it and see percent
will give you the value as 65 only it
won't show you the value the decimal
value
but if you are using here number or pass
float it will give you the whole numeric
value let's see what happens if you use
number here
number and save it here you can see the
value is
65.343 like number if you are using here
pass float
let's use parse floatio
and we'll change the value here as well
let's suppose it's 72 point
five four three save it and see here it
will give you the whole numeric value of
the variable I hope this is clear for
you guys
now there is one more function you can
use in numbers which is dot two fixed so
this function has by default zero value
let's suppose I am using here we have to
use it here only let's see what happens
if I am using number Dot
to fixed
so inside bracket we are giving it a
value by default the value is 0 Let's
suppose we are giving it the value as 2.
now save it and what will happen it will
give you the value as 72.54 similarly if
you are using here some other number
let's suppose seven you can see we have
only three digits here after the decimal
we have three digits only that is five
four and three what happens if we run
this program now let's save it and see
it says
543000 so it will show you the value up
to seven decimal points it doesn't
matter if there are available numbers
after decimal point but it will show you
the value instead of 7 you can also give
here 30 let's save it and see it says
6366 and so on hope this is clear for
you guys in any programming language an
operator is a symbol that makes the
computer understand that it needs to do
some specific tasks like if you want to
perform an addition between two numbers
let's say we want to perform addition
between four and five so guys if you see
the plus sign here this is known as the
operator and the two terms which are
four and five these two numbers these
are known as the operands
we have different operators for
different purposes like we have Plus for
addition we have minus for subtraction
we have star or asterisk we can say for
multiplication and many more other
operators as well so there are many more
operators present in almost every
programming language which is present
out there like it operators are present
in Java they are present in C plus plus
in C almost every programming language
out there has the concept of operators
it's essential for you to know how and
where to use any operator despite of the
language you are working on one needs to
understand which operators are available
right so in this particular video I'll
take you through the basic types of
operator present in JavaScript I'll let
you know the types and we'll learn about
how to use them and of course I'll take
you through the different categories of
operators present in JavaScript so in
JavaScript there are basically eight
categories into which operators are
divided which are we have arithmetic
operators we have assignment we have
string we have conditional we have
logical bitwise comparison and type of
operator we'll discuss the first three
types in this video that is we'll
discuss the arithmetic operators we'll
discuss the assignment and the string
operators rest we'll talk about in the
following video
first up here is the arithmetic operator
hope you all are aware of the term
arithmetic right
so arithmetic operators perform
mathematical calculations like it
performs addition subtraction
multiplication and division as well
so here are the few operators you can
see on your screen the plus operator
minus asterisk division we have modulus
we have increment we have decrement so
these are the basic arithmetic operator
we'll see each of these operator with an
example so let's move on to the
programming part first so guys I want to
mention one more thing here I want all
of you to make a separate file for each
topic we'll be covering from now on like
for operators you will create a separate
file will create a separate one for
control statements and other topics
we'll cover in future from today so I
want you to create a separate file
because you know in future if you want
to access these topics it will be easy
for you to access those files instead if
you are using a single file for all the
topics it will be quite confusing so
let's start with the arithmetic
operators first let's take two variables
we are in the Javascript file let's take
two variables let's say where x equal
equals to 6
and we'll take another variable let's
say where y equals to
4.
now we'll perform some arithmetic
operations on these two variables we
have already seen the arithmetic
operators present like we have plus
minus we have increment decrement we
have multiplication division so we'll go
through all of these right so let's
start with it here we are done with our
basic three operators which is addition
subtraction and multiplication I have
commented the division because I have
something to tell you about the division
so let's check the output here first
let's save it and see the output is
addition 10 subtraction 2 and
multiplication 24. for addition it added
the two numbers it's six plus four
similarly for subtraction and
multiplication it is 6 minus 4 and it's
6 multiplied by 4.
for division I have left division
because I hope you guys know the
difference between Division and the
modulus operator let's try to use the
modulus operator along with the division
so what we'll do we'll comment these
three and let's remove it from here and
what we'll do we'll paste this here and
we'll use the modulus here so now let's
check the output what it says for
division and modulus see we have divided
6 by 4 division it says it's 1.5 6
divided by 4 that is 1.5 it will show
the quotient here for modulus it's
saying 2 because
in modulus it gives you the remainder
and in division it gives you the
quotient as the answer so keep this
thing in mind guys keep this in mind
always take a note of it so we are done
with division and modulus next up we
have the increment and The decrement
Operators let me show them to you real
quick so what we'll do we'll declare
another variable let's say where Z
equals to 5.
and we'll use the increment operator
here we'll use again document.write
and here we'll let's say we write
increment how to use increment operator
for increment operator you have to use
plus plus whatever variable you have
used so we'll use plus plus Z
and similarly we'll copy this
paste it here and here we'll use
minus minus 4 decrement
and change here as well
so let's see what happens let me give
some space in between them so that you
won't get confused
let's save it and check the output here
increment is it says 6 and decrement it
says 5. so you can see here the
functioning of decrement and increment
operator the increment operator will
increase the value of Z by 1 and the
decrement operator will do the opposite
of this it'll decrease the value by 1.
so we are done with the arithmetic
operators next up we have the assignment
operators
assignment operators are used to assign
values to different JavaScript variables
let's see the types first and then we'll
see how to use them so we have these
assignment operators here here we have
equals to plus equals to minus equals to
and we have multiplied equals to we have
divide equals to modulus equals to and a
few more so let's see each of them with
example maybe not each of them but we'll
try to cover almost every single
operator out there which is present in
your screen so let's move on and see
let's move on to the programming part so
here we are guys let's declare a few
variables let's say we are declaring a
variable a and we are giving it the
value as 10 suppose
and we'll declare another one let's say
where B and give it the value
5. so for assignment operators what
assignment operator mean we have used
here the equal to sign right we have
used a equals to 10. this means whatever
value present on the right side of the
operator like here it is 10 it will be
assigned to the variable a
I hope you guys are getting this keep
this in mind so we have the value 10 and
we are assigning this value to the
variable a
it says let's try to check the output of
a let's try to print a on the screen
okay
document
see here you can see that the value of a
it says 10. and similarly the value of B
is 5 so let's do one more thing we'll
assign the value of a to B how to do
this let's change the value here only
let's suppose we are using the value of
where a is 13. okay and the value of
where we will be providing as let's say
a
so now let's try to print the value of B
here we'll change
will print the value of B only let's
save it and see the output see it says
the value of B is 13. because we have
assigned B the value present at variable
a which is 13. that's why it is showing
the value of b as 13. this is what
assignment operator is let's try other
assignment operators as well
let's take another variable
so let's say where even
equals to let's say 51.
so the next operator we will be using is
let's update the value of A1 first so
how to do this let's say A1 equals to no
it's a 1 plus equals to 9.
and we'll print the value
let's check the output now
see it says the value of A1 is 60 here
we have given that A1 plus equals to 9
see even plus equals to 9 is the same as
if you don't want to write here A1 plus
equals to 9 you can also write it as
even equals to A1
Plus 9. both of these lines are same
both these statements means the same
they are performing the same task so A1
equals to A1 Plus 9 is same as a 1 plus
equals to 9. that's what I want you to
understand with assignment operators
similarly if you want to perform a 1
minus equals to you can do it as well so
let's say A1 minus is equal to 5 and
we'll copy this line from here paste it
here again and save it now let's see the
output here what it says some of you
guys may get confused that here it shows
the value of 6 is 69 of A1 so in the
first statement when we try to print A1
here the initial value was 51 then this
statement was performed and the value
was updated to 60. then after that one
more statement this statement is also
performed and the value updated to 69
it's 51 plus 9 plus 9 and the value we
have here is 69. now what happens if we
are using the minus equals to operator
what it will do it will decrease the
value of A1 by 5. it means that A1
equals to A1 minus 5 the value of A1 is
69 and it will subtract 5 from 69 so
here it says the value of A1 is 64.
hope you guys are getting this so we
have so many operators we have so many
of them like let's try a few more so we
have multiply equals to we have division
equals to we have modulus equals to so
I'll write these and then we'll see the
output
so we are done with it let's check the
output here for A3 A4 and A5 you can see
for A3 we have used multiply equals to
for A4 we have used divide equals to and
for A5 we have used modulus equals to
let's check the output here
save it and see it says the value of
a350
it here we have taken a3s5 it's 10 into
5 because A3 equals to A3 into 5 so it's
10 into 5 it shows the value as 50.
similarly
here it says the value of A4 is 3.75
because we have used your food so
instead of 4 let's try to use 3 and save
it see here you can see it divides it
and gives you the quotient and the value
of A4 divided by 3 is 5.
so similarly for A5 it shows the value
of A5 is 6.
because we have used the modulus
operator here N20 divided by 7 we have
6s remainder
so I hope you guys are pretty clear with
assignment operators now next up we have
string operators the plus operator which
we used as the arithmetic operators
earlier right it also operates as a
string operator so we can use it to
concatenate two strings that mean we can
add two strings as well in JavaScript it
is possible with the help of string
operator similarly we have plus equals
to operator for Strings as well like we
have plus equal to for assignment it has
the same functioning for string as well
let's take the example for these two
operators let's move on to the
programming part so here you can see we
have two variables where str1 and where
str2 the value of where str1 is hello
and the value of where str2 is full so
what we'll do we will add str1 and str2
so let's check the output here save it
and see here you can see the output as
hello world but there is no space
between hello keep this point in mind
guys so if you are adding two strings
just like this there will be no space
between the two strings so if you want
to add any space between these two what
you have to do you have to mention it
here separately
and this this is the syntax if you want
to add space between your strings so now
let's save it now and see here you can
see there is a space between hello and
world
so this is the use of plus operator in
strings so the next one we have plus
equals to let's take another string
let's take it as whereas tr3 and we'll
give it the value as
welcome
so what we'll do we'll use the plus
equal to operator here str3 plus equals
to
let's say
simply code
and
what we'll do we'll print the value of
str3 here
so save it now
so here you can see the value of str3 if
we remove this this line
let's see what happens now
and we'll give it a space here
save it now see here you can see it says
hello world for the first str1 plus str2
it says hello world for str3 it says
welcome to Simply code see here the
space is already given so it will show
this in the output but between welcome
and two if you want to add space you
have to do the same what you have done
for str1 and str2 so let's do it here as
well plus sign yes save it now and see
here you can see it says welcome to
Simply code with proper space now we
will cover the rest of the operators now
we are left with five more these are the
first three operators now we are left
with conditional operators logical
operators we have bitwise operator and
we have comparison and finally we have
the type of operator
so these are the five operators we are
going to cover today before we start
with the operators let us first discuss
associativity talking about
associativity
it refers to the direction in which the
entire expression is evaluated for
example if you have any expression let's
say you have a plus b
so the direction in which this
expression will be evaluated either it
will be from left to right or from right
to left so this is known as
associativity let's understand it with
the help of an example
so here you can see I have taken three
variables I have taken variable a and I
have assigned it value as 12. I have
taken variable B and the value assigned
to B is 8 and finally I have a variable
result which stores the value of a plus
b
lastly what I am doing is I am printing
out the result variable inside the H1
tag here you can see I have used the H1
tags and I have used the plus operator
to concatenate the strings right I have
concatenated these two strings along
with the result along with the answer of
result so the plus operator here is
doing two different tasks right here you
can see it is performing the addition of
two numbers right and here you can see
it is used to concatenate two strings so
now let's talk about associativity
because I guess you guys are cleared
with string operator till now we have
discussed them in the previous video
right so let's talk about associativity
now so certain operators have right to
left associativity and certain operators
have left to right associativity so when
I say right to left associativity in
this case the value present at the right
side of the operator see if you are
using any operator for example here you
we have used the assignment operator
right we have discussed the assignment
operator earlier so here you can see the
value present at the right hand side of
the operator will be assigned to the
variable which is present at the left
hand side of the operator so
it's going this way like first the
computer will check the for the value
present at the right it's going from
right towards the left this is what we
are known as right to left associativity
and assignment operators like equals to
this have right to left associativity
let's add here one more variable let's
say we are adding a variable variable C
and we are giving it the value as
5 and what we'll do we'll update result
as well let me first show you the output
of this particular program see the
output will be value of result is 20 and
high there high there is concatenated
with the string value of result is N20
is the actual answer the 20 is the value
of result so let's add one more variable
here let's say we are adding a variable
C and the value of C will be 5. what
we'll do now we will update result as
well here you can see I have done a plus
b plus c
so
save it and here you can see the value
updated to 25 the value of result is
updated right so the plus operator has
associativity from left to right till
now we have talked about right to left
as for assignment operators but for plus
operators the associativity is from left
to right it means it will first perform
a plus b
and then the value of C will be added to
that of a plus b first it will perform
12 plus 8 and then finally it will add 5
to that value so it will be 20 plus 5
and that's why the output here is 25.
know that JavaScript is a Loosely typed
programming language right
which means that we don't have to
specify data types every time like we
are using if we are using any data type
we don't need to specify it every time
like let's do one thing let's add a
string here so what we'll do we'll add a
string let's suppose I'm adding hello
so practically the answer would be hello
Plus
25 or hello 25 it should be the answer
but let's check the output now save it
and here you can see the output is hello
one two eight five what happened here is
the associativity of the plus operator
is from left to right we know this so it
will start from the left and it will see
that okay the first thing to add is a
string so it will assume that everything
ahead of this will be a string that's
why we have the output as hello 12 8 and
5 so 12 8 and 5 all are acting as string
here
let me clear this one for you with a
little bit of modification now what
we'll do we'll remove this string from
here and we'll add it somewhere else
let's say we are adding it here
so
let's add one more variable to make it
more clear let's say we are using
variable D and the value will be 10.
and what we'll do we'll perform a plus b
before the string and then we'll perform
C plus d
right so here you can see when you save
it it says 20 hello 510 so when it
reached out the first variable it finds
out that the first variable is a number
so it added the first two numbers right
it added 12 and 8 the answer is 20 then
it came across this string hello and
then finally it assumed that everything
ahead of this will be a string so that's
the output 20 is the addition of a plus
b and then the string hello and finally
we have the value of c and d as string
so we have the value 5 and 10 not 15
right I hope you guys get this
so let's move on to conditional
operators the conditional operators
assign a value to a variable based on a
certain condition like it contains a
condition and you know for every
condition like there exists only two
possibilities either it can be true or
it can be false there is nothing else
you can do with a conditional operator
so it works the same as if else
statements which we'll cover in further
videos the only difference between if
else and conditional operators that it
takes less time or we can say its usage
is pretty easy
so here is the Syntax for conditional
operators so it seems pretty
straightforward right so here you can
see we have a variable name we have a
condition depending upon the condition
we have two values
here's the example as well C you can see
we have a variable voter next up we have
a condition if age is less than 18 so it
will check for the condition that if the
value of age is actually less than 18
let's suppose the value of age is 15. so
it will check if 15 is less than 18 it's
true then it will print 2m or if the
value of H is greater than 80 then it
will print false or you can say it will
print old enough here
so let's move on to the programming part
so here you can see I have taken a
variable X and the value assigned to X
is 30. what we'll do in variable y I
have given it a condition so it will
check for X which is 30 if 30 is greater
than or equals to 50.
so if it's true if 30 is actually
greater than 50 then it will print true
else it will print false so we'll check
the output once let's save it and see
here you can see the output as false so
if you update the value of XL let's
suppose we are updating the value of x
let's suppose it's
60 save it now and see the output has
changed to true because 60 is greater
than 50 right also if you want to write
a message here only you can do it write
it here as so we'll copy it from here
we'll copy document.write
and we'll paste it here
let's remove this document dot right and
we what we'll do we'll
use this bracket
here
and if any message you want to write
like you want to write value of
so
and now what we'll do will
save it
see it says value of true so or you can
write any other message here as well you
can write value of x is greater than or
you can write whatever
so if you want to update it like value
is and here we will update true
with
greater
and here we will use
smaller
save it now see here it says value is
greater value of x is greater than y
so that's all for conditional operators
also one more thing and conditional
operators has three different parts
right and that's why it is also known as
ternary operator three different parts
as in it has a condition like here it is
it's okay it has a condition and it has
two values right it has true or false so
that's why it is also known as ternary
operator
next up we have the logical operators
so logical operators are used to
determine the logic between two
variables or values we can say we use
logical operators to check whether
multiple conditions are true or false
here on your screen you can see the
three different types of logical
operators present in JavaScript along
with the syntax and example
so the end or note are the three
operators present in JavaScript
the and operator here you can see it it
is holding two values right it it has X
less than 10 and y greater than 1. so
the end operator will return true only
if both the conditions are true like X
has to be less than 10 and Y has to be
greater than one so here you can see we
have taken x equals to 7 and Y equals to
4 so both the conditions are satisfying
here so that's why the output of the and
operator will be true for our operator
the case is a bit different so if any
one of these two conditions like we have
two conditions if any one of these two
is true then the output will be true and
if both are false then only the output
will be false
the not operator on the other hand will
check if x is equals to Y if the value X
is holding is equals to that of Y if the
value is not equal then it will return
true
I hope you are getting this that's a
little bit
confusing but if the value X and Y
holding if they are not equal then it
will return true if they are equal then
it will return false
right
we'll understand the programming concept
of logical operators in further videos
when we learn about control statements
we primarily use logical operators with
the if statement through which we'll
come across in the following video in
the next video we will go through the
control statements so we'll understand
the programming part of logical operator
there only
next up we have the comparison operators
so comparison operators are similar to
logical operators in some way
they are also used to check for true and
false as the name suggests we use
comparison operator to compare two
values or we can say to compare two
variables using different operators
so here you can see on your screen these
are the different types of comparison
operators present in JavaScript we have
equals to we have not equals to we have
equal value and data type we have
greater than less than and we have a few
more so I hope you guys must remember
from the previous video that a single
equals two operator is an assignment
operator so if we are using a single
equals to then it will be considered as
an assignment operator for comparison we
have to use double equal to keep this
thing in mind whenever you are using any
operator in JavaScript or especially the
equals to operator so if you want to
compare two values you have to use
double equals to because single equals 2
is used to assign values this is an
assignment operator so let's move on to
the programming part now
so guys here you can see I have taken a
variable X and the value assigned to X
is 10. this code seems a little bit
longer to you but that's a simple piece
of code like I have used almost every
comparison operator we came across in
the previous slide I have used each one
of them and I've used the document dot
right after every comparison operator to
put some spaces in between so that you
guys don't confuse between them so let's
check the output now see you as you can
see I have used the double equals to the
triple equals to I have used X not
equals to it so let's check the output
save it and see here it says false false
true true false true false so for x
equals to equals to it it compared the
value 10 with 8. and 10 and 8 are not
equals to so the output will be false as
similar for 10 and we have used the
triple equals to operator which means
equal value and data type so both 10 and
8 have equal data type they both have
the same data type that is number but
the values are different so it will
print false
for X not equals to it it says 10 is not
equals to it yeah 10 is not equals to it
actually so it will print true similarly
for X not equals to equals to it it will
check that both the values are not equal
but the data types are equal right so it
will print true for this as well for X
greater than 8 yeah 10 is greater than 8
so it will print true
similarly for it will check for X
smaller than it and it will check for X
greater than equals to it and also for X
less than equals to it
so by now you have understood how
comparison operators work so comparison
operators are the easiest to use in
programming
and that's all for comparison operators
let's move on to the next one we have
the next type of operator we have is the
type of operator you guys have an idea
about the type of operators right as we
have discussed it earlier in case you
haven't watched the previous videos let
me give you a brief introduction about
this type of operator
so the type of operator is used to
provide you with the type of whatever
value you put to the right of it like if
you are using any data type and you want
to know about the data type of a
particular variable let's say so you can
use the type of operator it will tell
you the actual data type of any variable
so in JavaScript as we have discussed
earlier in the video where we have
particularly discussed about the data
types so there are five different types
of primitive data types right we have
the numbers we have strings we have
Boolean we have null and undefined
so let's try to use type of operator
so here you can see I have used four
different variables which are I've used
variable X variable Y and variable flag
and variable P so the values are
different the x is holding 17 why is
holding header and flag has the value as
false and I've defined P but I have not
assigned it any value till now so what
I'll do I have used the type of operator
to find out the type of every variable
like here I have used it for X for y for
flag and for p
let's check the output now
save it and see it says number string
Boolean and undefined see here we have
given X the value as 17. so 17 is a
number then it says it is a number for
hey there it says it is a string for
false it says it is a Boolean value like
in Boolean value we have only two values
like false and true
so for variable P it says undefined
you know there is a difference between
undefined and null data types undefined
means lack of value whereas null means
this absence of value that there is no
value at all
so suppose you are using null as the
value for any variable right the type of
operator will return
object but if you are not giving any
value to any variable like you are using
the variable as it is like here we have
not given it any value so if you are
doing this the type of operator will
return undefined so let's take an
example of null as well let's declare
another variable let's say where ABC
and we'll give it the value as null
so and finally what we'll do we'll
use type of operator
save it and see here it says the type of
variable ABC is an object
so remember this thing guys
and now we are done with almost 7
operators we had and we are left with
one operator only
so let's move on to our last operator
which is the bitwise operator this
operator doesn't have that much of
practical usage in the real world they
are not definitely useless but this is
something like we are not going to use
on a daily basis so in computers if you
know the numbers are stored in binary
format bitwise operators work on 32-bit
numbers and we have decimal numbers like
we understand decimal numbers computer
works on binary numbers right so when
bitwise operators are used any operand
present in the operation
is first converted to a binary number
and then convert it back to a JavaScript
number
so here you can see on your screen we
have four different bitwise operators we
have the and operator we have or we have
not and we have zor or we can say
exclusive or the result and the answers
are also here it's pretty simple see we
have used the and operator before as
well while we were in logical operators
but the syntax was different and
here you can see we have a single
Ampersand sign to use bitwise and
operator
so here you can see
how the decimal number first changes to
a binary number suppose we have X as 5
here you can see access first changed to
a binary number this is the binary
equivalent of five and one is also
changed to a binary number and finally
the result whatever result we get it is
changed to a decimal number so that's
how bitwise operators work let's take an
example of bitwise operators
so here you can see I have taken two
variables I have taken variable X and
the value of variable X is 5 and another
variable is y and the value of y is 1
and then I have used all the four
bitwise operators like I have used X and
Y I have used X or Y I have used not X
and I have used the xor operator between
X and Y so let's check the output now
here you can see if we talk about the
output C here it says 1 5 minus 6 and 4
so for X and Y see
the value of x is 0 1 0 1 and for and
operators it will return 1 if both the
values are 1. if any one of the two
values are 0 then it will return 0. so
what it will return here it will return
0 for 0 0 for 1 0 it will also return 0.
similarly for 0 0 it will also return 0
and for 1 1 it will return one which is
the binary equivalent of one so the
answer here is 1.
for x or y it will return 1 if any one
of the two values are 1. see if both are
0 it will return 0. if any one of the
two values is 1 it will return 1.
it will return 0 again and finally it
has two ones so it will return one
and 0 1 0 1 is the binary equivalent of
5 that's why the output here is 5.
for not operator it works a little bit
different it gives you the output which
is same as minus x minus 1 so minus x
minus 1 will be
see minus x minus 1 will be minus 5
minus 1 which is minus 6 so this is a
bit different here the not operator here
is a bit different
for xor operator or we can say exclusive
or it will return 4 why it will return 4
it will return 1 when any one of the two
values is one if both are one then also
it will return false it will return 1
only in one condition if any one of the
two values is 1 then only it will return
one that's why the output here
the output here will be 0 1 0 0 that's
why it's written as 4 which is the
binary equivalent of 0 1 0 0. the term
control statement is pretty
self-explanatory and straightforward
right we came across JavaScript
statements in previous videos JavaScript
statements are the instructions that
tells the browser to perform specific
actions control statements are also
instructions and they govern the flow of
control in a program
so let's take a look at control
statements with the help of an example
let's suppose we have a piece of code
that has n number of statements here
let's say we have this code and so the
conventional workflow will be it will
first execute the first statement then
second then third and so on till
statement n right
so this is the basic flow right from
statement 1 till statement n and it will
execute each statement in between
however in real world the scenario is
different like we don't write the code
in same menu every time
for example let's suppose you are in
line 5 and you want to print this line
10 times so what should you do you can
write this line 10 times or you can copy
paste it right okay let's forget about
10 times let's suppose you have to use
this code or we can say let's suppose
you have to print this statement 100
times doing this like copy pasting it
for 100 times or writing this statement
for 100 times that's useless and
unnecessary right so that's where
control statements comes into picture
we'll discuss them in a while let's
assume another situation this time you
want to make a choice based on certain
conditions you can use conditional
operators but then it has limitations
right to tackle this problem we have
control statements in JavaScript
so these are the very basic reasons why
we need control statements for
performing a certain activity like if we
want to perform a certain activity n
number of times or if you want to make a
certain decision making kind of
scenarios in your program that's where
we need control statements in JavaScript
in JavaScript we have two different
types of control statements depending
upon what action we are performing so we
have the conditional control statements
and we have the iterative or we can say
looping control statements
talking about conditional statements as
the name suggests we use conditional
statements when we have to make
decisions based on conditions when we
have two choices or when we can say when
we have two different conditions and we
want to make choices accordingly so
that's where we use conditional
statements we have two different types
of conditional statements the if else
statements and the switch case
talking about the iterative statements
as the name suggests if you want to
perform any action more than once or
maybe n number of times instead of
writing them again and again
we use loops so Loops are basically
statements we use Loops to perform any
activity n number of times with specific
conditions
so in JavaScript we have four different
type of Loops we have for Loop while
loop do while loop and foreign Loop
so the for Loop while loop and do while
loop you might have heard about them
earlier because they are also present in
other programming languages but this
foreign Loop this is a new type of loop
present in JavaScript we use foreign
loop with objects we'll go through
objects in upcoming videos and of course
we'll be looking at each of these
control statements in detail will have a
particular video for each of these topic
now let me introduce to you the break
and the continue statement
they are not the types of control
statements but they do assist in other
control statements the break is used to
exit a switch statement or Loop like
when used in a loop it breaks the loop
and continues executing the code after
it
and on the other hand the continue
statement breaks a single iteration when
used in a loop when we use continuous
statement in a loop it breaks a single
iteration and it breaks the iteration
only if the specified condition occurs
and then it will continue with the next
titration in the loop
so the if else conditional statement is
used whenever we work with condition it
can be either a single condition or
maybe more than one condition or
multiple conditions we can work with
so let's try to write a basic program
with a single condition
so then we'll move on to multiple
conditions using the elsif statement so
we'll create a new file today so I hope
you guys know the importance of creating
a separate file for every topic you know
it will be easy for you to work to find
out that separate file later if you want
to revise that topic
so here is the program where we have
taken a variable X and the value of x is
10. so what we are doing in this program
is we are checking if the value the
variable X is holding that is value 10
and if the value is less than
10 or if the value is greater than 10 so
we have only two conditions either the
value can be less than 10 or the value
can be greater than 10 or equals to 10
as well so here in this program what
we'll do we'll first we'll update this
value as 8 so the variable X is holding
the value 8. so to check the output
let's save it and here you can see it
says the value of x is less than 10. of
course the value 8 is always less than
10 right so for it that's fine it will
say the value is less than 10 and
similarly if we do the same for let's
say 11 save it now and see it says the
value of x is greater than 10. so that's
quite simple right but what if we are
giving the value as 10 we know 10 is
equals to 10 so save it now and see here
you can see
it says the value of x is greater than
10.
this is happening because what we did we
as we told The Interpreter to check the
value if the value of x is less than 10.
we didn't mention that if what to do if
the value is equals to 10. so it will
check for only X is less than 10 not for
equals to 10 or greater than 10 so here
what it is doing it is checking if the
value is less than 10 so that it says
okay let's print this statement if the
value is less than 10 or
if the value is not less than 10 or if
the value is equals 2 or greater than 10
it will print the value of x is greater
than 10. to avoid this type of
misunderstanding we use an elsif
statement so the concept of else if
statement is the same as if statement
but we are doing we are using multiple
conditions right we are giving it more
than one condition so how to use else if
it's quite easy and the syntax is also
similar to
the if statement the only difference is
that it contains an else before if so
it's an elsif so what we are doing is
we are giving it a condition that else
if x equals to 10.
so now what it will do it will check for
two conditions that if the value X is
holding is less than 10 or equals to 10.
and what we'll do we'll update it as
so let's check the output now
save and see here it says the value of x
is equals to time right so I hope you
guys are getting this the execution flow
for this program will be like it will
check for the first condition if x is
less than 10 if yes it will print the
value of x is less than 10. if no it
will move on the to the following
condition like under the elsif statement
it finds a condition that if x is equals
to 10 it will check for it if yes if x
is equals to 10 then it will print the
value of x is equals to 10.
or if not then otherwise it will move to
else statement and print the value of x
is greater than 10 we don't need to
specify any particular condition for
this you know because we have already
specified the two conditions that if x
is less than 10 or if x is equals to 10
now we'll take a look at some basic
programs other than this one we'll take
a look at a few more basic programs
so here's the another program what we
are doing here is we are taking a
variable X and the value of x is 5. so
what we are doing is we are checking if
the number is an even number or an odd
number the thing you have to keep in
mind is the logic to find whether a
number is even or an odd number so to
check uh whether a number is even you
what we do we'll divide that number with
two right but basically we want is we
want the remainder is 0 when we use the
modulus operator so what we'll do here
we have written X mod 2 equals to equals
to 0. so if the reminder is 0
then the number will be an even number
because it is divisible by 2 else it
will be an odd number so that's quite
simple right let's save it and check the
output for 5 it says odd number yeah 5
is of course an odd number right so
that's for even and odd number
so here we have it another program here
it says we have a variable Y and the
value of y is
let's say
eight and
what we are doing here is we are
checking if a number is positive or
negative or zero so we have three
different conditions either number can
be positive or it can be a negative
number Any number greater than 0 is a
positive number right and any number
less than zero is a negative number and
the third one is a number zero it's
neither positive non-negative so let's
check for the number eight save it and
see here you can see it is a positive
number let's see for
minus 2 save it now it says a negative
number for 0 it will say 0.
so these two programs are quite simple
guys right the conditions are pretty
simple we use modulus operator we used
greater than or less than sign and
that's quite easy to use right so let's
move on to the next program which is a
bit tricky than these two
so what we'll do in our next program is
we'll check if a number is positive or
negative and at the same time we'll
check for even an odd also if you are
giving any number as input like let's
suppose we are using five we'll check if
the number is positive or negative and
odd or even so we'll do this
simultaneously let's move on to this
program so there are two ways to check
whether a number is positive or negative
and odd or even
so the two methods we'll discuss them
one by one the first one here is
to use nested if and another one is when
we use logical operators along with the
if else if statement so this one here
you can see right in front of your
screen is
the nested if method so here you can see
we have used the if statement we have
given one more condition inside another
if statement so first it will check
whether a number is positive or not for
X greater than 0 it will check if the
number X is greater than 0 then if yes
if it will find it that yes this number
is greater than 0 then it will move on
to the nested if and it will check for
odd or even
for odd number and even number it will
check if it finds that the number is
even it will print that the number is
positive and even
if the number is not even it will print
the number is positive and odd so here
you can see the difference what The
Interpreter is doing is it will check
for the number as positive and if the
number is positive then it will move on
to the nestative and check for the even
or odd so if it finds that the number is
even it will print positive and even
otherwise it will print positive and odd
then it will move on to the next
condition which is for negative number
if x is less than 0 then it will again
move to the nested if and it will check
for even and odd so if it finds that the
number is even it will print negative
and even otherwise it will print
negative and odd and the last condition
is for the number 0. let's
try to find out the output of this and
what we'll do we'll update the value of
x as 8. so save it now here it says the
positive and even so 8 is a positive
number and even as well let's update the
value of x as minus 5. save it now it
says negative and odd number minus 5 is
a negative odd number right so that's
how it will check for positive
or negative and odd or even so we are
doing both the things simultaneously in
a program we have an alternate method as
well here you can see on your screen we
have written a program and here we have
taken a variable X the functioning of
both the programs is same
both of these program will check for
positive or negative and odd or even
so here you can see I have taken a
variable X let's say the value of x is
7. it will check for X greater than 0
and x mod 2 is equals to equals to zero
so we have four different conditions
right a number is
greater than 0 that means a number is
positive and even a number is positive
and odd a number is negative and even a
number is negative and odd and the final
one is a number is zero okay we have
five conditions and we have to specify
these four conditions here so here we
you can see we are using the logical and
operator this means it will print this
statement let's suppose for this
statement it will print this only if
both the conditions are true right if
the number if the value X is holding is
both greater than 0 and an even number
so if you try to
find out the output now save it and see
here it says number is positive and out
so the number 7 is greater than zero but
the number 7 is not an even number
that's why this line is not there on the
browser it will print this line because
the number is
positive and odd right the switch case
is another conditional control statement
just like the if else control statement
there is a difference between the usage
of if else and switch case statement
now both if else and switch case works
with conditions and we have to choose
when to use which case over if else
switch case is generally preferred over
the if else when there is n number of
test cases present or we can say when we
are working with a lot of conditions
let's say we are working on a program
and you ask the user for an input
between 50 and 100 a numeric input
basically and in the output we have to
print the textual form of that number
suppose if the user enters 75 right the
output will be like this
so what we are doing we we are taking a
number from the user as an input and we
are printing the textual form of that
number right
so we can use the if else or we can say
else if control statement but the
program will be so lengthy and not so
clean
also switch case is much more efficient
than if else when it comes to execution
time like if we have n number of
conditions then using switch case is a
better option we'll get to know why in a
bit so let's move on to the programming
part and today
we'll write a program where we have to
find the month in a year by accepting
its number so we have 12 months in a
year for example if we enter 4 then the
output will be April and if we enter 8
then the output will be August because
August is the eighth month of the year
right so I hope you guys are clear with
the question of course we can do this
program with the help of if else
statement but we discussed earlier that
using IF else in such cases is not
efficient right we can use switch case
in this scenario so let's create a
variable first let's say we are creating
a variable where month and
you can give any value to this variable
from 1 to 12. you can provide it with
any initial value
so let's create a variable first let's
say we are creating a variable where
month and the value we are providing it
one as the hardcore initial value for
Simplicity again we are not taking the
input from the user or from the browser
to do so we have to first go through the
Dom manipulations and we'll go through
it in later videos so let's start with
the switch case now
the Syntax for switch case is quite
simple just write down
switch and
pass the variable month
so we have to check in this round
bracket for the variable month because
you know any value you are providing to
month the switch will check the program
accordingly so for now we have taken the
value as one for month we can take any
value like we can take 3 we can take 11
12 or any value other than 1 to 12 as
well so whatever value you are providing
to the variable you can provide the
variable to the switch statement right
so next up we have an open end curly
braces for the body of the switch case
we have to test for 12 different
conditions inside this
starting from 1 to 12 right so the
syntax goes like this you have to write
case
and then the value month variable might
hold like one two three and so on
followed by a colon right so we have to
write the value 1 and
a colon not a semicolon but a column
keep this thing in mind guys and below
that we are going to write what we want
when the value is 1 like what the output
we want when the value is 1 so we have
to write document
dot right
and
whatever you want as the output like for
one the first month is January so we are
writing here
January
and a semicolon
so if the value of the month is 1 you
will get the output as January save it
and here you can see the output is
January
let me increase the font size for this
as well
so here you can see the output is
January right next we'll use a break
statement
if you guys remember we discussed the
break statement in the control
statements video right the break
statement is not actually a type of
control statement but it assists other
control statements or we can say it
helps us manage the control statements
right what this statement does is once
we are done with the output we get our
output right once we are done with case
1 we get our output as January this
break statement helps us to come out of
the switch case so to understand this
much better let's write here one more
case so let's say we are writing here
one more case as
case 2
and the output will be document dot
right
the second month is February right
and February we can write so
we'll include one break here like we'll
come in the first case and include a
break statement so here's how you can
write a break statement how you can
include a break statement in your code
so let's check the output now so for now
it says January
so if we don't include this break
statement here when The Interpreter will
execute this code
and it will see that the case is 1 right
so it will print January
but it will print other statements as
well so for example if you remove this
break statement and save it now see you
can see here the output as January and
February January and February both are
getting printed on the output so we need
a break statement to break it here see
the value is 1 and if we include break
statement here the moment The
Interpreter finds the answer the correct
answer as January it will come out of
the switch keys
so I hope you guys are getting this
similarly we'll write all the cases for
all the months let me show you all the
cases
so here you can see on your screen that
we have 12 different cases from 1 to 12
one for each month depending on the
value the variable month is holding
right
the output will be June if the value is
6 and if we say 10 the output will be
October and so on and so forth
now the question here is what if we try
to write a random value for the variable
month
by random value we mean that if we try
to write any value other than these 12
values from 1 to 12 if if you leave
these values then if we try to write
another value like if we write here 13.
so what will be the output now let's
save it and see there is no output and
there might be no error for this as well
so if you try to check for an error go
to inspect and check out
see there's no error right so in that
case we have one more case like we have
default case
so let me show you how to include
default in your program what you have to
do is write here default
with a colon and right
document
dot right and let's suppose we are
writing here
wrong input
what is happening is let's try to run
this program first
press Ctrl s and now you can see it says
raw input for value 13.
so what is happening is the switch case
will first check these 12 cases and any
value other than 1 to 12 will get the
output as wrong input it works the same
as the else statement right analysis
statement we don't need to specify any
particular condition any condition other
than the if condition or else if
condition will fall inside the else
statement it's not necessary to add
default in your program it's just if you
want to give the user a prompt that he
has entered a wrong value
so you must include this default case in
your program every time by using switch
gears because it's quite useful you know
okay so this is the complete program to
find out the month by accepting its
number
if you try
six
and save it now it will say June if you
try 10 save it it will say October if we
try 12 save it it will say December so I
hope this is clear to you guys
next up let's discuss about switch case
in detail because the switch case in
JavaScript Works differently from other
languages like switch cases also present
in C plus plus and Java but in
JavaScript it is a bit different so in
JavaScript
switch case can accept numbers it can
accept strings and Boolean values as
well now let's have a look at how the
switch case works with string values
so here is an example of string values
you can see the value variable month is
holding is June right and you can see
use this string in case as well so here
you have to give the case as a string
value right because we are using switch
case statement with
strings so the first case here is when
the value will be June the output should
be sixth month and when the value is
July the output will be seventh month so
let's check it out if this is working or
not let's save this program and see for
June it says sixth month and similarly
we can check it for July as well let's
check for July
save it and see it says seventh month
you can include the default case as well
if you want to it will be similar like
there's no difference for default case
let me show you how
will write here wrong input
save it and now let's try to change the
value here let's say we are using May
save it and see it says wrong input what
if we use a numerical value here let's
try to use two save it now it says wrong
input for 2 as well it will give you the
output when the value is either June or
July
so any other value you try to use here
it will give the output as wrong input
in the same way it works for Boolean
values as well let me show you how it
works for Boolean values so what you
have to do instead of 2 you have to give
here a Boolean value let's suppose you
are writing here true and for true you
have to change the case as well for true
you have to change the output as let's
say for true it the output will be 1.
okay and similarly for false
the output should be
zero
and the output should be wrong input for
any other case right so save it now and
see here for true it says one the output
you can see here is one and if you try
to do the same for false like let's
write here false
and now try to check the output see here
it says 0.
you can see the output is correct right
we will discuss uh our first iterative
control statement that is the for Loop
in JavaScript
so iterative statements or looping
statements we can say are used when we
want to perform an activity multiple
times or n number of times so we don't
have to copy paste that code every time
but we can use iterative statements
using iterative statements we'll make a
code clean and definitely more efficient
so we have four different types of
iterative control statements right we
discussed it in the previous video let's
move on to for Loop which is the first
iterative control statement and we'll
move on to the programming part directly
so before we start one thing to keep in
mind guys is that we use for Loop when
we are clear with the number of
iterations in advance so let's start
with the first program in this program
we will print the multiplication table
of 10 from 10 into 1 to 10 into 10.
let's start with coding
first we write the four keyword and then
we have
three different parts we have the
initialization
which is separated by a semicolon next
up we have the condition
and finally
we have the increment or decrement
so this is the Syntax for for Loop next
up we have the open and the closed curly
braces for the body of for Loop
we'll change these three values
as these are not the actual values right
or parameters for these three different
parts of the loop are going to be
different
so let me comment this one so we'll what
we'll do we'll leave it here only we'll
change it from here so in the
initialization part what we are going to
do is we'll create a variable let's say
we are creating a variable where a and
the value of and the initial value of a
will be 1.
this initialization happens only one
time when the for Loop begins we have to
be careful about the condition we are
going to use because sometimes what
happens is the loop runs forever because
of a wrong condition which will
ultimately crash our program
so in the condition what we have to do
is we have to give a value as in for how
long a for Loop should execute here in
this case we want to print the table of
10 right we want to have 10 iterations
so what it will do it will start from a
equals to n and it will go till this
final condition so let's suppose we are
writing here a less than equals to 10.
it will start from a equals to 1 and it
will go till a less than or equals to 10
and next up we'll use the increment
operator we want to increment the value
of a by 1 every time right so we'll use
increment operator a plus plus or we can
say a equals to A plus 1 both are the
same things right so here the condition
will be like this for variable a equals
to 1 a less than equals to 10 and a plus
plus
so here you can see the loop fill
execute from a equals to 1 till a equals
to 10 and the value will will be
increased by 1 every time because we
have used the increment operator right
next up the body of for Loop will go
like so what we want to print here we
want to print the
table of 10 right so we'll use document
dot right and inside document.red we'll
use the H1 tag
so what we want to do is we want to
print the table of 10 right so we'll
multiply 10 by a
for every iteration the value of a will
be multiplied by 10 and then it will be
printed on the browser so we'll close
the H1 tag here
in the semicolon
so here you can see we have printed 10
into a let's save it and check the
output first and then we'll look at the
execution flow of this program
see here the multiplication table of 10
is printed on the browser you can see 10
20 30 40 so on and so forth till 100. so
what is happening is firstly the for
Loop is also known as the entry control
Loop it means that the condition is
checked initially the first time the for
Loop runs
we perform initialization only once so
here the values stored at variable a is
1. initially the value is 1 next up it
will check for a less than equals to 10
is a which is 1 is 1 less than equals to
10 then true the control will be shifted
to document.write and it will print
10 into the value of a is 1 right so it
will print 10 here
next thing it will go for the increment
and the value of a will be changed to 2
from 1 1 plus 1 or we can say 1 equals
to 1 plus 1 right so it will be 2. now
next thing it will leave this now
because the initialization happens only
once now it will go for the condition
directly now it will check for is 2 less
than or equals to 10 if yes then again
the control will be shifted here and it
will print 10 into 2 because the value
of a is 2 now and after that it it will
print 20 here and after that
the value of a will be increased to 3
because we have used a plus plus then it
will check for 3 is 3 less than 10 and
same thing will happen it will print 30
and so on and so forth till the value of
a is 10. now if the value of a is 10 it
will print 100 right and when the value
is incremented it will become 11.
so what will happen now it will check
for 11 less than equals to 10. no we
know that 11 is not less than equal to
10 right then it comes out of the loop
and it will print nothing after that so
this is the basic working of the for
Loop we'll go through one more program
wherein we'll print the odd numbers
between 1 and 10. so what are odd
numbers odd numbers are those numbers
which are not divisible by two right so
we have the odd numbers as one three
five seven nine and we want to print
them so the difference between each
number is of two the one plus two plus
two plus two till nine right so what we
have to do is we have to write here a
plus equals to 2 we have to increase the
value of a by 2.
and instead of writing here 10 into a
because this time we don't want to print
any multiplication table we want to
print a number only right so we'll use a
only save it and check the output it
says one three five seven nine so these
are the odd numbers present between 1
and 10.
keep one thing in mind that you have to
give the condition wisely every time
so next up we have the while loop like
the for Loop while loop is also an entry
control Loop which means that the
condition will be checked first so the
question here is how while loop is
different from the for Loop if you guys
remember when we discussed that we must
know the exact number of iterations then
only we can use the for Loop right so
the while loop is preferred when we are
not aware of the number of iterations or
we can say we don't know if the
condition will be true for a certain
number of times we'll start with the
programming partner and then we will
discuss more about when to use while
loop over for Loop
so let's start with the program in this
particular program we will print odd
numbers up to a specific number let's
say we want to print all the odd numbers
up to 50.
so we want to print all the odd numbers
from 1 till 50 right
we came across the same program in the
previous video as well but this time we
will use the while loop instead of for
Loop so the Syntax for the while loop is
relatively easy to use the code goes
like we start with the while keyword
then opening and closing round round
brackets and finally the body of while
loop in curly braces
if you guys remember from the previous
video wherein we use the for Loop we had
three different parts right we had the
initialization we had conditions and the
increment decrement part here we have
only one condition and until this
condition holds true the while loop will
be executed for example here we want to
print all the odd numbers from 1 to 50
right so we'll first initialize a
variable
let's initialize a variable first let's
say we have a variable X and the value
of x will be 1.
we used here 1 because 1 is the very
first odd number right after that inside
the condition what we want to do is we
want to print the odd numbers up to 50.
so while the condition will be like
while
X less than equals to 50.
so the loop will go till X is less than
or equals to 50. or we can say x less
than 15 that depends on us if we want to
check for 50 or not so the odd numbers
will go like
1 and then we have 3 then we have 5 then
we have 7 and up to 50. so the last odd
number will be 49 so inside the while
loop we will print the value of x so
here we will print the value of x let's
print it
document dot right
and inside this we will print the value
of x inside the H1 tag
suppose we try to run this program now
it will go on an infinite Loop and the
reason for this is we are not doing
anything to increment the value of x
just like in for Loop if you remember we
had the initialization first we had the
initialization here as well then we had
the condition we have a condition here
as well and then finally it has an
increment or decrement part right so
here we don't have that same increment
or decrement part we have to do it
separately so we'll increment the value
of x here only so here we will write X
plus equals to 2 or we can say it is
same as x equals to X plus 2 you guys
are aware of it right so the reason is
simple because we want to go from 1 to 3
to 5 and so on that's why we use X plus
equals to 2. we incremented the value of
x by 2.
save it here and let's check the output
so here you can see it says one three
five seven nine and so on and so forth
till 49 so 49 is the last odd number
before 50 because we are checking
between 1 and 50 right so 49 is the last
odd number let me show you how the
program goes into an infinite Loop so
for that what we have to do we will
comment this whole line here let's check
the output now save it and here you can
see it is refreshing forever and this is
basically how a program in an infinite
Loop looks like the output of this
program is the program will ultimately
crash so what we have to do we have to
open a new tab and then again we have to
run the program with correct increment
part so here you can see you can wait
for it to become responsive or exit the
page so here you can see we have all the
odd numbers from 1 up to 50 and the last
one is 49. coming back to the difference
between the while loop and the for Loop
we did the same program previously right
using the for Loop so where to use while
loop over for Loop so consider a
scenario where we are taking input from
the user and the input from the user is
y we want to do something let's say we
want to print something on the screen or
if the input from the user is n we want
the process to be stopped we can give
the condition in the while loop which
will go like when the character y
becomes n the process will be stopped
we'll go through one such program once
we are done with the Dom manipulation
part wherein we take the input from the
user let's move on to the do while loop
in JavaScript
in the previous videos we have already
discussed that both for Loop and the
while loop are entry control Loop that
means the conditions are checked first
right but the do while loop is a bit
different or we can say it is an exit
control Loop wherein the condition is
checked after the execution of the loops
body thus an exit control loop executes
at least once even if the test condition
fails or we can say the condition is
wrong the loop will execute once using
the do while loop is relatively easy it
seems like we are giving the system a
command to do something while the
condition is something
so let's start with the syntax now
the syntax goes like this we write the
keyword do and we have a pair of curly
braces for the body of the loop and
after that we have the while keyword and
here we'll write the condition
make sure you are using the semicolon
after the while loop it's necessary
while using do while loop keep this
thing in mind
so we have two parts in the Dual Loop
the do part and the while part or we can
say the condition part while part is the
part where we write the condition
so let's Define a variable first let's
say we are using a variable we are using
a variable X and the value of x will be
5.
so here we have taken 5 as a random
value you can take 1 as well now inside
the condition part of the do while loop
this is the condition part where we are
using the while keyword so we'll give a
condition let's say we are using while X
greater than 5 it will check for the
condition that if the value of x is
greater than 5. or if the value of x is
smaller than or equal to 5 it will come
out of the loop in the do part we will
write what we want to do let's say we
want to print a single sentence here we
write document.write
and whatever sentence we want to write
let's say we are using
welcome to
simply code so here you might be
thinking that the condition is false but
the condition will be checked after the
first iteration in the do while loop so
no matter what the condition is the
first iteration will happen always so if
we try to save this program and let's
try to run this here you can see the
output is welcome to Simply code a
single line is printed
what is happening here is although the
condition we used was wrong but the
condition will be checked only after the
first iteration when the Dual Loop will
perform this particular statement when
the document.write will be performed
after that it will check for the
condition if x is greater than 5 or not
if we use a 6 instead of 5. let's try to
write here 6 instead of 5 and if we run
this program now it will go into an
infinite Loop because we are not
performing the increment decrement
operator here right as we have discussed
in the previous videos the importance of
increment decrement part so we need to
do it here after the document.right part
so what we'll do here we'll write x
minus minus today we are using x minus
minus and for the other two Loops we use
the plus increment operator right so the
x minus minus is the same as x equals to
x minus 1. let's check the output now
save it here you can see the output is
still welcome to Simply code the
execution flow of this program will be
like it will first perform the iteration
before checking the condition and it
will print here welcome to Simply code
for the first time when the loop will
start executing it will first perform
this statement and it will write here
welcome to Simply code
so then it will perform x minus minus
means the value of x is now 5 because we
are decrementing the value by 1. so when
the value of x is 5 then it will check
for the condition if x is greater than 5
or not so here we can see clearly X is
not greater than 5 because x equals to 5
n it is equals to 5 right so it will
come out of the loop
let's make few changes in the code here
suppose we use here 10 instead of 6 now
and let's print the value of x as well
it will be easy for you to understand so
we'll print here x and we'll use a
space so that it will be clear for you
we'll use here the BR tag and now let's
try to run this program here you can see
the output goes from 10 to 6 and it
prints welcome to simplicode every time
right if you guys are wondering where we
use the do while loop sometimes it may
happen that even though the condition is
false but we have to execute that
command we use the do I Loop when we
want the code to Output some sort of
menu to the user or to generate the menu
at least once will get to know about the
do while loop in future videos when we
create a program specifically for the
Dual Loop this video is just a syntax
demonstration we'll go through the
examples of all the three Loops present
in JavaScript so today we have three
different problems
for three separate Loops right we'll go
through each of the problems and we'll
discuss the execution flow for each Loop
we'll go through so let's start this
session with the first problem statement
so the first problem statement goes like
this so here we have to write a program
to check whether a number is prime or
not I hope you guys are aware of what
prime numbers are right so a prime
number is a positive number that is only
divisible by 1 and itself for example 2
3 5 and we have 7 and 11 these are the
first few prime numbers right if we take
an example let's say we are taking an
example of 7 so 7 is a number which is
divisible by 1 and 7 only no other
number can divide 7 right so here in
this code we have to check whether up
number is prime or not so let me take
you through the code
so here is the code to check whether a
number is a prime number or not let me
take you through this first so we have a
variable number and the value of
variable number can be any random value
like any number you want to check if the
number is prime number or not you can
give that value to the variable number
so here we have taken 83 next up we have
a variable is prime whose value is a
Boolean value right it can be true for a
prime number or it can be false for a
non-prime number so we have used
comments in this program to make it
easier for you guys to understand so
here we have used the if statement to
check if the number is 1 because we know
that 1 is neither a prime number nor a
composite number right so we have to
check if the user enters the value 1 or
if we are giving the value 1 we have to
check for it so if user enters the value
1 it will print this statement that one
is neither prime nor composite
here in else if we are checking if the
value of number is greater than 1 or not
so if the value of number is greater
than 1 the control will be shifted to
for Loop present inside the elsif
statement right here you can see we have
the for Loop here the control will be
shifted to this for Loop so here you can
see we have initialized the variable I
and the initial value is set to 2 that's
because any prime number is divisible by
1 as well right so it won't make any
sense to include one here will start
from 2 and we'll check until the value
of I becomes half of the value of number
so if we take an example of 10 we'll
check until 5 because you know any
number greater than 5 won't divide 10
right it's practically not possible so
we'll check for number by 2 or we can
say we'll check till 5 only and the
value will be increased by 1 every time
till now I hope you guys are aware of
how to use for Loop and why we are using
for Loop here we can do the same program
using while loop as well but to make it
more clear how to use for Loop we are
doing this program with the help of for
Loop so then we have the I plus plus or
we can say we have increased the value
of I by 1 after every iteration until
the value of I becomes
half of the number
so the condition number percent I equals
to equals to 0. so here is the main
condition to check if the number is
divisible by I or not
so the execution will be like if we are
taking here a number 10 it will start
from 2 and it will check if the
remainder is 0 or not so if the
remainder is 0 then the value of is
prime will be changed to false and it
will come out of the loop
next it will check for the value of is
prime if the value of S Prime is true or
not here you can see if the value of S
Prime is true then it will print n or we
can say then it will print that the
number is a prime number else it will
print that the number is not a prime
number if the value of is prime is false
for example when we took the example of
number as 10 so the value of S Prime
will be changed to false because you
know 10 divides by 2 is equals to 0 or
we can say the remainder will be 0 so
the value of S Prime will be changed to
false and for false it will print number
is not a prime number
so at last we will check if the number
is less than 1 if the number entered by
the user or any other number we have
taken like if we take a minus 5 so it
will print the number is not a prime
number
Because by the usual definition of prime
numbers any negative number cannot be a
prime number that's a usual definition
right so we have to keep this thing in
mind and here in this else Loop we'll
print that if any negative number is
entered we'll make sure that the program
gives the output that the number is not
a prime number
so let's try to run this program and
check the output let's save this program
and the output says 83 is a prime number
as 83 is not divisible by any number
except 1 and 83. for example if we take
here any number which is divisible by so
let's say we are taking 75 save it now
and see it says 75 is not a prime number
okay here's a spelling mistake it says
75 is a not prime number so here we'll
correct this
is
so we are done with it and save it now
now it says 75 is not a prime number s75
is divisible by numbers other than 1 and
itself right it is divisible by 3 it is
divisible by 5 15 and 25 as well all
these numbers divide 75 basically so
let's take a different value here
let's say we are taking minus 7.
let's change the value here as or we can
take it as minus 75 let's save it now so
it says the number is not a prime number
or if we want to try for one as well
let's take it as 1
and let's check the output now so it
says 1 is neither prime nor composite
number because we have given here the
condition if number is equals to is
equals to 1 then it will print that one
is neither a prime nor a composite
number
you can try this program with the help
of other Loops as well so let's move on
to the second problem statement but
before that let me take you through the
same program using the while loop so
here you can see we have used the file
Loop for the same instead of for Loop
here you can see we have used while I
less than a number by 2 and we have
given the increment condition here and
we have initialized the value of I
at the start of the program so if we try
to run this program it will give us the
same output there will be no change in
the output so we can use while loop as
well so we'll use the while loop in
other program
let's move on to the second problem
statement so in this example we'll learn
to write a program in JavaScript to
check whether a number is an Armstrong
number or not
so we'll do this with the help of while
loop let's have a look at how to
implement this program before proceeding
to the coding part let's have a look at
what is an Armstrong number so an
Armstrong number of three digits is in
integer such that the sum of the cubes
of its digits is equal to the number
itself
so for example 153 is in Armstrong
number since 1 into 1 into 1 it means
the cube of the digit 1 plus the cube of
5 that is 5 into 5 into 5 which is equal
to 125 and the cube of 3 which is three
threes are Nine and Nine threes are 27
so it will go like 125
plus 27 plus 1 so which is equal to 153
so an Armstrong number of three digits
is an integer such that the sum of the
cubes of its digits is equal to the
number itself so here we have the code
for the same this is the code to check
whether the number is an Armstrong
number or not
so here we have taken a variable and the
value is 153 the value of the variable
number is 153 right because we already
know that 153 is an Armstrong number
there are few more numbers like 3 7 1 is
also an Armstrong number next up we have
taken a variable sum and the initial
value of sum is 0. we have used the
variable sum to store the value of the
cubes and next up we have a temporary
variable so that we can break a three
digit number and we need the number
after all this all this program all
these loops and all will need the number
we'll need the original number to
compare it with the sum of the cubes
which will be hold in sum so but we need
to break the number as well right so we
need a temporary variable to break it
here we use the while loop and the loop
will run until the value of variable
temp is greater than zero so the initial
value of temp will be 153 here in this
particular case the initial value will
be one five three and the loop will run
until the value of 153 is greater than
0. next up we have a variable remainder
that stores the last digits value as we
are dividing 153 by 10. so
the remainder here will be 3 so the
value save that variable remainder will
be 3 for the first time then what will
happen when we are updating the value of
sum and the MU value of sum will be 0
plus 3 into 3 into 3 so 3 3's are Nine
and Nine threes are 27 so the updated
value of sum will be 27 next up we are
removing the last digit from the number
so for example we have here one five
three and if we divide 1 5 3 by 10 the
answer will be 1 5.3 that's why we are
using here percent because what percent
will do it will convert the float value
into an integer so if we try to perform
a simple divide in JavaScript like if we
try to divide 153 by 10 it will give us
1 5.3 it will give us a float value but
we want an integer value right so
percent will
change this value to the nearest integer
so 1 5.3 the nearest integer will be 1 5
so the new value of temp will be one
five then again this Loop will be
executed and for this time the variable
reminder will hold the value of 15
modulus 10 and the remainder will be 5
right
so the new value of remainder is 5 and
the value of sum is 27 plus 5 into 5
into 5 which is 27 plus 125 right so the
new value of sum will be 152.
and then again it will go to the temp
and it will divide 15 by 10 and it will
change the value to an integer so 1.5
will be changed to 1 and next up the
final value of temp is 1 which is
greater than 0 right so it will divide
10 by 1 and the remainder will be 1.
so next up it will add 152 plus 1 into 1
into 1 that is 153 right and then it
will divide 1 by 10 using the percent
but this time the value will be 0
because there is no remainder right
next up we'll compare the value of the
sum and the number variable so the sum
variable here it is holding the value as
153. we break this number into three
different parts then we took the cube of
these three number and added them so the
final value of the variable sum is 153
and the initial value of number or we
can say the value we gave to the
variable number is 153 so right it will
print here that 153 is an Armstrong
number or if we use any other number
instead of 153 let's suppose we are
using 121 so it will print 121 is not an
Armstrong number let's check out the
output ones let's save it and see the
output a is one five three is an
Armstrong number so if we change the
value of one five three two
one two one
so let's check the output now it says 1
to 1 is not an Armstrong number why
because if we take the cube of each of
the digit and we'll add them suppose the
answer here will be 10 because the cube
of 1 is 1 and the cube of 2 is 8 and the
cube of the final one is 1 so 8 plus 1
plus 1 is equals to 10. so that's why
one two one is not an Armstrong number
let's move on to our last problem
statement where we'll use the do while
loop to find the factorial of a number
so here's the problem statement where
we'll have to write a program to find
the factorial of a number
so factorial of an integer is the
product of an integer and all the
integers below it or we can say before
it till 1 so if we take an example of 5.
so the factorial of 5 will be
it will multiply each number before it
if we take 5 the factorial will be 5
into 4 into 3 into 2 into 1. or if we
don't include one that's totally fine
so this program is pretty simple as
compared to the previous two video
so this is a small one two let me take
you through this so here we have the
program
and here we have three variables right
we have a variable I which is
initialized as 1 then we have a variable
n which is 5 and then we have a variable
F whose value is 1 f is 4 factorial and
n is for number we want to check the
factorial of and I is for checking the
condition
so here what we will do we'll use a loop
where if we for example if we are taking
5 then the loop will go from 1 into 2
into 3 into 4 into 5 from 1 to that
number it's not like if we are using
from 5 towards one but we are going from
1 towards five the answer will be same
right because we are multiplying all the
numbers in both the cases
so here we took 5 as the number next up
we have a variable F and the value of f
is also one as you know
so here we are using the do while loop
for the first iteration it will perform
this so the value of f for the first
iteration will be f equals to F into I
which means f equals to 1 into 1 which
is one so the value of I will be
increased and it will become 2 and now
it will check for while 2 is less than
equals to n yes 2 is less than n so it
will again go up and it will update the
value of F and the new value of of f
will be 1 into 2 that is 2 then again
the value will be increased and it will
become 3 and then it will
change the value of
f as well if it will become 6 and the
value of I will become 4 then it will
check if 4 is less than 5 yes 4 is less
than 5 and then it will multiply 4 with
6 because the value of f for 6 right so
4 into 6 it will become 24 and then
finally the value of I will be 5 and it
will check if the value of I is less
than or equals to 5 right while I is
less than equals to 5 yes that's true
because now 5 is equals to 5 and it will
again execute the loop and the value of
f will be 24 into 5 which is 120 and
then again the value of I will be
increased now it will become 6 which is
greater than 5 so it will come out of
the loop and it will print the factorial
of a number so let's save this program
so the factorial of 5 is 120. because
see here we have used the factorial of
n n is 5 and the factorial is 120 so if
we try to give any other number here
other than 5 let's say we are using here
10 save it it says the factorial is
three six two double eight double zero
or it's 36 lakh 28 800. so if you try to
multiply 10 into 9 into 8 into 7 so
until 2 or we can say 1 the answer will
be this you can check it you can Google
it or you can go through it in your
calculator
the typical definition of function
states that to work in a proper or in a
particular way
similarly functions in JavaScript are a
block of code that is used to perform a
specific task
in this particular video we will go
through the syntax and usage of
functions so a function has a particular
name and we can reuse that block of code
again and again in our entire program
for example let's suppose that we have
to add two numbers in a program that's a
basic program right sum of two numbers
so let's write the code first so we are
going to take a variable X and the value
of x will be 10. and then again we are
going to take a variable Y and the value
of y will be 5.
lastly we are going to take a variable
total and the value of total will be X
Plus y
so the last thing we are going to do is
we are going to print this on a browser
so here we are we are done with our
program we are done with adding two
numbers so let's save it and check the
output see the output here says 15. so
what is happening is
the value of x plus Y which is 10 plus 5
is stored in the variable total and we
are displaying total on a browser
so that's a very basic program right now
consider a scenario where we have to do
this addition for n number of times at
different intervals so we have to
perform the same task of addition at
different intervals so in that case what
we can do is we can copy paste this same
code repeatedly but the length of the
program will increase because of that
right and it doesn't make any sense to
copy paste the same code again and again
so this is where functions come into
play with the help of functions we can
create a separate function to do this
particular task and we can call that
function again and again I'll take you
through it so basically a function has
three parts we'll go through each of
them a function has function declaration
then it has function definition and then
finally it has function calling
so we'll perform this same program of
adding two numbers we'll add two numbers
but this time we'll use the concept of
functions so we'll use this whole code
we are going to use it inside the
function so let's move on and see how
the function looks like how the syntax
of function looks like
so we use the keyword function
and then we have the function name
so let's suppose here we are naming the
function as sum
then we have the opening and closing
round brackets which denotes that this
is a function this is the way to write a
function next up we have a pair of curly
braces for the body of the function so
this is the basic syntax of how a
function looks like the naming
convention for functions is the same as
we had for variables in JavaScript if
you guys remember we have already
discussed this naming Convention of
variables
so this is the basic structure of a
function
so now we'll cut this whole code
and we'll
paste it here inside the function
right so we are done with it we are done
with our functions first part first we
declared a function with name sum then
we are done with the definition of
function
now what if we try to run this program
let's save this program and see it is
not printing anything on screen but if
you try to check out for any errors it
won't show any errors see there is no
error in this program this is happening
because we haven't called the function
yet right so to call the function we
have to write the single word just write
sum with opening and closing round
brackets and save it now now you can see
the output here is 15. so this is known
as function calling the program already
knows that there is a function by the
name sum it will go and check for the
same if the function is there or not if
the program finds it it will execute the
function next up a function can also
have parameters what do I mean by
parameters is we don't have to declare
these variables variable X and variable
y here instead of declaring them here we
can pass these values to the function
let's say we are passing X and Y here or
we can pass A and B any variable you
want to pass you can pass it here
now we can remove this variable X and
variable y we have to write here where
because we still need the variable total
and next up we have to pass the value
for these variables when we call the
function so we have to pass the values
here let's say we are passing the values
as 4 and
3.
so let's try to run this program now and
see if it works let's save it and see
you can see here the output as 7.
we can also pass strings over here so
instead of 4 if we try to pass any
string let's say we are passing
welcome to
and instead of 3
will pass simply code right now let's
save this program and see the output it
says welcome to Simply code we don't
have to worry about the data type we'll
use here because JavaScript is a Loosely
typed language right so the function
will automatically adapt to the data
type according to the value we will pass
during the function call
here in this code
variable X holds the value welcome to
and the variable Y is having simplicode
allocated to them dynamically so this is
what is known as parameter passing in
functions let's move on and discuss the
return types in functions so a function
can also return a value right now we can
see that a function is doing the
printing task what if we remove this
document dot right from here and we'll
paste it somewhere else on the program
outside the function so we'll paste it
here right now the function will perform
addition only it won't print anything it
will just perform the addition let's
save this and see there is nothing so if
we try to check for error it says total
is not defined because total is defined
inside the function this is because of
the concept of local and Global variable
we'll discuss this concept in upcoming
video
so here you can see it says total is not
defined right so now what we have to do
is we have to write here return
total
so now the function will return the
value of total outside
what this return statement does is
whenever we call the function as you can
see here we are calling the function
from outside and we are passing the
parameters as welcome to end simply code
right
so these parameters will go as X and Y
and we are getting the concatenation of
Welcome to Simply code
right so when this return statement
comes into function the value of this
total variable will be given out of the
function so there has to be a particular
variable to hold the value returned by
the function
will use a variable here let's say we
are using the variable output
and in the rhs we are calling the
function so we have an equals to between
the LHS and rhs that's because when we
are calling the function it will return
a value and the assignment is done from
right to left in the case of an
assignment operator if you guys remember
we came across this that whenever we are
using an assignment operator the
assignment will be done from right
towards the left so whatever value the
function will return upon calling will
be assigned to the variable output
in this program we are passing welcome
to and simply code right so let's change
these two values now we'll change them
to a numerical value let's say we are
using here
and instead of Simply code we'll use a
15 and we are going to print here output
on the browser because the variable
output is holding the value returned by
the function right so let's save it now
and see the output is 50.
okay guys so this was the syntax
demonstration of functions in JavaScript
with a quick small program we already
know that JavaScript is a Loosely typed
scripting language right that means we
don't need to specify the data types
every time
so a variable is basically a container
that can store data values those values
can be changed whenever needed in this
particular video we are going to discuss
the scope of variables in JavaScript so
what does this scope mean in variables
so scope refers to the life of a
variable in a program
there are basically two types of
variables present in JavaScript local
variables and Global variables
depending upon where we are creating a
variable a variable may have two
different types of scope so let's have a
look at these two different types of
variables with the help of examples
let's say we are creating a variable
here let's say we are creating a
variable where a and the value of a will
be 5. so we have created a variable here
and let's print the value of this
variable in the browser so what we'll do
we'll print this value in the browser
so let's print the value of this
variable on the browser so here we have
printed the value of variable a so here
you can see the value is 5. so we can
print the value of this variable anytime
and anywhere in our program right so if
we try to copy this line from here and
we'll paste it somewhere else in a
program let's say we are pasting it here
so if we try to save it now see here you
can see that we have two values of a
because we have printed a twice here
right once we have used this a here then
we have used this a here so here you can
see we have two values of a 5 and 5. so
this variable a is a global variable
which means its life is available
throughout the entire program or the
entire script we can see
and when we declare a variable inside a
function that variable is known as a
local variable for that function so
let's try to do it as well we already
know what functions are as we saw in the
previous video right so what we'll do
we'll make a function here let's say we
are creating a function
my function
opening and closing round bracket and
the body of the function right so let's
declare a variable here let's say we are
using a variable where X and the value
of x will be 10 right let's try to print
this value
so we have created a function here now
we are left with the function call only
so let's call the function here
what we'll do we'll call my function
right
save it and now here you can see the
output is 10 5 and 5. so if we comment
these three lines if we remove these
three lines and we'll save it now so
here you can see we have the output as
10 only so this variable X which is
declared inside a function so why it is
a local variable because if we try to
access this variable from outside the
function it is not possible so let's
cut this line from here and let's try to
paste it here so now what we are doing
is we are trying to access this variable
from outside the function let's save it
now
let's save this program now and see the
there is no output in the browser
because a local variable can be accessed
only in that function we can't access it
from outside of the function
so this is happening because as soon as
the function is executed the variable
gets destroyed means there is no
variable present in the memory now the
same thing applies to the memory
whenever we run a JavaScript program the
whole browser is present in the ram
or we can say in the memory so these
local variables are created only till
the function is executing once the
function is done running the same
function wipes out of the memory
whereas the case is different for Global
variables so Global variables are
available throughout the script they
have a global lifetime which means that
they will exist throughout the programs
running
or we can say until the tab is open the
next exciting thing about global
variables is that we can access Global
variables from inside the function so
what we will do
let's
cut this line from here
and we'll paste it
here so now what we will do we'll
declare a variable here let's say we are
declaring a variable where Y and the
value of y will be 15.
so copy this line
and paste it again now what we'll do
we'll try to access y from inside the
function
so let's save the program and see the
output here is 10 and 15. 10 is the
value of x and x is a local variable for
function my function because we have
declared X inside the function whereas
variable Y is a global variable we have
declared it outside the function and we
tried to access it from inside of the
function right so we tried to access y
here and we can see the value of y is 15
which is printed on the browser this is
what Global variables are one more
exciting thing I want to mention at the
end of this video is if we declare any
variable in JavaScript without using the
where keyword so if we try to declare a
variable here let's say we are declaring
where one okay we have not used any
where keyword so what we are doing is we
are declaring a variable and the value
of where 1 is 15. so we don't need the
where keyword separately when we are
declaring a variable however some of the
newer versions of web browser have some
sort of issue if we try to declare a
variable inside this function without
using the where keyboard so let's try to
access this variable let's try to access
let's declare it inside the function
okay what we will do is we'll declare
this variable inside the function and
we'll comment this line and what we'll
do is we'll try to access it from
outside the function right
what we'll do is
we'll write here where one
save this
and see if you don't understand it let
me change the value of where one let's
change this value to 20 save it now and
see the output here is 10 and 20. so
where one is a variable which is
declared without using the where keyword
right so we can access this variable
from outside the function as well any
variable which is declared without using
where keyword is a global variable keep
this thing in mind guys we came across
the different types of data types
present in JavaScript in the previous
video where we came across the types of
primitive data types in JavaScript we
discussed number string and we had
Boolean null and undefined right so
these are the five types of
primitive data types present in
JavaScript
we know that strings in any programming
language are used to store and
manipulate textual value a string
contains a sequence of characters
written inside double quotes
so let's declare a basic string here
let's say we have a variable
and we have a variable as where X and
the value of x will be a basic string
let's say we have high there as the
value
okay
next thing we'll print this on a browser
document.write and will print x on a
browser
so this here is a string that holds a
textual value right suppose we try to
find the type of the variable X so I
hope you guys are aware of that if you
are not then please go through the
previous video on data types in
JavaScript let's print this value on
browser first
so here you can see it says hi there so
this is a string and let's try to
determine the type of variable X and
we'll see if it returns a string or
something else we'll do it with the help
of type of operator right I hope you
guys remember that so let's try to use
type of operator here
and here we'll use
type of x
so let's save it and see
here you can see we have a string as the
type of variable X so strings are
helpful for holding data that can be
represented in textual form so let's
move on to our first topic for today and
that is escape sequence in JavaScript so
if you guys ever noticed that in the
previous few videos we use a lot of HTML
tags in JavaScript right for example we
use the heading tag so often like when
we are using the document.write to print
anything on the browser we use heading
tag quite a lot right so the thing to
notice here is that these tags behaves
as HTML tags right we use them inside
the double inverted commas just like
strings but they still act like HTML
tags so let's understand this with the
help of an example what we'll do is
we'll remove this code we'll print a
simple
statement in a browser so we'll use
document.write and we'll write here hi
there and we'll use a
tag
right so a basic HTML tag we are going
to use
let's say we are using the brake tag I
hope you all are aware of the brake tag
so the next sentence will be
so here in this example we try to print
a sentence and we are using the BR tag
right so let's print it on the browser
so we are using the Break Tag in between
the sentences we have hi there and we
have welcome to Simply code
so we use this Break Tag in a string
right so the output what we were
expecting was hi there and the BR should
be returning
string but there's a difference in the
output right the BR tag is actually
functioning as an HTML tag
so here the Break Tag works the same as
it did for HTML so with this we can
conclude that if we try to infuse any
HTML tag inside the JavaScript statement
it will act as that tag only
so let's move on and we'll look at some
other types of Escape characters present
in JavaScript
so let's say we want to print this line
okay we'll edit this one only so what we
will do is we'll remove this brake tag
and suppose we want to print this on
screen so we want this on our screen and
we want the welcome to be inside the
double inverted comma in output as well
so if we try to run this program now
there will be nothing
in the browser let's try to check if it
gets any error so here it says uncut
syntax error it says missing after the
argument list so how to print this on
the browser we want to highlight the
word welcome so if we try to run this
program as it is it's not working right
to do this type of task we have the
backslash Escape character
to print the double quotes inside a
string we use a single backslash with a
double inverted comma if the syntax is
we have to use this backslash before the
double inverted comma so now if we try
to print this on browser here you can
see it says hi there and welcome is
written within double inverted commas
right so that's how you can print this
on a screen next up if you want to use a
single inverted comma we have to use a
single backslash with a single inverted
comma so just like we did here with the
double inverted comma similarly we can
do it for single inverted comma as well
what we'll do is we'll copy this
document dot right and we'll print it
here
so here what we will print is
we'll print here it's all right okay
so we are using here a backslash with a
single inverted comma Now we will write
a s
the output will be it's all right
so
we have to use them because
we need them in a program at times right
so to avoid any confusion one must know
how to use this sequence character in
JavaScript let's save this and see if we
try to comment this line
let me comment this to make it more
easier for you to understand let's save
it now and see it says it's all right
you can't print it in similar way
without using the backslash Escape
character lastly if we want to put a
backslash in our string if we want to
put a backslash we want to show it in
the browser so the Syntax for that will
go like
we have the document dot right right so
here we will write
the character
and we'll use two backslashes is called
backslash
so let's try to print this so here one
thing you can note is
only a single backslash is printed on
the browser the first one is used as a
backslash Escape character and second
one which we have used will be printed
on the browser
we have a few more escape sequence
present in JavaScript like the backslash
and or we can say new line we don't use
them quite often I'll let you know if we
use them in future so for now it's
enough for escape sequences present in
JavaScript so let's move on and now
we'll go through the different string
Methods present in JavaScript
so there are several string Methods
present in JavaScript we are going to
discuss a few in this particular video
and we have a property as well
so here you can see it on your screen
now these are the string Methods present
in JavaScript the first one here that is
length it is a property and the rest are
string method
so let's start this video with the
length property you can pause the video
to note down all the string Methods and
property or you can just take a
screenshot of it
so let's move on to the programming part
now the length properties used to find
the actual length of a string so to find
the length of a string let's declare a
string first and then we'll find out the
length of that string so the statement
will go like this we have a variable Str
and the value of Str will be let's say
welcome
to Simply code okay
so here we have a string and we have a
variable a which holds the length of
this string
right
so
this Str dot length is a property of
string and it will return the actual
length of this string so what we'll do
is we'll print
document dot right and we'll print the
value of V because the variable a is
holding the actual length of string Str
so let's try to print this and here you
can see the output is 21.
so if you count the total number of
characters present in this particular
string it will come out as 90. 7 for
Welcome 2 for
2 and 10 for simply code right so the
total number of characters are 19 so the
remaining two are the spaces present
between welcome into this one space and
the other space is this
so the total comes out to be 21 so this
is how the length property of string
works if we want to find out the number
of characters present in a string we can
simply use the Str dot length property
and it will give us the exact number of
characters including spaces as well
so next up
we have the two methods which are tool
over case and the two uppercase methods
so this two lowercase method is quite
simple to use the functionality of this
method is it can change the whole string
to lower case characters irrespective of
what is already written in the string so
let's try this method and you can
understand it much better
so here what we'll do is we'll replace
this Str dot length with DOT to
lowercase
and we'll see if the output is changed
here
so let's try to run this
and here you can see each of the
characters present in the string is
changed to lower case alphabets so you
can see we have W and SS upper case so
what we'll do is
we'll write welcome in uppercase here
let's say we have welcome in uppercase
and now we will save it so here you can
see the welcome is also in lower case so
every character present in the string is
converted to lower case
the case with two uppercase is a bit
different so if we try to write here
to uppercase and now if we run this
program
so every character present in the string
will be changed to uppercase letter so
here you can see we have simply code in
lower cases now here in the output it is
changed to uppercase letters if you guys
noticed that we use the length property
previously right but we didn't use the
opening and closing round brackets there
but we are using them with uppercase and
lowercase methods right that's the
difference between property and methods
next up we have the includes method so
this functional method is used to find
something particular in our program so
this function either returns true or
false if we want to check if a
particular word is available in a string
or not we can use the includes method
so this is a case sensitive method which
means that it differentiates between
uppercase and lowercase letters so let's
try this function here and we will
search for a word here
let's say we are searching for
2 right so instead of uppercase we are
writing here includes and we are looking
for two
so 2 here exists in a sentence right it
exists in a string so it will return
true for this case let's save it and
check the output C it says true but if
we try to find something like let's try
to find here from and we'll save it see
it says false if we try to find a
something else like we try to find your
code save it and it says true because
code exists in a string but if we try to
write here code with a capital D
see it says false because it is a case
sensitive method right next up we have
the starts with and ends with function
so these are used to check the initial
and final words present in JavaScript
for example let's try to use here starts
with first what we'll do instead of
includes will right here starts with
right
it will return false for any value other
than welcome or W whatever we are
writing so if we write here anything
other than this welcome
it means that we can write here w w e l
w e l c o m e or we can write here welc
so anything other than that if we write
here 2 let's say let's save it now and
see it says false why this is happening
because if the searched item matches the
first word
suppose if we try to write here
well okay so these are the four initial
letters of a string let's save it now
and now we can see that it says true
because if the searched item matches the
first word then only it will return true
otherwise the value will be false see
here it returned false for 2. and for
welc it returned true
the same goes for the ends with method
so let's try to use ends with instead of
starts with
and here we try code so here what we'll
do is
instead of starts with Will right here
ends with and we know that the last four
characters of a string are code
right so we'll write here code
or let's say we'll write here
simply
save it and it says false because it is
checking for the last four volts so if
we write here simply code and save it it
will return true only if the last four
letters are included which are present
in the string so if we write here
code instead of Simply code then also it
will return true because codes are the
last four letters or characters present
in simply code right next up we have the
search function so the search function
works almost the same as includes method
the only difference between these two is
the include method Returns the Boolean
value
meaning if it finds out that the word is
present in the string it will return
either true or false right the case is
slightly different for the search method
it Returns the exact position of the
word if the word exists in this string
else it returns -1 as the answer so
let's try to find out the word 2 in this
string here or we can change the string
let's change the string here so we are
going to use a different string
let's say we are using this string right
so we'll copy it from here and we'll
paste it here but we'll not use this
backslash sign so let's try to use here
the search method
and what we'll try to find out in this
string is let's say we are trying to
find out is
okay so we have the is in a string so
let's save it and see it says 14 14 is
the
index number of is it starts from 0 like
0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 and at
number 14 is is present so it will print
14 on the browser
that's how we can use the search method
in JavaScript so next up we have the
index of method used to find the index
of a particular word
so let's try to use the index of method
now so what will happen is as soon as it
finds the word
is it will
return the index value right so if we
try to write here
index
of
is and we'll save it see it says 14
because we know 14 is also returned by
the search method because they both are
doing the same thing actually so if we
try to write here instead of is let's
say we are writing a called
save it now and it says 17. so 14 was I
15 and then we have a space at 16 and
from 17 called is started so it will
return the index number index value of
that word
if we have two similar words present in
our strings
let's suppose we have one is here as
well
right so we have 2 is now
and or we can say called we have two
called right so save it then also it
will return 17.
because as soon as it finds out that the
word called is present in the string it
will print that on the browser it won't
check for other word other similar word
it won't check for the second cold so
the search and the index of methods
works almost the same the following
method we are going to use is the last
index of method so it works the same as
the index of the only difference is if
we try
to use this last index of method it will
start checking from the last so
the output for this code will be a
little bit different so let's
try to find out the output
and then we will check
it says 17 because if you try to check
it from here 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12
13 14 15 16. 70. so here you can see it
it says 17 because when it started
checking it will start checking from the
last of the string so that's why we are
using a last index of and we know the
working of this method as well till now
we came across a lot of string Methods
and we have a lot more string Methods
still remaining so we'll go through them
at once let me take you through them at
once before we end this video
so here is the list of all the remaining
functions let me take you through all of
them one by one the first function here
is the replace function so here you can
see we have the replace keyword here so
this is a new function we are going to
discuss about so replace function is
used to replace something from the
string for example in this first example
we have replaced here 2 with from right
so this is the syntax of how to use the
replace function and what we did is we
replace the word to with from
so
we'll remove this 2 from here and save
it now so here you can see it says
welcome from Simply code it replace the
word to with from right
so here I have taken two examples that's
because if we write here two once again
so let's save it now here you can see it
changed the first two only because it
has two similar words right it has two
here it has two here as well so what it
did is it changed the first two but the
second two is still the same so that's
why I have used this example here this
is the basic syntax using which it will
search for the word globally and change
it every time it finds the word so we'll
discuss about it in later videos for now
you can see if we use this globally
what's happening is when it traverses
the string it will find the word is
twice and it will change the word is to
from right so here you can see we have
two similar words we have is here and
here as well so both of them are changed
in the output so that's how the replace
function works
let's move on to our next function next
up we have the concat method so we'll
remove it and now we'll have a look at
the concat method so the concat method
is used to concatenate two strings
basically so here you can see we have
two strings we have that str2 and we
have where str3 the value where str2
holding is Javascript was developed by
Brendan Ike and the other string is in
the year 1995. so this is the syntax of
how we concatenate two strings so here
you can see we have concatenated string
3 to string two so string 2 Dot concat
and in bracket whatever string we want
to concat if we want to concatenate more
than one string then also we can use it
here we can write here comma and the
other string as well so the output will
be
like this it says JavaScript was
developed by Brendan Ike in the year
1995.
so that's how the concatenation method
Works let's move on to our following
string method which is the split method
so as the name suggests
split means to break the string into
pieces so let's remove it from here and
now what we'll do is
we'll comment it from here now we'll go
through the split method so the split
method is used to break a string into
pieces the syntax is quite simple we
have to write the string name dot split
and what it will do is it will put a
comma in place of every space because if
we want to split something let's say we
want to write here I instead of space
right so it will Traverse the string and
every time it finds an i it will put a
comma instead of that I so let's save it
now and see here it says JavaScript here
in place of I a comma is inserted right
so similarly from Brendan Ike i is
replaced with a comma so that's how the
split function works so if we use here
space instead of I or anything else
let's save it now see instead of every
space a comma is inserted JavaScript
comma was comma developed so
that's how the split function works next
up we have the repeat method right so
we'll remove it and we'll go through the
repeat method so repeat as the name
suggests it will repeat the string so
the syntax is as usual similar like the
other syntaxes so we have a string
here's str5 and the value is similar
JavaScript was developed by Brendan Ike
so the repeat method is used if we want
to repeat a string n number of times
like here we have written here five it's
printed five Time Brendan Ike and then
the second then again it's printed so on
and so forth till 5 right so the repeat
function is used if you want to print a
string for n number of times basically
next up we have the slice method in
string
so the slice method extracts
parts of a string and Returns the
extracted part in a new string so let's
go through
the slice method so what slice method
does is
here you can see it uses the start and
the end parameters to specify the part
of the string we want to extract so here
you can see we have given two parameters
as 5 and 10. it will print crypto on the
browser because it started from index
value 0 and went till
10 so when it was at number 5 the value
present at number five it will start
from there and it will print till 10. so
C is the value present at number five if
we count from here 0 1 2 3 4 C is the
value present at 5 and it will print
till 10 because T is present at number
10 right so it will print crypto on the
browser
so if we try to do something else here
let's say we are using here 12 and we'll
take it through 30. save it now it says
as developed by BR so
a is present at number 12 and
R is present at number 30 so that's how
the slice function Works in string and
if we want to use the negative values we
can use it so it will print the string
from the end like if we write here minus
2 it will print the last two characters
of the string so let's try to write here
minus 2 and save it now see it says CH
it will print the last two characters of
the string next up we have the substr
method
so it works the same as the slice
function the only difference is in the
parameters so in the slice method we
give the two parameters it starts from
the first one and goes till the second
parameter but in the substr method it
starts from the first parameter and
prints the number of characters
mentioned in parameter 2. so let's try
to understand this with the help of an
example so here you can see we have this
string JavaScript was developed by
Brendan Ike and the parameters are 5 and
10. so the same parameters we have taken
for the slice method so what will happen
is it will start from 0 it will go till
5 so we know that c is present at 5
right so what it will do is it will
start from 5 and it will print the next
10 characters
so the slice function was printing till
10 but the substr will print the next 10
characters from index value 5 let's save
it and see it says Crypt was so there
are 10 characters which will be printed
on the browser because that's the only
difference between substr and slice
function
I hope you guys can spot the difference
between slice and substr Method right
next up we have the substring method
which works the same as the slice method
the difference is it will start from the
first parameter and goes till the second
parameter but
it won't include the character present
at the second parameter so if we try to
start it from 5 and we want it to go
till 10 save it so we can't do it this
way let's make it a 9 why 9 because at
number 10 a space is available so it's
not visible in the output right
so let's save it now and see it says
so C is present at 5 R is present at 6 I
is present at 7 and P is present at 8.
so T is present at 9 so it will not
print T because that's the only
difference between substring and slice
function both starts from the first
parameter both goes till the second
parameter but the slice function
includes the second parameter it
includes the value present at second
parameter whereas the substring leaves
the value present at second parameter we
discuss data type in previous videos
right so data types in JavaScript are of
two kinds we discuss the primitive data
types and the other type is
non-primitive or we can say complex or
composite data types right so an array
comes under the category of composite
data types or non-primitive we can say
so the basic definition of array states
that an array is a collection of
elements stored in contiguous memory
locations so array is a list of similar
type of elements or in JavaScript array
acts a bit different from other
programming languages we can discuss it
later so let's understand the concept of
arrays with the help of an example we'll
move to the programming part directly
let's consider a scenario where we have
a collection of similar types of
variables suppose we have a list of cars
let's create a small list here for a few
different car companies let's say we
have a variable where carbon
and the value of carbon will be let's
say Honda
okay and then we have another variable
let's say car two and the value of Car 2
will be Kia
and finally we have a variable let's say
where
car 3 and the value of car 3 will be
let's say food so here we have taken
three different car manufacturers we
have Honda we have Kia and we have food
and we have three different variables
right so if we want to print all three
of them what we have to do is we have to
use the document.write method right so
we have to use the document.write again
and again
so we can do it for this small piece of
code right let's print the value of all
three variables here let's say we are
using document
dot right and we will print the value of
all three variables
so here we have printed the value of all
three variables right we have carbon the
value was Honda we have Honda here we
have Kia and we have Ford as well
so this task is a bit simple for this
small piece of code right now imagine if
we have 100 values here instead of just
three values or maybe we can say we have
thousand values in a list we can't
follow the same procedure in that case
right that's where arrays come into play
what we can do is we can use a single
variable and we can store as many values
as we want inside a single variable by
doing this we don't have to access each
and every variable separately while
printing them the data types of those
values present inside the array does not
matter at all so we can save either
numbers or strings or a value with any
data type we'll discuss it in a moment
let's try to Define an array here first
so the Syntax for array goes like this
we have to take a variable let's say
We'll declare an array here
let's say we are taking a variable where
car
and these opening and closing square
brackets represent the array it means
that it is an array if we are using them
in a variable inside this we can use
double quotes with the value we want to
insert it will go like this let's
suppose we have three values here right
we'll use these three values only values
Honda Kia and food so to insert these
three values we have to follow this
syntax
so let's say we have the first
manufacturer as Honda the next one we
have is Kia
and the last one we have is
food right so we have all the three
values here present inside a single
variable so we have a single variable
where car and we have all the three
values we have Honda we have Kia and we
have food so
we can insert as many values as we want
like if we have a list of 100 car
manufacturers we can insert them in this
array now let's print the output of this
array so the output will go like we will
copy document dot right from here paste
it here and the output will go like this
so we don't need this piece of code
right now so we'll comment this
so that we can understand the difference
between these two codes and now let's
save this program and see here you can
see we have all the three elements of
the array we have Honda we have Kia and
we have Ford as well
so an array is a non-primitive data type
or composite data type with one single
name and can hold multiple values here
the array name is car and it stores
three similar values right here we have
three string values we have Honda Kia
and food so this array can store
any number of values we want to store in
that array so what if we want to print a
single value from these three values we
have we have Honda Kia and four right so
if we want to print Kia let's suppose so
it's easy to print this on a browser all
we need to know is the index number of
that value so the index number in the
case of arrays starts from 0 and goes
further so we have three values here as
we can see so the index value for these
variables will be so for Honda the index
value will be 0 and for here the index
value will be 1 and for 4 the index
value will be 2. so the index value
starts from 0 and goes on further so one
thing to keep in mind guys whatever
number of values and arrays holding the
last index value will always be 1 less
than the number of values so as here you
can see we have three values right so
the index number of the last value will
be 1 less than 3. it means the index
number will be 2 because the index
number starts from 0.
let's try to access the element present
at index 1. so we have Kia here right
all we have to do is we have to put
square brackets here in the document dot
right here we have to put square
brackets
and we have to write the index value
inside of these square brackets so if we
write here 1 and if we save this program
now so here you can see we have Kia only
it will print
the element present at index number one
so here in this particular case it is
Kia
we can also Loop through this array
using the index values let's say we want
to print each element on a separate line
every time right so we can use the loop
here I hope you guys are aware of the
for Loop by now will right here so we'll
we have declared an array so we will use
the for Loop here and we will print here
for we'll take a variable I and the
value of I will be initial value will be
0 and then we'll give the condition the
condition will be I Less Than 3 because
we know there are three values only and
it will go till 2 only because it's
going for the index value and the final
condition will be I plus plus
so here we'll
use the curly braces because this is the
Syntax for for Loop and the I value will
iterate through the array and print all
the values present at indexes till the
index 2. so the same thing goes for 100
elements as well we can use the for Loop
to access all the hundred elements in
separate lines
so guys if we save this and here you can
see okay
it is printing Kia Kia and Kia because
we have particularly mentioned here cars
present at index one so we have to
remove one here and we'll save it now
so the document.write syntax will be
changed a bit we will write here I
and if we save it now so we have all the
three values here you can see guys the I
value here will iterate through the
array and print all the values present
at indexes till the index 2. so the same
thing goes for 100 elements as well we
can use the for Loop to access all the
100 elements present in the array we can
use the same iteration concept for doing
so so guys there's another way to
represent an array in JavaScript it goes
like this we have a let's say we have a
variable this time we'll take the
variable as where fruits so the syntax
will be like new we have to use the new
keyword and then we will use new array
and we have to give a space here and the
elements we want to store inside the
array so we'll use a apple then we have
let's say
banana and finally we have let's say
mango
okay and we can access the elements of
these array with the help of a for Loop
we can use the similar for Loop here so
if we copy this for loop from here
and we'll paste it here
instead of cars we'll use a
fruits
right and we'll give the value as I
because we want to iterate the variable
I through each index so we have once
again the index value as 0 for apple one
for banana and 2 for mango let's comment
this program as well so that it will be
easy for you guys to understand
let's save this program now and see we
have the list of all the elements
present at array fruits so we have apple
we have banana and we have mango printed
on a browser so this way of array
representation or Declaration is less
recommended because the other way which
we discussed earlier like when we
discussed the car manufacturers so that
way is a bit easier to use so I'll
recommend that way only because this way
is a bit tricky as well
so let's move on to a next topic of
discussion so if you know guys arrays in
JavaScript work differently when
compared to other programming languages
like Java and C plus plus so arrays in
JavaScript have Dynamic nature which
means we can add or remove elements from
an array at runtime just like we saw the
string Methods in the previous video for
arrays also we have a few methods like
if we want to add elements into an array
or if we want to delete an element from
an array we have the push and pop
methods available to do such tasks
add an element into an array we use the
push method and the Syntax for pushing
elements into an array goes like so
we'll
remove this piece of code
and we'll use the first one only the car
manufacturer
so if we want to push
something inside the array right we'll
write here the variable name dot we use
the push method and we'll push whatever
value we want to push let's say we are
adding another car manufacturer let's
say we are adding Nissan we have to
change the value here as well because
what will happen we have used the
condition I Less Than 3 so it will check
for indexes still index 2 only it won't
check for index 3. so if we write here I
less than 4 it will check for Nissan now
let's save this and see a new value is
pushed into the array which is Nissan
so let's move on and discuss the pop
method so the pop method in Array
removes the last present element from
the array if we use this pop method here
it will remove Nissan in this case so
now you can see we have four car
manufacturers present in a array so if
we use the pop option now if we use
car.pop and let's run this program and
see it says undefined this is happening
because as you can see we have pushed
the value Nissan into array so and
address in the memory location was
reserved for that particular element now
if we pop out that particular element so
if we try to use cars.op once again
let's save it now and see it removed the
element fold as well so let's try to
push one more value in this particular
scenario let's say we are pushing a
value as
Hyundai and now let's run this so you
can see here it have inserted Hyundai in
place of food because we have used the
pop method to put Ford out of our array
so I hope you guys understood this so
these are the different methods for
arrays in JavaScript which are already
predefined to do some specific tasks
like this sort method if we write here
card dot so here are all the methods
here are all the array methods present
in JavaScript so if we use this sort
method what it will do it will sort the
array in ascending order
the array dot length property so just
like we had the length property in
strings so we have the property in
arrays as well the array.length
properties used to find the length of
the array so if we use it in the for
Loop in place of this I less than 4 so
here you can see we have used I less
than 4. now if we write here array dot
length so if we write here car
dot length so now we don't have to
change this value again and again so if
we are inserting any value or if we are
removing any value from this for Loop so
if we are removing any value from this
array so we don't have to write here 3
or we don't have to change it to 4 every
time we insert an element we don't have
to change that value basically what will
happen it will check for the length of
the array so the length here is let's
say we have the length here 3 right so
it will check for the length and it will
be 1 less than the length of the array
so if we run this program now it will
work fine I hope you guys understood the
concept of array methods present in
JavaScript the other main difference
array has in JavaScript which makes it
different from C plus plus or Java is we
can add elements with other data types
in JavaScript we try to use the push
method to insert a numeric value here in
this car's array so we'll push another
value let's say we are pushing car dot
push and this time we will push a
numeric value let's say we are pushing
here 20.
so let's save it and here you can see
the value 20 is inserted inside the
array car so we can use any data type
inside the array in JavaScript
objects are the most powerful and the
most used data types in JavaScript so
far we have seen that we can use a
single variable to store a value the
value can be a string or a number or any
other type of variable after that we
have seen arrays in which we can store
multiple values like we can store lists
in arrays so let's take a scenario here
and let's say we have a piece of code we
are taking a variable let's say where
car manufacturer
and the value of this car manufacturer
will be Audi a string right
next up we have another variable let's
say we have variable car model
and the value of this will be let's say
car from Audis Q7
then we have another variable let's say
where price of this car and the price
will be
let's say 50 000 US Dollars all right
next up we have a function let's say we
are using a function that is all wheel
drive
so we are having a function all-wheel
the opening and closing curly braces for
the body of the function and inside this
all-wheel drive function we are using
document.write and here what we will
write
we'll write let's suppose
this car comes with
Quattro all-wheel drive Quattro I hope
you guys are aware of this word Quattro
it means that four wheel drive
next up we will call this all-wheel
drive function here
so here's the data about a particular
car from a particular brand Audi right
so the car model is Q7 and the price of
this car is 50 000 US dollars so these
are the three different things we are
storing for a car of a particular brand
next up we have a function which states
the capability of the car the function
here is the all-wheel drive which means
that this car comes with four wheel
drive instead of General front wheel
drive or rear wheel drive so this
function is the behavior of the car
right it shows that the car is four
wheel drive things are pretty sorted
here right we have the data about the
car and a function associated with it so
let's save this and we can see the
output here the car comes with Quattro
all-wheel drive so this is a basic piece
of code right we have been through
functions we know how to use functions
we know how to call them so that's quite
easy for now right the problem occurs
when we have a list of cars let's say
that we have to maintain 100 different
cars with all the data of car
manufacturer we have car model price and
then we have different behaviors for
different cars not all cars have the
all-wheel drive property so what we will
do in such a case where we have to use
the same property again and again for
100 different cars or 100 different
entities we can copy paste this same
piece of code repeatedly and we have to
change the value every time we copy
paste it so we have to change the
variable name the car manufacturer the
car model and the price as well imagine
we are doing this for a list of cars
then it goes on and on so this is the
most inefficient way of tackling this
problem right
this is where the concept of objects
come into play these objects help us to
bundle all these properties and
attributes about one particular entity
if we talk about this particular example
of a car we can put all these properties
and many other properties like car
weight we have car color and so on
together under one name and make it an
object
let's move on to the Syntax for objects
in JavaScript we'll do it for this same
program we'll use objects now let's go
ahead and have a look at the Syntax for
objects so before we start there are few
ways in which we can create objects in
JavaScript we are going to discuss two
different ways of doing so the first one
is the literal way also known as the
literal objective
so the Syntax for literal object way
goes like this
let's say we are declaring a variable
where car and curly braces so these
curly braces represent that this car
variable is actually an object inside
this we will Define all the cars
properties that is whatever data we want
to store about the car like car
manufacturer car model and price in this
particular scenario so let's use them
here so we have car manufacturer and the
car manufacturer is
OD
right
next up we have car model
car model is
Q7
finally we have the price which is
50 000 dollars
so you can identify the difference here
inside the object right when we declare
a variable we usually use the equals to
sign for assignment but here in objects
we use the colon and we are using commas
here because we have some more
properties so these three are the
properties for this object car we have
three properties associated with it we
can also add this all-wheel drive
function inside the object and when we
use this function inside the object it
will be called a method whenever we use
a function inside a class or an object
so it is known as a method keep this
thing in mind guys so that syntax is
also a bit different when it comes to
methods inside an object the Syntax for
that will be we have to write here all
wheel drive
and we'll use the colon then it is a
function so we will write a function
with opening and closing round brackets
and the body of the function
so what we want to write here is we want
to we want this function to return the
value right we want this function to
return this value so we'll copy it from
here
and we'll paste it here
so we want this function to return this
value so we'll write here return instead
of
document dot right now this function
will return this string that this cars
comes with a Quattro all-wheel drive
so if you want to change this string a
little bit you can change because we
have already
use this string in the previous program
we did so let's suppose
we'll write here
four wheel drive now this will be easier
for you to understand this so this is
what an object looks like our object is
entirely ready what we did here is we
bundled all these things and coupled
them we bundled all these things we
bundled all the three variables we
bundle this function we bundled all of
them together inside a single variable
and now this particular variable car is
an object now if we want to access these
properties of the object like car
manufacturer car model Etc whatever
properties we have here so what we have
to do is we have to use document.write
so it is quite simple so after this
object we'll write here document
dot right
and to access this object what we have
to do is we have to use the object name
with the dot operator and the property
name so if we want to Let's suppose
we'll use here
car dot and property name will be car
underscore manufacturer
so here is the syntax the syntax is
quite easy you can see here we have used
the car object with the dot operator and
then we have the property name whatever
property we want to access
so let's save this program now and see
here it says OD
by using this dot operator we can access
any property of the car not just a
property we can access the method as
well so if we want to access the method
like if you want to access this
all-wheel drive function we can do it
simply by writing here car dot and we'll
write here instead of this we'll write a
all-wheel drive and we are good to go so
if we save this now so here you can see
it says this car comes with four wheel
drive so it is quite easy to access
these properties of an object so we can
do it by using this now suppose we call
this function normally with the document
dot right inside the function in place
of return so if we write here
document.write
normal like how we normally call a
function so if we write a document dot
right inside this function and we can
call this function by the normal method
like if you are calling this function
from outside what we will do we'll write
here car dot and the function name
so if we save this now here you can see
the string is printed on the browser
this car comes with four wheel drive and
you can see here we didn't used any H1
tag or h2 tag so you can spot the
difference right so that's how you can
call a method of an object from outside
this is the normal way
so now you guys might be wondering what
if we want to add more cars into this we
can copy paste it again to do so and
change the value of properties again it
is the same thing we can do with the
variables so this is where the following
way of creating objects come into the
picture in which we use something
different known as object Constructor
that's a bit different from other object
oriented programming languages so don't
worry if you don't know about it also in
the newer versions JavaScript supports
the concept of classes and object so
what we used to say earlier is
Javascript is an object oriented
scripting language because it does not
supports the concept of classes and
objects fully but now the scenario has
changed JavaScript do support the
concept of classes and objects but we'll
keep it a bit simple so let's comment
this code as well
and we'll use this code for reference so
we'll comment this that's why we are not
removing it but we can remove this piece
of code
so let's remove it
and let's
move on to user second way of creating
an object now we will create multiple
objects using a single template which is
known as a Constructor function
let's have a look at the Syntax for this
method so we'll write the function
keyword and we have named this function
as cars and in parenthesis we will
provide the
properties as parameters so these are
the properties we have car manufacturer
we have car model and we have car price
so these are the properties which we
used in the previous code as well so
here we have also used these properties
so we'll keep it that way only now
inside a function these parameters are
known as arguments so if we talk about
the naming convention so these
parameters are known as arguments
so let's move on to the body of the
function and inside the body we will use
this keyword here
this keyword refers to the object it
belongs to so here in this program this
will refer to the object basically so
what we are doing here is whenever we
are creating any object using this
Constructor function we will pass
specific values like the car
manufacturer car model and the price all
of these values so all these values will
be present at the rhs so let me write
this first let's say we are using this
Dot and the property name car
manufacturer
will right here car manufacturer
so all these values will be present at
the rhs and the actual property of the
object will be this dot car manufacturer
so this is the actual property of this
method you will understand it much
better when we create the object for now
let's mention here the other two
properties and Method as well so let's
use the other two properties which were
this Dot car model
and
we'll write your car model the last one
was this Dot price
right here price
let's add the method here as well inside
the Constructor function we'll use this
keyword again to add the method the
syntax will go like this we'll use this
dot all wheel drive
and this is a function so we'll write
here function with the opening and
closing round brackets and then we have
the body of the function inside the body
of this function we will write
whatever we have written in the previous
program so we'll copy it from here and
we'll paste it here
right so this is a complete Constructor
function Now using this Constructor
function we can create multiple objects
of this car type so this Constructor
function works like a template or like
the classes work in other languages like
C plus plus and Java so let's create an
object here
so we'll create a variable here let's
say we are creating a variable C1 now
we'll use the new keyword and along with
the
Constructor function so we'll use your
cards and we'll pass the values for all
the three properties so here you can say
we have the car manufacturer is Audi and
next up we have the
model as
Q7 and the prices
50 000. okay so we have created a
variable we have passed the values for
the properties
and now if you want to access this
function if we want to access this
all-wheel drive function we can access
this as well we have to write here C1
dot all wheel drives and this is how you
can call a function
if we save this program see here it says
this car comes with four wheel drive so
if you change anything here let's
suppose we are using here H2 Tech
if we save this program now see you can
see the change here so we are calling
this function here and this will be
printed on the browser so this string
will be printed on the browser
let's create another variable here let's
say we are using where C2 and the syntax
will be same for this as well we'll
write here new cards and we'll pass the
values here so let's say we are using
BMW
and next up we have the model as
X7
and the price of this car is let's say
40 000 okay 40 000 USD so if we want to
access any particular property of any
object like if we want to access the car
model or if we want to access the car
manufacturer so we can do it the same
way as we did previously as we did in
the literal object way so
to do so we have to write here
document.write
and it was quite simple so we have to
write here the object name Dot and
whatever we want to print let's say we
are printing here car model so if we
save this now you can see here X7 is
printed on the browser because X7 is the
value of object C2 and let's suppose if
we want to
print a car manufacturer save it and see
here you can see we have BMW as the
output on a browser similarly we can
access the price as well let's save it
now and see here it says 40 000. so this
is how we can create multiple objects in
JavaScript we'll continue with the
previous program we made so today we
will use the literal object way because
this method of creating objects is a bit
easier than the other one we discussed
which was the Constructor function
method so here we created the car object
which has three properties car
manufacturer car model and the price of
the car we have a method here as
all-wheel drive when we use this method
here we use this method with the dot
operator and we call that function we
call that method with the help of the
object
so the output was this car comes with
four wheel drive so this was something
we did in the previous video if we talk
about objects in JavaScript a lot of
things we know about in JavaScript are
basically objects like the Boolean
values numbers strings and a few more so
many of these things can be objects if
we Define them with the new keyword
basically any of the data type other
than the null and undefined can be
converted to objects or they have their
equivalent object forms if we Define
them with the new keyword so we have a
few predefined objects as well we have
the math object the date object and the
regular expression are also considered
objects in JavaScript a lot of things
are objects in JavaScript we'll use
objects in Dom manipulation which we
will go through in further videos so
that's why it is pretty essential to
understand the whole concept of objects
right so next stop let's look at how we
can use different data types as objects
in JavaScript
so the Syntax for using the basic data
types as objects in JavaScript goes like
this we will declare a variable first we
have a variable str1 and next up we'll
write here the new keyword and the data
type so Stringer is a data type which we
will be using as objects for now so this
is the complete syntax of how to use a
data type as an object in JavaScript if
we'll write here str1 and we'll use the
dot operator so here we can see we have
the object methods as well right so I
hope you guys are aware of the methods
present in JavaScript like we had the
string and array methods right we have
methods for object as well like the
index of method we have seen the use of
index of method when we went through the
string Methods in JavaScript so
similarly we have the font color and the
length property for object as well so
length here is the property and other
which we can see are the methods for
objects in JavaScript so here this str1
becomes the object by default when we
use the new keyword with the string
while declaring
so there are few ways to determine if a
variable is an object or a primary data
type so the easiest way to do so is to
use the type of operator so let's use it
here and check the type of variable str1
we'll write here
document.write
and we'll print the type of this
variable
so we'll use the type of operator and
the type of variable str1
so let me put it inside the H1 tag
so here we have written a type of
operator so let's print this value on
the browser if we save it see here you
can see it says object
if we write a string here in place of
this new string so if we write here any
string let's suppose we are using a
string here let's say we are using
hello
okay let's save it now and here you can
see the type of this variable str1
changed from object to string so this is
the difference between a primitive data
type it was a Stringer layer but when we
use it with the new keyword along with
the string and this is the basic syntax
of how to define a primitive data type
as an object so if we save it now here
you can see it is converted to object
similarly we can use the other basic
data types as well and the other
predefined objects we talked about like
the date object and the math object
we'll go through each of them in
separate videos so moving on let's go
back to our car object after we declared
the whole object we defined all the
three properties and the method also
somewhere in the program we realized
that we had missed the particular
property and we realized it after we
have written 150 lines of code after
this car object so here you can say we
have written here 150 line of codes so
I'm not writing 150 lines but let's do
it this way so we realized it after 150
lines
in JavaScript we can add a particular
property to an object outside the
definition also we can add a property to
an object anywhere in a program the
Syntax for that goes like this will
write the object name
with the property name along with the
dot operator so we'll write here one
more property let's say we are using
car color
and the value of this
property will be let's say black right
what this line will do is it will add
one more property inside this existing
car object so initially we had three
properties now this line will add one
more property to this car object we are
using the same name that is the object's
name having three properties over here
we are using the same object name here
you can see here the object name is car
and here we have also used the car
object name now we have added one more
property to this object car we can check
it let's print it out on the browser
so what we will do we'll write here
document dot right
so here you can see we have used the
document.write method to print this car
color on a browser so we have used a car
dot car color let's save this program
now and see here you can see the output
is black so this is the property of the
object car now and if we comment this
line let's say if we are commenting this
line let's save this now and see here
you can see it says undefined we can add
more properties similarly like if we
want to add another property here we can
go like car dot and the property name
whatever property we want to add let's
say we want to add fuel type
so it can be a petrol car or a diesel
car or an electric car it doesn't matter
so we can add properties as well in fact
we can add methods as well so the syntax
to add method goes like we can add a
method here we'll see it will go like
car dot let's say we are adding a new
function
let's say we are adding the function new
fun equals to and here we will write
function
so the
body of the function now whatever we
want to write inside the function let's
say this function return function
successfully
edit
so if we try to call this function from
outside we can do it so let's try to
check out the output for this function
let's say we want to access this
particular function so save it now and
here you can see it says function
successfully added so the new method we
added is the new fun and we added this
method to our pre-existing object which
was the car object so I hope you guys
are aware of how to add a new property
or a new method to an existing object by
now what if we want to delete a
particular object so it's pretty easy to
do so in JavaScript we can use the
delete keyword object name and the
property name after the dot operator
let's suppose we want to delete car
model here we want to delete this
particular property of the object car so
we what we'll do we'll delete this car
model
so the Syntax for it is quite simple so
we'll remove this for now and we'll
delete a property let's say we are using
the delete keyword with
the object name dot method name or the
property name so we'll delete here car
model right
let's save it now
so this particular line will delete the
car model attribute of this car object
let's check it out and we will print
here the car model so we'll write here
car dot
model
and
save it now so here you can see it says
undefined and if we try to comment this
line and now if we try to save this
program so here you can see the car
model is Q7
so this is how we can delete a
particular property or a particular
method from an object one more thing
before we wrap up this video is as we
all know JavaScript is a Loosely typed
language right so we can change the data
type of these properties on the fly now
we will change the data type of this
property we had the price property right
so we'll change the data type of this
particular property now
we note that the value of the price
property is a number let's change this
number to a string data type what we
have to do is we have to write so we
have to write here car dot
price
and update the value here let's say we
are using 70 000 and we have to put a
semicolon it's the same thing we do to
update the value of a particular
variable right so if we try to print the
value of price now we'll get the output
as seventy thousand let's try to print
it on the browser so we'll cut it from
here
we'll paste it here and we'll print car
price
save it now see here you can see it says
70 000.
if we want to check the type of this
property what we can do is
we can use the type of operator so we'll
use the type of operator
so this is the syntax of how we can use
the type of operator let's save this now
and see here it says string earlier it
was a number but now it is a string so
all these things can be done dynamically
in a program wherever we want to do them
so that's the benefit of having objects
in JavaScript till now we came across
many methods and properties of objects
in JavaScript like the push method which
we use to add something to the object or
if we want to delete something from the
object we can use the delete method
right so these are some of the
predefined methods we have in JavaScript
for objects apart from these methods we
have some predefined objects as well
which are used in certain specific
conditions math object is one among them
we use the math object whenever we are
making a calculator or working on a
program with calculations on any kinds
of numbers so the math object in
JavaScript has as built-in properties
and these properties most often provide
mathematical properties such as the pi
and we have Euler's Constant and many
more such methods if we talk about the
methods present within the math object
we have several methods present like we
can't discuss all of them but we can
look at these methods and we will use a
few of them so let's move ahead and have
a look at all the methods present in
JavaScript so Guys these are the methods
we have we have a list of methods having
a variety of usage and you can pause the
video and take a screenshot or if you
want to note them down you can do it as
well so it depends on you totally so
these are all the methods we have in
math object
so we will go through a few essential
methods which we might need ahead in
this particular course
so let's move on and have a look at few
of them so I hope you guys are aware of
the value of pi which is something like
3.1415 and so on a hard to remember
value right we can use the pi method in
JavaScript and we don't have to read out
or remember this value every time we
need it so the syntax is quite simple
all we have to do is we have to call
this method and we are good to
so let's print this value of pi now we
are going to print the value of pi what
we have to do is we have to write here
document Dot
right and we have to use a math Dot
Pi so this is the syntax of how we can
print the value of pi on our browser so
if you want to put it inside something
like H1 tag or h2 tag it's totally upon
you go ahead and save this and check it
out
so this is the value of pi which is
3.1415926 so this is the complete value
of pi it's a hard to remember value
right so JavaScript already stores the
value of pi so anytime we want it like
if we want to know the area of a circle
so we don't have to Google for the value
or we don't have to remember the value
JavaScript gives us effortless access to
use the value of pi one more similar
value is Euler's value so we can use
this method anytime just like we have
the pi method we also have the Euler's
method so we can use this method anytime
we need the value so the Syntax for
Euler's value goes the same as that for
method dot Pi the only change is we will
write e in place of Pi so here in place
of Pi we will replace it with capital e
so this is similar like we can use the
same for pi and we can use the same for
eulers the only difference is of a
character so we can save it and see here
is the value of Euler's constant these
values are pretty hard to remember right
so anytime we need them we don't have to
Google it or we don't have to remember
them as well so what we can do is we can
use the math object and we are good to
go in our program apart from that the
math object is used for some other
methods such as finding the square root
of a number yes we can create the
function for it still many of these easy
and straightforward mathematical
functions are already built in in
JavaScript like the square root of a
number
or the power of a number if you want to
round up a number we can use the
built-in method for that also so let's
make a program that gives us the square
root of a number as we already discussed
we can create a function for it but why
do we do that when we can use the
built-in JavaScript math object methods
so let's move on and create a variable
first so we'll
remove this and we'll create a variable
let's say where and and the value of n
will be 49 let's suppose
so we know that the square root of 49 is
7 so to get the output we have to create
another variable that will hold the
value returned by the math object so
we'll create another variable let's say
we are creating another variable where
answer and this variable will hold the
value returned by math dot sqrt so math
dot sqrt is the method for returning the
square root of a number so
then we will print the value of answer
now we will print the value of variable
answer so we'll write here document dot
right
and we'll print the value of
answer so let's print it inside the H1
tag
so let's print the value of answer now
and see if the output is 7 or not so
here you can see we have the output as 7
so the square root of 49 is 7. the
program works like we give it a number
let's suppose we are giving it a number
144 okay in place of 49 we are giving it
a number 144 so this value will be
stored in the variable n then it will
find the square root of this number and
it will save the square root in a
variable answer so we have another
variable here and the value of square
root will be saved inside the answer
variable and finally when we save this
program we have the output as 12. so
this is how this particular program
works so there are several similar
methods present in JavaScript and the
following two methods we are going to
discuss are a bit more helpful and we'll
use them in future we'll definitely use
them in future so the two new methods
are the Min and the max method let's
suppose
let's comment this out first
so suppose we have a list of numbers and
we want to find the smallest and the
largest numbers present in that list so
let's do it for the largest number first
so the Syntax for the max method goes
like we'll write here document
dot right
let's suppose we are using here math Max
and we have a list of numbers let's
suppose we have random numbers 1 2 6 3
and we are using random numbers
so this is our list of numbers so what
is the output of this particular program
so we are using the math.max but this
method will do is it will find the
greatest number of all these numbers so
here we can see that
87425 is the greatest among all these
numbers so if we save this program we
will get the output as eight seven four
two five similarly if we copy this line
and paste it here and instead of the max
we'll use the Min method so what Min
method will do that it will find the
smallest number of all these numbers so
let's save it and see the answer here is
0 that's because 0 is the smallest
number present in this list so that's
how the Min and the max methods work in
JavaScript
so the last method we are going to
discuss in this video is math dot power
method suppose we want to print the
value of 2 raised to the power 4. to
print this on the browser we can also
create a function but we have a method
in math object that makes this task a
little more straightforward it is
beneficial when we want to print a
larger number so what we have to do is
we will again write here document.write
foreign
we'll use the
math Dot
power method so here we have to provide
it two parameters let's suppose we are
providing here the parameters as 2 and
4. so it will print 2 raised to the
power 4 the second parameter will be the
power of the first number so this
particular line will print 2 into 2 into
2 into 2 that means 16. so save it and
let's check the output now so here you
can see it says 16. if we do the same
for let's suppose 10 save it now and
here you can see the output as 10 000 it
is 10 into 10 which is 100 into 10 1000
into ten ten thousand so these are some
vital math object methods present in
JavaScript you can use the other methods
as well as we have seen earlier in this
videos we have a list of methods there
are different methods present in math
object methods the benefit of using
these object methods is that it's way
easier to write these eight characters
suppose we are using the math dot sqrt
method it is easier to use this method
instead of creating a whole new function
so that's why we use the math object
methods in JavaScript so object literals
method in JavaScript are defined as a
comma separated list of name value pairs
wrapped nicely in curly braces so we
already came across this method in the
previous video when we talked about
defining objects in JavaScript right so
we are talking again about this method
because in the following video where we
will be discussing Constructors in
JavaScript I want you guys to understand
this method thoroughly so that it will
be easy for you guys to understand the
difference between the object literal
method and the Constructor method so
this method is all about wrapping up of
all the data of an object in a nice and
tidy way so the object little method is
one way of creating an object right and
the object Constructor method is another
way of creating an object
so let's discuss the advantages of using
the object literal method so the first
advantage of using the object literal
method is we don't have to create an
empty object so what we can do is we can
directly add properties and behaviors
while creating the object so let's take
an example wherein we will print the
area and the parameter of rect
so we'll create an object first so let's
say we are defining an object and
here we will write where and the name of
the object will be let's say rect one
because we are printing the area and the
parameter of a rectangle then we have a
pair of curly braces for the body of an
object so here we are with an object
which is named as rectum and now let's
say we have two properties which are the
length and the width of a rectangle so
let's define them as well
so we'll write the property name and so
let's say the first properties length
so this is the first property and then
we'll use colon so here one thing to
notice is we are using colon in place of
equals to to assign a value right we are
assigning a value to this length
property and let's say the value is 5
and then it will be followed by a comma
then we'll write here the next property
let's say width is the next property and
we'll again use colon and let's say the
value of width is 10.
and then we'll separate this key value
pair so one thing here to notice is that
we are using the key value pair so here
in this case the keys are length and
width and the values for these keys are
5 and 10. so remember this guys because
we need them in following videos so
let's move ahead and we'll declare the
methods as well I hope you guys are
aware of the Syntax for how to use a
method within an object so let's define
here the methods as well so
we'll use two methods one for the area
and the another one for parameter so
let's say the method for area is get
area
and then we'll use colon and then we'll
write here function
and then we have the body of the
function so what this get area method
will return is it will return the area
of the rectangle right so it will return
so the area of rectangle is
let me write it here so the area of
rectangle is length into width or we'll
write here W so it will return this
Dot length into this dot width right so
one thing to notice here is we are using
this keyword again
so this keyword refers to the object it
belongs to so here in this program this
will refer to the object basically right
here in this case it refers to object
rect1 so let's use the other method as
well the next method will be get
parameter and then we'll use the column
then we have the function keyword and
the body of this method so what this
particular method will return is it will
return the parameter of a rectangle so
the parameter of a rectangle is 2 into
length
plus width or we can say 2 into length
plus 2 into width so here in this case
it will return
2 into
this dot length
Plus
2 into
this Dot
width
right so let's print these values as
well so we'll write here
document dot right
and we'll print all the four properties
or we can say we'll print the length
then we'll print the width and then
we'll print the area of the rectangle
and finally we'll print the parameter
right so let's say we are using the h2
tag here to make it more clear for you
guys
so here we will write the first sentence
will be
the length of rectangle is and then
we'll print the value of length then
finally we'll use the h2 tag again now
we'll copy this statement and we'll
print it four times because we want to
print all the four values right we want
to print the length width area and
parameter so we'll write here width and
here in the next line we'll print the
area and finally we'll print the
parameter right
so we'll change the values as well
so here we have two properties the
length and the width and then we have
two methods the first one is get area
and the second one is
get parameter
so here we are done with our printing
process so let's save this program now
and see here we have four values the
length of rectangle is 5 as we have
given the value 5 and then we have the
width test 10 and then we have the area
as 50 because area is length into width
which is 10 into 5 or 5 into 10 50 and
then finally we have the parameter which
is 2 into length which is 10 and then we
have 2 into 10 that is 20 because width
is 10 right so 20 plus 10 30. so the
parameter of rectangle is 30. so we
discussed this method again to make it
more clear to you guys whenever we are
working with a single object or when we
know everything about the properties and
the behavior of an object we should
always use the object literal method
that's because this method runs faster
and we have to write minimum code while
using the object literal method so we
discuss this method to clarify to you
guys that when we use Constructors in
JavaScript that is in the following
video it should not create any sort of
confusion or such thing the date object
in JavaScript is a handy built-in object
specially used when working with the
date and the time so how the date object
work is whenever we create a date object
it goes ahead and grabs the current date
and the time from the browser so
whatever time is there in a browser the
date object will grab it and give it to
us as the output
so before we move on to the date object
let me introduce to you guys a small yet
exciting function present in JavaScript
so that function is set interval
function what this set interval function
or method will do is it will run a
function repeatedly after a specific
interval for example if we have a
function and we want to print that
function in a browser automatically
after five second so in that case we can
use the set interval method so let's
move ahead and have a look at the Syntax
for the set interval method so that you
can understand it much better
so let's create a function here first so
let's say we have a function named
something
and then we have open and close round
bracket and the body of the function so
what this something function will do
that it will print a string on the
browser so let's suppose we are using a
document.write and the string we are
going to use is a basic string which we
used in our previous program that is
welcome to Simply code
so this is a basic function which will
print welcome to Simply code on the
browser if we call this function using
the set interval method so this set
interval method will print this string
on the browser repeatedly let's use the
set interval method here so the Syntax
for using the set interval method is we
have to write here set
set interval and we have to give two
parameters the first one is the function
name so we'll write here something and
we'll call the function then after a
comma we have to mention the time here
which is in milliseconds so 1000 here
means one second so let's say we are
using 2000 milliseconds so we'll write
here 2000 and this 2000 refers to those
two seconds of interval between the
strings that will be printed again so
let's save this program
and
here after two second you can see it's
printing welcome to Simply code so after
every two second it will print this
string so let's do one thing let's use
the H1 tag here
so guys we have used the H1 tag here
what we are going to do we use the H1
tag because it will make it more easy
for you guys to understand so let's save
it now and see after two second it will
print welcome to Simply code on the
browser then again after two second the
same string will be printed again then
again and again and so on and so forth
so I explained this function right now
because we are going to use this
function today in a program so let's
move ahead and have a look at the date
object now so we'll go deep in the date
object now first thing is while creating
a date object we have to keep in mind
that in JavaScript we have four
different ways to create a date object
so we'll discuss them one by one the
first way is to use the new date
Constructor so we'll comment this
program
and let's save this program now let's
have a look at the example of how to use
the new date Constructor so what we'll
do we'll create a variable first let's
say we are creating a variable where now
and we'll create a date object so we
will write a new date
and this is the first way of how to
create a date object so we'll write here
new date and then what we'll do we'll
write
document
dot right and we'll print now
so creating the date object will return
the weekday month date year time and the
local time zone so let's print this on
the browser and let's save it and here
you can see it it shows everything it
shows the weekday it shows the month it
shows date year time and the local time
zone as well right so the date object is
a static object it means that the
computer time will change right so
whatever time it is right now it will
change after few seconds but the date
object will remain the same once called
so once we have called this function the
time here will remain the same
it will not change according to the
browser's type
so that's where we can use the set
interval method to update the time again
and again after a specific interval of
time
so the following way to create the date
object is by providing the parameters to
the previous function so what we'll do
we'll provide here parameters to this
new date method so let's change this
date object here only what we will do is
we'll
use new date and will provide these
parameters so we'll provide the
parameters as the first parameter will
be the year the second one will be month
the third one will be day and the next
one will be r
so whatever value we want to assign as R
so there are seven basic parameters so
the seven basic parameters are year
month day are minute and second and
millisecond so the order Remains the
Same suppose we are providing all the
seven parameters then those seven
parameters will be taken accordingly
it's not like we can give the day first
and then we move ahead and provide the
year or a month so if we want to print
all the seven so what we have to do is
we have to provide all the seven
parameters let's say we are providing
all the seven and the last one will be
zero so let's save it now so you can see
here the year is 2018. so we have used
here 0 so the month will be January one
thing to keep in mind is if we are
writing 0 it will take as January so if
we want to print December we have to use
a 11 instead of 0. so if we'll write
here if we write here 11 it will print
December so you can see here December is
the 11th month because the month is
starting from 0 in this case so next up
we have the day as well
we have Monday
and we have the time as 10 33 and 30
seconds so it's 10 hours 33 minutes and
30 seconds and finally it has the local
time zone
so that's how the new date Constructor
work with all the parameters suppose if
we want to print only five of these
values so these five values will be year
month day or n minute so what we'll do
is we'll remove these two values and if
we save it now so here you can see
instead of the seconds it will print 0 0
because the default value of seconds
will be 0 0 in this case the fun part
here is we have to provide at least two
parameters here if we try to put only
one parameter that is the year value it
will take it as a millisecond so if we
try to write here only 2018 so this is
the year basically right so what we are
expecting is it will print the year but
this is not what is going to happen so
if we save it now you can see here it
shows
1970 January 1 1970. so this is actually
the Third Way of creating the new date
Constructor in which we give millisecond
as the parameter
so the last way we have to create the
new date Constructor is we have to use
the new date along with the string here
so let's understand this with the help
of an example first so let's
use here a string what we'll do is we'll
write here
October 13
2014.
and we'll give it the time as 11
hours
30 minutes and
34 seconds
let's say let's save it now and here you
can see it shows the day Monday on
October 13 2014 and the time is 11 hours
30 minutes and 34 seconds along with the
local time zone so that's the fourth way
of how to create a new date object from
the provided string here you can see in
the output
it created a new date object from the
provided string so these are the four
ways to create a new date object moving
on let's talk about the methods present
within the date object so just like we
had methods for the math object
similarly in the date object methods are
also present in fact more than 40
different methods are present within the
date object so here is the list of
methods present within the date object
we have a list of methods having a
variety of usage so you can pause the
video and take a screenshot or if you
want to note them down you can do it as
well it's totally up to you guys but
these are the methods we have in the
date object so we have the get method
and
then if we talk about we have the set
methods as well so these are the methods
and they have different functions so you
can see here like the set date method we
can use it
to set the day of the month for a
specified date according to the local
time so similarly we have many more
methods like we have more than 40
methods as we mentioned it earlier so
these are the basic 40 methods we have
in the date object so you can take a
note of these method and you can use
them later
so we can't go through each of these
method but we'll go through a few
essential methods which we might need
ahead in this particular course so let's
comment this as well so what we'll do
now is we'll create a program a basic
clock we can say using few methods so
the first thing we need to do is we need
to create a function this function will
print the current time on the browser so
let's say we have a function
and let's say the function name is clock
and we have the opening and closing
round brackets and the body of the
function moving ahead we will create a
variable and a new date object let's do
it first let's say we are using a
variable CD and what we'll do we'll
create a new date object
so we'll write here new date so we have
created a new date object remember we
have different ways to create a new date
object right we'll be using the first
one here what it does is it will grab
the current time and date and store it
in a variable called CD so now the
variable called CD holds the current
date and current time this variable CD
actually contains a lot of information
right but we need access to only
specific values like the hours minutes
and second because we want to make a
clock right so we need hours minutes and
seconds only so that's where methods
come into play so let's declare a few
variable first and then we'll use the
methods so we'll declare here three
variable let's say the first variable is
whereas
and the second variable is where minutes
and the third variable is
where seconds
so we have these three variables now the
next thing we are going to do is we'll
use the methods for these three
variables so if we want to take the
value of hours from the new date object
what we have to do is we have to use the
method and the method is get ours so how
to use this method we'll access the
value of hours from the variable CD
because remember the CD variable holds a
lot of information like it holds whole
information about date current time and
everything about that so we'll use here
where get
ours so similarly for minutes we'll use
get minutes
and for seconds we have to use
get seconds
so these are the three basic methods we
are going to use in this particular
program so one thing to keep in mind is
this method works with 24 hour format so
3 pm will be stored as 15 in the
variable RS similarly for the variables
minutes and seconds we have two methods
right we have the get minutes and the
get seconds method
so the current value of minutes will be
stored inside the minutes variable and
the current value of seconds in the
computer will be stored inside the
seconds variable
the value of these variables will change
every time we call the program right
every time it will print the current R
minute and second now all we have to do
is we have to print this time on the
browser so what we'll do is we'll use
document dot right
and we'll print here
let's say we are using the
h2 tag we'll print here
ours then we have to use the colon then
we have to
print the minutes and then again we'll
use colon
and then finally we have
seconds
so we'll close the h2 tag here
and now
so we are done with printing the time on
a browser the final thing we have to do
is we have to call this clock function
right so let's save this program now and
see here it says 22 22 50 it means 11
hours 22 minutes and 50 seconds it's 11
pm right so because we are using the 24
hour format one thing you might notice
that the time we have in our browser is
static which means it is not changing so
for that we have to use the set interval
function
let's use it here so that the time will
change after every second so if we want
to do it what we have to do is we have
to use the
set interval here so the set interval
method we have to call the clock
function and then we have to provide the
time after which it will be printed so
let's save it now
and here you can see after every one
second the time is being printed on the
browser so it's it was 51 then 52 then
53 4 and so on so Guys these are some
basic methods present within the date
object in JavaScript we have a lot of
such methods present in JavaScript we
have already seen them in the video if
you want to use them you can do it
that's quite easy to use them in
JavaScript we can use Constructor in two
different ways we will be discussing
both of them the first one we will
discuss is the object Constructor method
and other way of doing so is by using
the Constructor function we have already
discussed the Constructor function in
the previous video wherein we took the
example of a car but we'll go through it
once again so that there will be no
confusion between all the methods of
creating an object in JavaScript
so let's move ahead and we'll go through
the object Constructor method now
so the Syntax for creating an empty
object using the object Constructor
method goes like this we'll write the
where keyword followed by the object
name then we have the equals to sign and
the equals to sign is followed by the
new keyword and object with a capital u
so this is the syntax of creating in
empty object by using the object
Constructor method
so you guys have to remember the syntax
and it will remain the same every time
we use the object Constructor method so
this object here so this object is the
Constructor what this will do is it will
create an instance for this object and
assign it to the object name so whatever
object we are creating here it will
assign it to this object through which
we can write and access other properties
of the object so let's move on and we'll
create an object first let's say we are
creating the same program we did in the
previous tutorial wherein we printed the
area and the perimeter of a rectangle so
we'll use the same program so that there
will be no confusion let's move ahead
and create an empty object now so the
syntax will be like we'll write the
object name is let's say rack 2 and then
we have the new keyword along with the
object and opening and closing round
brackets so this is a empty object so
this statement is the same as like if
you remember in the last video when we
created an object using the object
literal method so we created it like we
wrote where keyword along with the
object name
and then we have a pair of curly braces
so both these statements are same what
we did is we created an empty object in
both the cases so after creating an
empty object the next thing we'll do is
We'll add properties and behaviors to
that object so let's move on and we'll
add two properties which are length and
width of a rectangle and then we'll add
methods as well so how to add properties
to an object we'll write here the object
name dot property name so the object
name here is rec2 and the property name
will be length
equals to the value of length will be
let's say 5. and the second property we
have is the width and we'll write here
rec2 dot width and the value for this
will be let's say 10 so we are done with
the properties here next up we'll add
the methods as well so let's add the two
methods as well in this object uh two
methods are the get area and the get
parameter method the Syntax for adding
methods to an object goes like this we
are adding a method get area right so
we'll write here the object name
dot method name so let's save our method
name is get area
followed by n equals to sign n
we'll write a function and then the body
of the method so this get area method
will return the area of a rectangle
right so we'll use this keyword again as
we did in the last video by now I hope
you guys are aware of this keyword so
we'll write here return this Dot
length into
this dot width so this method will
return the area of a rectangle next up
we have another method which is
we'll write here rec2 Dot
get perimeter
for printing the parameter of a
rectangle
so we'll again write here function and
then we have the body of the function so
this method will return the parameter so
the parameter of rectangle goes like
2 into length
plus 2 into width
so here we are done with the object next
up we'll print these values on the
browser so we'll use the same code for
printing which we used in the previous
video
so we'll copy it from here and we'll
paste it here so what we have to change
here is we have to change the name of a
object so we'll write here Act 2 in
place of rect 1 and we are good to go
let's save this so here you can see we
have made a mistake here so you can see
that it is not printing the parameter of
a rectangle right so the mistake here is
we forgot to mention the this keyword
here
so we'll write here this dot length and
this dot width so let's save this now
and
see we have the length width area and
parameter of the rectangle so the area
is 10 into 5 which is 50 and the
parameter is 2 into 10 plus 2 into 5 so
20 plus 10 equals to 13. so we have the
parameter here as well and if you guys
remember we had the same output in the
previous video as well so the difference
between the object Constructor method
and the object literal method is almost
negligible right the main difference is
that the initial part of the code so the
main difference lies here the syntax is
a bit different in the object literal
method we used curly braces and in the
object Constructor method we use the
parenthesis of course there are some
more minor differences but the code
looks almost the same in the end so the
advantage of the literal object method
over the object Constructor method is it
is easy to use syntax wise also it
executes faster than this method because
we Define all the properties and Methods
at a single place while defining the
object right
so this is the difference between the
object literal method and the
object Constructor method so we'll
comment this program now and let's move
ahead and discuss another way of
creating an object which is the
Constructor function method this way of
creating an object is a bit different
from the other two ways which we
discussed till now it is used when we
work with multiple instances of an
object it works like we have a template
and we can access that template using
multiple objects so if we want to make
more than one object and we don't want
to write the code again and again for
each object we can use this method when
we have more than one object if you guys
remember like in the previous video
where we took the example of a car we
created an object car and then we
created multiple instances wherein we
use those instances for different car
manufacturers
let's take a look at this method first
and then we'll discuss the advantages of
using this method as well
so as the name suggests the method
starts with function and then we'll
write the name of the function let's say
we have Rec
and then inside the opening and closing
round brackets we'll pass the properties
as parameters so let's take a look we'll
write Here length
comma width so we have these two
properties only and then we have the
body of the function so inside the
functions body we'll write the
properties and we'll use this keyword
here what we'll do is we'll use this dot
property name equals to property name
so
we'll write here this
dot length
equals to
length
so this is the Syntax for adding any
property to a function what we just did
is whenever we are going to create an
object using this Constructor function
method we'll pass certain values we'll
pass the length and the width right so
all these values will be present at the
rhs so all these values will be present
here and this dot length will be the
actual property of the object so let's
move ahead and add the second property
as well
will write here
this Dot
width
equals to
so we had two methods as well right
let's add them here inside the
Constructor function
we'll use this keyword again
we'll write here
this Dot
get area
and we'll write your function
with opening and closing round brackets
and the body of the function so this
method will again return the area of a
rectangle so we'll write here return
length
into
width
so there's a difference in these two
methods so here we use this keyword here
and in the previous method we used this
keyword inside the
method right so there's a difference in
these two methods so now what we'll do
we'll add another method so the next
method is this Dot
get parameter
and the syntax will be the same we'll
write a function
then the body of the function
we'll write return
2 into length
Plus
2 into width
so here we are done with the Constructor
function now all we have to do is we
have to create an object and we'll pass
the parameters as well so let's say we
are creating an object here
for that we have to write a where and
the object name so let's say the object
name is R1
and after the equals to we have to write
the new keyword and the
name of the function so we'll write Here
track 3 and we'll pass the parameters so
let's say the parameters are 5 and 10
because we use these parameters in other
two videos as well so we'll write here
five and ten let's suppose we want to
print the area and parameter so here we
are done with the printing part so what
we are printing is we are printing the
area of the rectangle and the perimeter
of the rectangle so we have called these
two methods using the
object name so we have written here R1
dot get area and R1 dot get parameter
similarly if we want to print the length
and width we can do that as well what we
have to do is we have to write
document dot right
and let's say we are printing them
simply we'll write here
R1 Dot
length
and then we'll copy this
right here bit so here we are done with
the total process and now we will save
this program and see we have the values
here the value of length is 5 because we
have passed the parameter S5 and then we
have the value of width which is 10 and
this is also because of the parameter
then we have the area of rectangle which
is 10 into 5
so it is 50 and then we have the
parameter as 30. so the advantage of
using this method is we can create more
objects if you want to add one more
object here let's say we are using where
R2 and we want to print let's say the
parameters are different here let's say
we are giving as 4 and 10 or let's say
we are giving in 4 and 8.
so what we have to do is we have to copy
all this and we have to change the value
here as instead of R1 wheel
use R2 here again we'll use R2
and then we have to update the value of
R2 here and we are good to go now so
let's save this program and see we have
the
values for other object as well so here
we have 4 as length and then we have 8
as width and the area is 8 into 4 which
is 32 and the parameter is 2 into 8
which is 16 and 2 into 4 which is 8 so
16 plus 8 is 24. till now we came across
several different ways of creating an
object in JavaScript right we can create
an object using the object literal
method or we can do it with the help of
the Constructor function so by now I
hope you guys are aware of how to create
an object and how to add properties and
methods to an object like we can create
methods that perform several specific
tasks if we talk about a method in
particular if you guys remember in the
previous video we created a program for
the area and parameter of rectangle so
in that program we created a method get
area which Returns the area of the
rectangle right so we had to call that
method and we can sit back and relax
because we know that it will print the
area of the rectangle right
so let's move ahead and today we will
discuss a completely new topic which is
prototypes in JavaScript so for this
video we are going to use console for
printing that's because it will be easy
for you guys to understand the concept
of prototypes if you use the console
instead of using a normal document.write
method
so let me do one thing guys we'll print
a statement on the console
so
we'll write here
console.log and will print
let's say
welcome to Simply code
so let's save this and if we open
console here in our browser
we have to go to inspect and then we
have to go to console and here you can
see we have welcome to Simply code
written over here
so in the last video we talked about
creating an object with the help of
object literal method right so let's
suppose we are creating an object here
with the help of same object literal
method so what we have to do we have to
create an empty object first so let's
say our object name is ABC
and we'll use the curly braces here so
what we have to do is we have to pass
the properties here so let's suppose our
properties are name and the value of
name let's say
caution followed by a comma and then we
have let's say subject value of subject
will be
let's say JavaScript
and then finally we have the
address so let's say the value of
addresses Bangalore right
this is a basic object we made right if
we write here console.log ABC so if we
want to print this object on the console
so what we'll do here we'll write
console.log and then we'll use ABC so
let's save this now and here you can see
on the console that we have our
objective so we have our object with all
the three properties we have address as
Bangalore we have name as causal and
subject as JavaScript
so if you guys look here carefully you
will notice that we have one more entity
here that is we have underscore
underscore Proto
so what is this underscore underscore
Proto
so all right we mentioned all the other
three properties in our object but we
didn't do anything for this underscore
underscore Proto so let's discuss this
now let's take a scenario wherein
someone told us to create a website like
let's suppose we have to make a travel
website through which people can book
their travel destinations now do we have
to start creating the website from
scratch no that's because we have some
of the necessary conditions already
fulfilled like we have Chrome we already
have bootstrap for styling and all and
we can use bootstrap to design a website
right so we have certain things already
present and we have to work over them to
create our website similarly prototype
refers to the destination from where we
started to create an object like we have
methods for arrays we have objects and
strings as well so all these methods are
being inherited from somewhere so
whenever we create an object using the
object literal method then it will start
creating the object from the object dot
prototype so if we click here on the
underscore underscore Proto we have
access to a list of methods already
present within the object dot prototype
so and all of them are predefined we can
use any of them we didn't Define them
they are already present we Define only
these three properties like we defined
address name and subject only
in simple words all JavaScript objects
inherits properties and methods from a
prototype date objects inherit from date
dot prototype and similarly when we use
array objects they inherit from
array.prototype so the object.prototype
is on the top of the Prototype
inheritance chain so date objects array
objects and person objects all these
objects inherit their properties from
object dot prototype so moving on now
let's create another object so we talked
about the object literal method so here
we don't have too much to do so let's
move ahead and we'll create another
object this time we'll create it with
the help of a Constructor function so
let's create a function here first let's
say we have a function named as function
XYZ
so then we have the parameters as name
and then we have we'll take all these
three properties we will take name
subject and let's say
address
so then we have the body of the function
inside which will use the this keyword
will write here this dot name equals to
name
similarly this Dot address equals to
address
and finally we have this Dot
subject equals to subject
so we'll create an instance now let's
say we are creating an object let's say
our object name is where
X1 and we'll write here new
and then we'll write XYZ and we'll pass
the values so let's say the name is
and we have
subject as let's change the subject
we'll write here Java and we have
finally have the address let's say the
address is Earth
okay so the values are different from
the previous example we took what we'll
do now we'll write here
console.log and we'll print
X1 now so we are done creating an object
and here we have a Constructor function
named XYZ and then we have few
properties which are the same as we used
in the previous example so then we have
an object named X1 which holds the
values for all three properties and
lastly we printed the object on the
console so let's save it now and we can
see here in console we have the object
with all the properties this almost no
difference here from the object literal
method right but when we click here on
the Pro 2 here we can encounter the
difference now you can see here we have
one more entity here named as the
Constructor so this Constructor here has
its own prototype
so this Constructor here has its own
prototype if you use a Constructor in a
program it always has its own prototype
this might seem a bit difficult to you
guys but don't worry it will be apparent
to you guys once we move on to the usage
and modifications of prototype so here
we are with the two examples in the
first one we created an object with the
help of object literal method there we
saw that it has only a single prototype
that is the object prototype later when
we moved on to the Constructor function
method we realized that there are two
different prototypes present one is the
Prototype which is available every time
that is the object dot prototype and the
other one is the constructor's OWN
prototype it might sound a little hard
to you guys but prototype is nothing but
it refers to the point from where it all
started from where we have inherited all
the properties
so we can make changes to the Prototype
of our own object like if we want to add
something to our prototype we can do it
we have a method for that in JavaScript
we'll do it later in this video we can't
make changes to the object prototype
remember this thing guys I'll suggest
you not to edit the object dot prototype
because it's not a good practice to make
changes in that if you want to edit any
prototype then we have to make sure that
we are making changes in our own
prototype that we made with the help of
Constructors the Prototype made by us is
also inherited from the object dot
prototype if we want to make another
prototype here we can do it like if we
are going to add utility functions to
our program but at the same time we
don't want to do anything with the
properties of a Constructor function we
can make another prototype for that we
can create a prototype for separate
method so if we want to add a method in
this Constructor function we can do it
we can add it separately with the help
of prototypes so for that we have to
follow a syntax a particular syntax we
can do it this way like we have to write
here x y z dot prototype and then we
have to write the method name let's say
we are writing here
get name
fine we'll write here function
and then we have the body of the
function so let's suppose this method
Returns the name
so we'll write here
return
this
dot name so if we try to run this
program now we can see there is no
difference from the previous one but if
we check the prototypes now so here you
can see we have another prototype named
as get name
so this is how we can edit the Prototype
of our object now if we try to access
this get name method with the help of X1
object so we can do it so let's try to
do it on Console we'll write here X1 dot
get name
and
see here we have the output as caution
similarly let's create one more
prototype here to remove any sort of
confusion so what we'll do we'll create
another
prototype so let's say we are creating a
prototype for
address now so what we'll do we'll write
here x y z Dot
prototype
Dot
get
address
so it will be a method so we'll write
here function
we don't have to pass any parameters
here
so let's suppose it returns
the value of address
so we'll write here this dot address and
we are good to go so let's save it now
and if we go to Pro underscore
underscore Pro 2 we can see we have one
more prototype here named as get address
so what we have to do now is we'll make
another object let's say we are copying
this from here we'll paste it here
so let's change the values let's say we
write here Mars and then we have let's
change the subject basically because we
are
looking for the subject so let's change
this value as well
let's say we have here
simply code
and we'll change the name of the object
let's say we have X2 now save it and if
we write here
X2 Dot
let's say get name
so here you can see the output as Simply
Good similarly if we write here instead
of get name we write here get address
so here you can see the output as Mars
because the value we passed while
creating the object is Mars here so we
can access this value directly using the
Prototype method so if we use the object
Constructor function if you guys
remember we cannot add a new property to
an existing object for example if we try
to add a property here let's say if we
try to add a property to this existing
function what we can write here is
x y z Dot
grades
let's say the grid is
e
so if we save this now
here you can see there's nothing changed
here so we don't have any change in the
prototypes or we don't have any changes
in the properties as well so we simply
can't add a property to an existing
function like this but we have a method
for this also so to add a new property
to a Constructor we must add it to the
Constructor function or we can use the
Prototype property here as well so the
JavaScript prototype property allows us
to add new properties to a object
Constructor just like we added the
methods to a Constructor function
previously similarly we can add
properties as well so we have to write
here so we'll remove this line
we have to write here x y z Dot
prototype
and then we have to write the property
name here let's say we are writing here
grids and then we'll pass the value
let's say the grade is a
so if we save this now and if we go back
here and if we check the underscore
underscore Pro 2. so here you can see we
have a property here named as grades and
values a so if we try to print X1 dot
grade in our console so the output will
be a so let's try to do it here
we'll write here
2 Dot
grids
and here you can see the value is a here
so we can add a property to an existing
Constructor function with the help of
prototype methods so this is the basic
usage of prototypes in JavaScript we can
use prototypes to add a property or a
method to an already existing
Constructor function so guys inheritance
is an essential Concept in any
object-oriented programming language
inheritance refers to the procedure
through which one class or one
Constructor inherits the properties and
methods of another Constructor in simple
terms let's suppose we have a
Constructor named as vehicle and we know
we have different types of vehicles
present like we have cars and we have
bikes as well so all these types share a
few things in common right and now if we
want to create a Constructor let's say
we want to create a Constructor bike and
we want it to have a few of the same
properties and methods as of the
vehicles Constructor
so in that case we are left with two
options either we can copy the
properties from vehicle Constructor and
paste them inside the bike Constructor
or we can simply use inheritance to
inherit those properties from the
vehicle Constructor to the bike
Constructor in this case the vehicle
class will be known as a base class and
the bike Constructor or class will be
known as derived Constructor because we
derived a few properties from the
vehicle Constructor right
don't worry guys I know the concept of
classes might be new for you and the
concept of inheritance might seem a bit
different from other languages like if
you are coming from a C plus plus
background you may notice that there we
use classes for the concept of
inheritance but in JavaScript before the
introduction of es6 that is ecmascript
6. the concept of inheritance was based
on Constructors and prototypes so with
the introduction of ecmascript 6 the
idea of classes was also introduced in
JavaScript and the usage of inheritance
was also changed we'll discuss classes
and inheritance in the next video today
we are going to discuss the traditional
way of using prototypes for inheritance
so don't be stressed guys if you are not
clear with the syntax of inheritance by
the end of this video in the next video
you will understand the concept and
syntax of inheritance without any
confusion
so we'll now talk about a few things so
let's start with the programming part so
guys whenever we create an object with a
method like we can create an object with
the help of object literal method or we
can do the same with the help of
Constructor function method as well
right then we have a prototype every
time you might have noticed it we have
been through it in the past few videos
so every time we create an object we
notice that it has a prototype now what
we will do here is we'll create a
prototype so the syntax will be like so
we'll write here const we are using
const in place of variable I hope you
guys are aware of cons to wear and let
keywords so today we are using here
const so let's say the prototype name is
employee
we'll write equals to and then we have
the body of the Prototype let's do one
thing now we'll use a method let's say
the method name is post post of the
employee
and we'll write here
function and then we have the body of
the function so let's say this function
returns a string so we'll write here
return and let's say the function
returns a
software developer and then we have
another function named as change name
and we'll write your function
will pass a parameter
and then we have the body of this method
so we'll write here this dot name
is equal to name and we are good to go
right
so what we did here is we created a
prototype of the name employee and it
has two functions one is the employees
post and the other one is to change the
name so let's save this program and
check it in the console if it has any
errors so let's save it now and we'll go
here and
check on the console
so here you can see everything is fine
so till now we created a prototype now
let's create an object as well so what
we'll do
we'll create an object here we'll write
here let's say where and let's say the
object name is even
so we'll create an object with the help
of
object Dot
create method
okay so we have to write here Dot
so we have to pass the prototype name so
we'll write here employee and then what
we'll do we'll print this on a console
so we'll write a console.log
and we'll write here even let's say so
we created an object even with the help
of object.create method let's save it
and check it on the console if we see
here we don't have anything else other
than a single prototype right we have a
single prototype here we have no method
mentioned so if we open it we have the
two methods of course we have post and
we have changed name but if we write
here let's say we are writing here even
dot name and then value of name will be
let's say
kaushal
and then we'll assign a rule as well
let's see these are the two new
properties
we'll write here even dot role and let's
say the
a role of causal is
writer
fine and if we save it and check it
again on the console
now what we did is we changed the name
and Rule right so these are the two
properties we have both name as kaushal
and Rule as writer now let's see if we
can use the methods here as well
so we'll write here let's say we are
using the method even Dot
change name what we'll do here is we'll
change the name from kaushal to
something else let's say we are going to
change the name as
Ram
so if we save this now so here you can
see the name is changed to Ram initially
the name was kaushal and when we use the
change name method now you can see here
the name is changed to Ram so this means
that the methods we defined inside the
Prototype are working right now let's
say we want to create another object
here we created an object even till now
we assign some properties to it and we
changed the name and printed it on the
console now let me tell you guys an
alternate way to do so
so what we'll do is we'll copy this line
from here because the syntax of that
method also looks a bit same so the
syntax will remain the same till here so
we'll paste it here what we'll do next
is
we'll pass a few arguments here
so let's pass the arguments first then
I'll explain it to you guys so what we
are going to do is we are going to use
curly braces for arguments
and we are going to write here
it's a name and the value of name will
be we are going to write here
value
and we'll pass the value as let's say
causal 2 right
so we'll use a comma here then we'll use
roll and
will pass the value of rule as well so
let's say the value of rule is
programmer now
right put a comma here now I know the
syntax is a bit complicated but this is
the reason why classes were introduced
in es6 so this is the reason we will be
using classes in future but going
through this syntax will make the next
one easier for you guys so we have
created an object here with the
object.create method and we passed few
arguments here so we have name and the
value of name we want it to be causal 2
and the value of role we want it to be
programmed so if we copy this from here
or let's say if we copy these two lines
from here if we cut these two lines from
here and we'll paste it here
so if you see here we have two objects
of the same name we have where even and
here also we have variable now both
these syntaxes are doing the same thing
that is creating an object of the same
name suppose if we comment this first
object let's say we are commenting this
one and we'll also comment this line if
we save this now and if we see on our
console so here you can see we have the
name as kaushal2 and Rule as programmer
so these two syntaxes are doing exactly
the same thing the only thing to notice
here is if we use this line with this
syntax if we use even dot change name
and if we save this now you can see it
is not working in this case right so if
we want to do it we have to write
some more code so what we have to do is
we have to write here
writeable
and we have to
pass the value as true
so what we are doing is we are allowing
this method to change the name from
causal 2 to Ram so if we save it now
here you can see the name is Ram now
earlier it was causal 2 and now this is
working totally fine right so both the
syntaxes are doing the same things as we
can see here the reason behind going
through this is we need the syntax of
creating objects later in this video so
I hope you guys understood it
now moving ahead let's take a look at
prototypal inheritance so what we are
going to do is we are going to comment
this code
so we are going to comment all this and
we are going to write a new one for
prototypal inheritance
let's say we have a Constructor function
so let's create a Constructor function
first so what we are going to do is we
are going to write here let's say we are
going to create the same function we'll
take the same example of employee right
so we'll write a function employee and
we'll pass the properties here let's say
we are writing a name and another one is
ID and the last properties
salary of the employer right so next up
we have the body of the Constructor so
we'll write inside here this dot name
is equal to name
then we have this dot ID equals to ID
and then we have this Dot
salary equals to
salary
right
so we know this already right we'll now
add a method to the Prototype of the
employee so we'll write here we'll write
outside this Constructor will write here
employee
dot prototype Dot
post let's say the name of the method is
post so what we are going to do is we
are going to write your function
and then we have the body of the
function so let's say this Returns the
post of the employee what we'll do is
we'll write here return
and it will return the name plus post of
the employee right so we'll write here
this dot name
Plus
bit of space and then again
will write here
is a content creator let's say right so
we are done with the method here
as you can see what we did here is we
created a Constructor employee and added
a function that returns this string upon
calling so we haven't done anything
extra till now let's create an object
now so we'll write here let's say we are
creating an object
where caution and what we'll do is we'll
write a new underscore employee
and we'll pass the values here so let's
say the values are causal and the ID is
food let's say this is the ID
3432 or whatever it is and the salary
let's say is 10 000 okay so the next
thing is we'll write here console.log
and we'll print the value of question on
a console so let's save it now and here
you can see we have all the properties
here we have IDs 3432 name is kaushal
and salary as 10 000. here if you see
inside Proto you can see here we have a
method here name is post and we have
Constructor as employee and then we have
object as well now if we call the
Prototype post with this object so what
we have to do is we have to write here
in console we'll write a causal Dot
post
and here you can see we have the output
as causal is a content creator
till now it's fine right we did small
things which we learned in the previous
few videos so let's suppose we have
another employee named Arun and let's
assume he is also a content creator but
he's a master in JavaScript as well so
we want to mention it here along with
all these properties we have Name ID and
salary which we will inherit from this
employee Constructor and apart from that
we'll add another property which is the
subject or which is the language
property
so we have to create a new Constructor
here for it so what we'll do is we'll
write here
function and then we'll write the name
of this Constructor so let's say
the name is function programmer
so we'll write here name
will pass all the properties we'll write
a Name ID salary
and finally we have the language right
then we have the body of the Constructor
the first three properties will remain
the same right only subject or language
we have added languages so only language
will be added now we'll inherit these
properties from employee before the
concept of class was introduced
inheritance was based on prototypes only
so we'll see the concept of classes in
the upcoming video so
here what we are going to do is we are
going to call this employee
Constructor so we'll write here
employee Dot
call and will pass the properties which
we want to inherit so we'll write here
first this and first we have to write
this keyword and then we have to write
other properties so we'll write a Name
ID salary
what we did is we call the function
employee and asked it to provide all the
three mentioned properties to the
function programmer
we'll set the value of language by Ursel
we'll write here
this dot language
equals to
language now if we create an object for
the Constructor program what it will do
is it will take all the properties from
the employee and language will be added
to those properties let's do it first so
we'll
create an object here we'll write here
where let's say the object name is Arun
and we'll write a new
programmer
and will pass the values let's say the
name is Arun
ID is four three two one
and salary is let's say 12 000
and finally we have to add the subject
here as well or we can say language so
let's say the language is
JavaScript
next thing we are going to do is we we
are going to print this on Console so
we'll write a console.log
and we'll print a rune
right let's save it and see here we have
all the properties available with the
provided values we have name as Arun we
have ids4321 salary is twelve thousand
and language is Javascript so this is
how we can inherit the properties in the
derived Constructor from the base
Constructor the base Constructor is the
employee and the derived is a programmer
so coming back to the console we can see
here we have all the four properties
right
three of them are inherited and the last
one was assigned by us but I don't know
if you guys noticed here that we have
the properties only of the Constructor
so we don't have any method here right
so if we see here we don't have any
method of Constructor employee because
here you can see we have a method as
post and if we see here we don't have
any method so
if we write here let's say if we write
here in a console we are writing here
let's say Arun dot post
and we'll
run it so here you can see it says
around dot post is not a function
right this is because the Prototype post
is not assigned to the Constructor
programmer for that we have to write
some extra code we have to write here
so we have to write here
programmer dot prototype calls to object
Dot
create and we have to mention the
employee prototype
so we'll write here Arun dot post now
so here you can see it says Arun is a
content creator so we have to provide
the prototypes manually as well
let me show you guys one more thing now
see here it is not showing the
Constructor if we click here on the
Proto we don't have any Constructor here
named as programmer
so we have to set the Constructor as
well we have to set it manually and to
set the Constructor manually we have to
write here after this line we have to
write here programmer dot prototype
Dot
Constructor
equals to programmer if we save this
program now and if we go back to our
console and if we check here here you
can see we have a Constructor named as
programmer now
so you guys might be thinking that we
have to work a lot for all this
inheritance right the fact is we
actually had to do it before es6 was
introduced now if you want to do the
same with the help of classes the syntax
will be so easy we'll go through it in
the next video so that's all for this
video guys see you in the next one where
we will go through classes and
inheritance in JavaScript let's move on
and take a look at classes in JavaScript
a class is nothing but a template used
for creating objects in JavaScript just
like the Constructor function we can
also use classes for creating object in
JavaScript we can include properties and
behaviors in our class creating a class
is a pretty easy job to do the syntax is
somewhat the same as that of a
Constructor function so let's move on to
the programming part if you guys are
coming from any other object oriented
programming language like we have C plus
plus Java PHP and many more object
oriented programming language right so
you may have an idea about classes the
Syntax for classes in JavaScript is also
not so different from other languages
don't worry if you are going through
classes for the first time will have a
look at classes so let's move on to the
syntax
and to declare a class we use the class
keyword followed by the name of the
class and the body of the class so we'll
write a class so this is the keyword we
use for the Declaration of a class then
we have the name of the class so let's
say we have the name as student here and
then we use curly braces for the body of
the class so this is an empty class
named as student we know that this
student has a name age roll number and
many more properties right so the next
thing we are going to do is we can
define the properties here only in fact
the Syntax for defining properties is
also the same as we had in the
Constructor function so let's define the
properties first so let's say we have
three properties here name agent roll
number so we'll write here this dot name
is equals to name
and then we have this dot h is equals to
H
and the last property is this Dot
roll number so let's say we are writing
a rule so equals to role
so we have all the three properties of
student we have name age and roll number
so we have to create a Constructor here
which will be executed while we create
an object or we can say an instance of
this class so the Syntax for creating a
Constructor will go like we have to
write here Constructor
and we have to pass all these three
arguments here we have to pass name
then we have age and then we have a roll
number so all these three arguments we
have to pass here and also these
properties will be kept inside
the body of this Constructor
so this is the basic syntax of how we
are going to create a class in
JavaScript so we have all the three
properties here we have name we have H
and we have roll number if you guys
notice here the Syntax for the
Constructor function looks a bit similar
to the syntax of the Constructor
function method which we came across in
the previous few videos right
so what we are doing is we created a
class first with the name student then
we defined all the properties of this
class inside the Constructor so by now
things are going easy right that's
because the Syntax for classes is
relatively easy to use compared to other
methods
also we don't have to write code
manually for different things we will
understand it much better while working
on inheritance so let's move on and we
will add some methods to this class now
the Syntax for adding a method is super
simple guys we don't have to write here
a function name followed by a colon and
then we have the function keyword no
we'll just write here the function name
and parenthesis so to add a method here
we'll write here let's say we are adding
a method organization so let's say we
have a method org okay so we have to
write org and
a pair of round brackets that's all this
is the Syntax for defining a method in
classes so let's say we want this
function to return a string along with
the name of the student so let's say we
are writing a return
and let's say we want it to return
I am dot name from
simply code okay
so let's say we are passing a value here
as causal and we want this function to
return I am causal from Simply code
so similarly We'll add another function
here
which is for the date of birth of
student
so let's see we'll write here
DOB
and then we have the body of the
function so we want this function to
return the date of birth of a student
right so let's say we are in the year
2020 what we want to do is we have the
age of student let's say the age is 21
and what we are going to do next is we
are going to subtract the age from
current year so 2020 minus this dot h
will return the date of birth of student
right so we'll write here
return let's say we wanted to return a
string as well let's say the date of
birth
of
this dot name
Is 2020 minus this dot each
fine so here we are done with a string
so we want it to return the date of
birth of kaushal is
let's say 1999 if we are providing the
value as 21 then it will return 1999
right let's move ahead and create an
object first so let's say we have an
object named as
kaushal and what we are going to do is
we are going to write here new
and we are going to call the class so
we'll write here
student and then we'll pass the values
here so let's say the name is kaushal
the age is 21
and we have roll number is 45 so we have
all the three properties here right next
up we are going to print this on a
console so we'll write a console.log
and we'll print caution
so let's say if it's working or not save
it and here you can see on our console
we have a student class we have all the
three values we have ages 21 name as
kaushal and roll number as 45 if we go
inside this underscore underscore Pro 2
we can see here we have both the methods
here we have org and dub so let's try to
call these methods first so what we are
going to do is we are going to write on
our console
causal Dot dub
so here you can see we have the output
as the date of birth of kaushal is 1999.
similarly if we try to call function
kaushal Dot
org
so you can see here we have the output
as I am kaushal from Simply code right
so here you can see both the methods are
working fine we have both the outputs
here
the first one says the date of birth of
kaushal is 1999 and the next one gives
us the organization name so moving ahead
let me guys tell you about another
Concept in classes we'll now discuss
static functions in classes
we have to use the static keyword to
define a static method followed by the
method name so if we want to define a
static method what we have to do is we
have to use the
static keyword so the static keyword is
always followed by the name of the
method so let's say we are creating a
method here let's say for adding two
numbers so we'll write here the method
name is ADD
and then we have the body of this method
so what we want to do is we want to add
two numbers right so we have to pass
here two parameters as well we'll write
here a comma B
and then we want it to return the sum
right so we'll write here return
a
plus b
this looks fine right
notice here guys we don't have to use
anything from the class or the object
like in the previous two methods we used
the name and the H property right so
here we use this dot name and then we
used this dot age as well but here this
method is not related to object at any
cost the best part about the static
method is we can use static methods
without creating the instances of a
class so if we want to access this
particular method here we can do it with
the help of class name followed by the
dot operator and the method name so
let's try to access this method once
what we are going to do is we are going
to write console.log
and we are going to access this method
with the class name so we'll write here
student dot add and will pass the values
here so let's say we are passing 10 and
45 fine so let's see if it works or not
so save it and here you can see we have
the output as 55 so this is how we can
create or use static methods in classes
let's move on now and we will discuss
inheritance with the help of classes in
JavaScript by now we are clear with the
meaning of inheritance right guys we
discussed in the last video that
inheritance is the procedure through
which one class inherits the properties
and methods of another class so today we
are going to see how we can Implement
inheritance with classes in JavaScript
although the concept will remain the
same we will create another class here
and will inherit the properties of this
existing class with some more properties
of the derived class I hope you guys
know the difference between Base Class
and derived class so the class we are
going to create now will be the derived
class so let's move ahead and create a
class
let's say we are creating a class here
so let's save
for creating a class we have to write
class let's say the class name is
student
and if we want to inherit the properties
of the above class which is student one
we have to use a particular syntax so we
have to write the
extents keyword here so this is a
keyword extensor is a keyword which is
used for inheritance and then we will
write the name of the class which we
want to inherit so we'll write here
student
and then we have the body of the class
here we have a class student one that
inherits the properties of class student
next up we'll create a Constructor
function here and we'll pass all the
properties we want to be there for the
class student one so we'll pass the
Constructor function similarly like we
did in the previous class so we'll write
here Constructor and we'll pass all the
properties we want to be there for class
student one so we have the first three
properties are name which we are going
to inherit from the above class then we
have H and then we have
rule number right so let's add two more
properties here let's say the true
properties are language and then we have
section as well fine
so then we have the body of the
Constructor
so you can see here we have five
properties three of these five are
inherited from class
student and the rest two are those
properties that we want to add for class
students one exclusively the Syntax for
inheritance in classes is not a tough
one though still we have to keep a few
things in mind mainly the next statement
we are going to write here is an
important one it goes like we use the
super keyword
and then we'll
pass all the properties which we want to
inherit from the class in this
particular case we want to inherit these
three properties here right so we'll
copy this from here and we'll paste it
remember one thing guys we'll write only
those properties which we want to
inherit from other class
actually this super keyword we used here
refers to the parent class we use it to
call the parent classes Constructor or
we can also call particular properties
and methods with the help of super
keyword
next up we'll Define the two new
properties the language and the section
now
so the syntax will remain the same we'll
write here this dot language is equals
to language
and then we'll write this Dot
section
is equal to section
we are good to go now we'll create an
object for this class as well
which is student one so let's say we are
creating an object again
let's say the name of this object is
let's remove it first so let's say we
are creating an object for this class
now let's say the name of this object is
Arun and we are going to write a new
then we have the class name which is
student one and then we'll pass the
values here so let's say the name is
Arun then we have the ages 35 and then
we have roll number as three or two
and then we have the language so let's
say the language is Javascript and then
we finally have the section as well so
let's say the section is
a fine so we have all the five values
here we have around 35 to JavaScript and
a right so let's print this on our
console
we'll write a console.log and will print
Arun
let's save it now and here you can see
we have a student one with all the
properties and values we have age is 35
language JavaScript name is Arun roll
number S2 and section is e if we click
here on underscore underscore Pro 2. you
can see here we have a Constructor
student when along with that we have all
the methods of the previous class of the
base class we have org we have dob as
well right so this is how inheritance
work in JavaScript the key benefit of
using inheritance with classes is that
if we remember from the previous video
if we want to access any Base Class
method then traditionally we had to
manually provide the Constructor right
but in classes we don't have to do any
such thing once we are done with
inheriting the properties and all we can
directly access the methods as well
let's try to do it here on a console so
we'll write here
Arun dot let's suppose we are using org
so we'll write a arun.org and here you
can see we have the output as I am Arun
from Simply code
next up let's use the other method as
well so we'll write here
Arun and then we'll use
dub
so here you can see we have the date of
birth of arunis 1985 because we have
provided the value as 35 so 2020 minus
35 is 1985.
here we have the output as expected now
let's see if we can access the static
method or Not by using the derived class
so we'll try to access the static method
with the help of student one so let's
try to do it we'll write here
console.log and then we'll write here
student
one dot add and will pass the values
let's say the values are
65 and 8.
right
so we want the output as
73 now so let's see if it's working or
not so we'll save it and here you can
see we have the output as 73. so this is
a basic example of how inheritance works
with classes in JavaScript hope you guys
got it let's start this video with the
introduction to Dom
Dom stands for document object model it
is an API for HTML and XML documents
which helps JavaScript to understand
what is their return inside the HTML
document API stands for application
programming interface to understand API
better let's take an example of a
restaurant
imagine yourself in the restaurant you
are sitting at the table with the menu
the chef in the kitchen is also part of
the system the waiter here works as a
messenger between you and the chef
that's what API does it works as a
moderator between JavaScript and the
HTML document
Dom defines the hold HTML document in a
hierarchical form to make it
understandable for JavaScript so that
other JavaScript functions can work over
it it represents the entire document in
the form of object and nodes whether it
be elements or text or anything stored
in the document the entire page content
can be accessed or manipulated by
JavaScript Dom is not used with
JavaScript only other languages like
python also uses dom dom was designed to
be used independently to begin with dom
there is nothing special you have to do
different browsers have different
implementation of the document object
model every browser uses Dom to make the
web page of the document accessible by
JavaScript let's move on and see what is
document object model with the help of
an example I believe you guys have the
basic knowledge of HTML and CSS a
prerequisite for this course let's start
things off with a basic HTML example
here we have a code that consists tags
like HTML head body heading tag Etc we
have the HTML tag here the opening HTML
tag and the closing HTML tag inside the
HTML tag we have the head tag which
contains the documents header part
inside the headtech there is a title tag
that contains the title of the web page
then comes the body tag which contains a
heading tag and two div tags with IDs as
div 1 and div2 a div tag defines a
particular section in the HTML document
the ID used within the div tag it is an
attribute basically that has to be
unique within the document to make the
element unique from other elements next
up we have a paragraph tag with a class
attribute within it CSS and JavaScript
uses classes to select and access
specific elements don't worry guys if
you have no idea about it let us first
see the output of this code before going
to the document object model of this
whole document so guys this is the
output of the previous code we just came
through here we can see the title of the
web page as well as heading after it
there were two different div tags used
in the code here is the output of both
the div tags the question here is where
are those ID and class attributes seen
in the output the answer to this
question is there is nothing on this web
page that can show both of them we can
use them in our CSS file or through
JavaScript to specify the containers in
which they are used so we have concluded
how a normal document works and how the
browser interprets the HTML cool but how
JavaScript uses this code is a bit
different that's where Dom comes into
play when the actual HTML document is
loaded in the browser another
representation of that document is
created known as document object model
here's the model you can see on your
screen
each of the tags used in HTML document
is correspondingly represented as object
in the Dom next starting from the HTML
10 and covering all the other tags like
head title body and few more the same
hierarchy as there was in the HTML
document goes with the document object
model also document to object model is
simply the same HTML document with
different representation the reason
behind this different representation is
that it's easy for JavaScript to
interpret this format JavaScript can't
understand tags but it can understand
these objects JavaScript can easily
manipulate these objects using different
functions which we will see in future
while working on these function for
example if you want to access the text
present inside the heading tag you can
do it by accessing The Heading tag with
JavaScript you can also work on the
style of this text with the help of
JavaScript as well JavaScript uses the
concept of nodes it can access nodes of
the document object model there are many
types of nodes present in the Dom the
basic three types are element node
attribute node and text node the element
node consists of all the tags used in
HTML document like the head tag and the
body tag the attribute node contains the
attributes used in HTML document by now
I hope you have understood the concept
of attributes so JavaScript can access
these attributes as well and the user
can work upon them as per requirements
the text here in the HTML document that
is simply it can also be accessed with
the help of JavaScript it is the value
of that particular element
as we know the document object model is
simply the same HTML document with a
different representation right the
reason behind this diverse
representation is that it's easy for
JavaScript to interpret this format
JavaScript can't understand tags in an
HTML document but it can understand
these objects therefore JavaScript can
easily manipulate these objects using
different functions which we'll discuss
in today's video so if you haven't
watched the previous video on what is
document object model I'll suggest you
to go through it before we move on to
the Dom manipulation
in this tutorial we will understand the
basics of how we can use JavaScript
while creating or working on a website
it's like a real world application of
JavaScript in this particular video we
are going to discuss the window object
present in JavaScript we'll also see how
we can take input from the user for some
special tasks so let's move ahead and
discuss window object in JavaScript
a window object is actually a global
object present in the client-side
JavaScript that can be seen in a Chrome
browser let's move on to the programming
part directly and it will be easy for
you guys to understand
so let's write something on our console
first to see if the JavaScript file is
working fine or not so we'll write on
the console
we'll write here
console.log let's say we are printing a
string we'll write your welcome
to Simply code
right so we have to write a console.log
and we are good to go so save it and
here you can see we have the string
inner console so this means the browser
is working fine so let's create a
variable now let's say we are creating a
variable a and we'll write here window
let's suppose because we are talking
about the window object today now we
have written here window let's print
this variable on a console first and
then we'll see further so let's say we
are writing a console.log and we are
printing a on our console
save it and here you can see in the
console that we have the window object
here and if we click on this object see
we have a whole list of methods present
here inside the window object this
window object actually works the same as
the date object or the math object
present in JavaScript it also contains
methods that are predefined in
JavaScript to perform some specific
tasks
so here you can see we have an alert
method here
and we have many more methods right so
we have alert we have close we have
cookie store and so many other methods
as well if we go down here we can see we
have the document method here as well
so this document method contains the URL
of that HTML file and one can access it
if we copy it from here and if we
paste it here in a new tab so let's say
we are pressing enter and here you can
see we have the same HTML document we
have window.html open over here so this
document contains the URL of the HTML
file and one can access it with the
document method
next up we have two different ways of
using the window object in JavaScript
suppose if we want to use the alert
method so if you want to use the alert
method let's say we are writing here
window dot alert this is the first way
of using the alert method save it and
let's say we are providing a string here
let's say
hello everyone
fine
so save it and here you can see we have
a pop-up in the browser saying hello
everyone right so we have a pop-up here
if we remove the window keyword from
this statement like if we remove this
window keyword from here and if we say
okay and let's save this program again
and here you can see we have the same
output again
so this is how we can use methods
present within the window object in
JavaScript we can either write window
dot the method name or we can just write
the method name both will work fine
let's move ahead and talk about the
prompt method so guys you might have
noticed that we never took any input
from the user till now if we want to add
two numbers let's suppose and we want
the user to input those two numbers of
the user's choice we have to use the
prompt method here to do so so let's
create a simple program that will take
two inputs from the user and then it
will print the output on the console or
directly on the browser
so we have to create two variables to
store the values given by the user so
let's say we are commenting these lines
and we are creating two variables here
so let's say the first variable is where
X
and the next variable is where y so we
are not giving any values right now so
next up we'll use the prompt method in
both the variables so what we have to do
is we have to write here
prompt and we have to enter what we want
to print on that particular prompt so
we'll write here let's suppose enter the
value of
X and we'll do the same at y variable as
well so we'll copy it from here and
we'll paste it here and we'll write here
enter the value of y one thing to keep
in mind with prompt is whatever input
prompt takes from the user it takes the
input as a string suppose we try to run
this program okay if we are trying to
run this program let's say
we are writing here
console.log and we are printing X Plus y
so let's try to save it so here you can
see it says enter the value of x so
let's say we are entering 45 and then
again we are entering 50. so we want the
output as 95 the moment we will press OK
you can see here the output is four five
five zero because the input taken with
the help of prompt method will always be
a string so if we want this to be a
number what we have to do here is we
have to use the percent
right I hope you guys are aware of this
term percent it is used to change a
string value to a number value so we'll
write here percent
and we'll
put it inside a bracket so
similarly we will do the same for
variable y as well so now we can add two
numbers without any problem
so let's save this program again and
here we have the prompt which says enter
the value of x so let's say the value of
x is 50 again and we'll press enter then
let's say the value of y is again 45
fine
the moment the user presses enter after
inserting the desired value like the
moment we'll press enter it will print
the output as X Plus y so it will print
95 on the console so let's see if it
works press enter and here you can see
we have the output as 95.
so we can do one more thing here we can
print it on the browser as well for that
what we have to do is we have to write a
document Dot right and we have to pass
the values of X Plus y
so
let's save it now
and let's enter the value as 45 and 50
again so here you can see we have the
output as 95 on our browser so this
method is working totally fine
we'll use these two methods again in
other videos while manipulating an
actual HTML document with JavaScript in
the next video most probably so we'll go
through events and we'll see how
interesting it is to use JavaScript
along with HTML and CSS so for now let's
move ahead and take a look at another
method that is the confirm method we use
this method when we want to provide the
user with the choice of yes or no it
actually assigns a Boolean variable
whose value can be either true or false
depending upon okay or cancel whichever
button the user is clicking so let's see
the confirm method as well so what we'll
do we'll comment this
and again say we have a variable a as
window right so let's use this variable
so we'll write a equals to confirm and
any string we want to print so let's say
we are writing a are you sure
or anything else you want to write
so let's
write a console.log and we are printing
the value of a
fine
we have used console.log to print the
value this confirm method returns to
make it easy to understand so let's save
it and see here in the browser we have a
pop-up with a message are you sure and
we have two options right we have okay
and cancel
if we click here ok so let's click here
okay you can see in the
console we have the output as true so
and if we click cancel here so you can
see the output as false in the console I
hope you guys understood this so till
now we know about alert prompt and
confirm method the fun part is we don't
use these method too much in general
these days because we have bootstrap and
CSS for doing these operations more
efficiently these days so we are going
through these topics because these are
the basic topics one should know while
working on JavaScript we should have
knowledge about window object to
understand how JavaScript is embedded
with HTML to make beautiful and
responsive web pages
similarly the document is also a part of
this window object right so if we write
here let's comment this as well
and let's say if we write here
we have
variable a let's copy it from you and
we'll paste it here so let's say we have
a variable a and we'll write here window
Dot
document fine
next up we'll print variable a on a
console so we'll write here console.log
and we'll print the variable a
if we save it now and here you can see
we have the whole document here in the
console so if we click here you can see
we have the whole document we have all
the tags here we have head tag we have
body tag and even we have the script tag
as well so whatever tag we had in our
HTML documents all these tags are
written over here basically the entire
document is here right so we'll go
through Dom manipulation as well we'll
make changes to a particular HTML
document for now one thing I want you
guys to focus on is the window object
next up let's talk about the windows
inner width and inner height so if we
write here in the window.js if we write
here
window let's say window dot in a height
so save it and here you can see we have
the height as 149 now if we try to make
changes in the size of chrome let's say
if we try to change this size here and
let's refresh it see here we have the
output as 100 let's change it again and
refresh it again we can see the output
as one one
and let's do it once more so here you
can see we have the output as 144 now
similarly we can use in a width as well
so if we write here in a width and save
it here you can see we have the output
as three three five so if we change the
width of this particular document and
refresh it here you can see the output
is also changed to 564.
so these are the two methods the inner
height and the inner width we might use
them in further videos similarly we have
many more methods present within the
window object to perform specific tasks
we have the location we have scroll X
method we have scroll wire which works
the same as innovate and inner height
you can go through all these methods for
that you have to write here
variable a and window so save it now and
here you can see we have all the methods
present here
so these all are the methods we have
present within the window object so
there are more than 100 methods present
here or maybe more than 200 or 300
methods see scroll down you can see we
have a number of methods present here
you can go through any of these methods
so you guys can use them by yourself or
we'll discuss the important ones
whenever we need them this was a brief
intro to document object model
manipulation in this video we will start
with some Dom manipulations and later on
we'll be taking a look at the
document.getelement by ID method by now
we have come a long way from where we
begin now we know functions we know
classes data types and almost every
basic concept one needs to know while
working on JavaScript we know the
functioning of document object model
right we know that Dom is an API that
helps JavaScript understand what is
there written inside the HTML document
so Dom defines the whole HTML document
in a hierarchical form to make it
understandable for JavaScript so that
other JavaScript functions can work over
it right so by far we have a lot of
theoretical information about the
document object model in JavaScript we
also came across the window object
present in JavaScript and we know about
methods right but we never use to
JavaScript to manipulate Dom on any HTML
documents so today we are going to start
the video with the Dom manipulation so
in this video we are going to add some
functionality to our web page this means
that today we are working on a little
bit of HTML as well so let's move on to
the programming part and we'll see how
we can manipulate a basic design of a
web page and we'll try to manipulate it
with Dom so adding functionality to a
web page refers to doing tasks like we
want to perform validations or having
few text boxes for a phone number or
account number
so let's say we want only numbers to be
there inside these boxes or we don't
want them blank or any other
functionality we want to add then we can
use JavaScript so talking about HTML
let's do one thing here we'll create a
button with the help of button tag and
we already have this heading which the
h2 tag here right so we have this
heading Dom manipulation part two so it
is printed on a browser as well now what
we'll do is we'll create a button so
let's create an empty button first so
what we have to do here is we have to
write in this HTML document we have to
use the button tag and let's say the
button name will be
click here fine
so here we are we have created a button
save it and here you can see we have a
button named click here now talking
about events we have many events present
in HTML like if we are clicking on this
button so this is an event so if we
click here for now we can see nothing is
happening over here similarly we have
many standard events present in HTML
like click events scrolling events so if
you want to change the focus from one
text box to another or we are dragging
some text or selecting something or
double clicking on it as well what if we
target these particular events to
perform specific actions with the help
of JavaScript so these events are
basically the methods present within the
window object just like the on click
method we have we have the on click
method in window object right so we can
use on click method to perform some
specific tasks here so we'll see how we
can use on click method here for example
let's say we want this button to perform
a specific task when we click on it
right now if we click on this button
we can see nothing is happening over
here so let's say we want to show an
alert message on clicking over this
button so the flow of this click will be
like if we click here on this button
then something in the JavaScript code
has to register this activity and
perform some specific tasks like a
pop-up alert message or some sort of
other messages
so we have been through the alert method
present within the window object in the
last video so let's suppose we want a
pop-up when the user clicks on this
button so what is going to happen is
when we click over here where we want a
pop-up on our screen with a message
written over there so let's say we want
an alert with the message welcome to
Simply code right we can do it in
JavaScript with the help of functions we
already know functions right so
functions are statements we use to
perform some specific tasks we can call
them anytime here in this case if we
want to embed JavaScript within an HTML
document then what we have to do is we
have to use a window object method or
event we can say to call a function on
clicking the button
so we have to use the on click event so
let's try to do it what we'll do is
we'll write here button and over here
we'll write on click so here you can see
we have other methods or we can say
other events as well we have on can play
we have on double click we have on
scroll so we can use any of them so for
now let's suppose we are using on click
and we want to map it to the JavaScript
document so we can do it with the help
of functions so let's create a function
first so what we'll do we'll go to the
dot JS file and we'll create a function
here so let's say we are creating a
function named
function
let's say
button and then we have the opening and
closing round brackets and the body of
the function so we want this function to
return a pop-up with the message welcome
to Simply code right
so we'll write here alert
so I hope you guys are aware of this
alert term because we have seen we have
been through it in the last video so
we'll write here alert welcome
to Simply code
and we'll save it so if we call this
function over here only so what we have
to do is let's see if this function is
working fine or not so we'll write a
button and we'll call it so save it now
and if refresh this so here you can see
we have a pop-up with the message
welcome to Simply code so this function
is working totally fine we can use this
function with the HTML document as well
all we have to do is we have to write
the function name after the on click
event so we'll comment this statement
here and we'll go back to our HTML file
and we'll write the name of a function
here so our function name was
button
and here we have a function so save it
and here on the browser if we click on
this button so we can see the output as
a pop-up with the message welcome to
Simply code what it will do is it will
automatically call the function when the
user presses the button
so this is how we can map events in
JavaScript
will do so many such things in upcoming
videos like changing the style of text
and the on Mouse over effect we have in
JavaScript will also go through it and
we'll see many more such events in
further videos so this is just an
example of what is yet to come so let's
move on and talk about the get element
by ID method so let's say we don't want
this pop-up on click what we want to do
is we want to change this heading here
so you can see here we have the heading
as Dom manipulation part two we want to
replace this text with something else on
the button click so the function will
remain the same what will changes will
change the body of this function so
instead of writing here alert what we'll
do is we'll use the ID now so what we'll
do first is we'll provide ID to this
heading tag so let's say this heading
tag has the ID named as
heading so we have the ID heading for
this head h2 tag so what we'll do here
is we'll write here document
so as you guys know document is also a
method present within the window object
right so we'll write here document dot
get element by ID
and will
pass the ID we want to use so here in
this particular case we want to use this
ID heading so we'll pass
heading over here so we'll copy it from
here
and we'll paste it here
fine then we have the dot inner HTML
property
so here in this case we want to take a
reference to the object H2 so we know H2
acts as an object in the document object
model right so we can use it to take the
reference of this object and also all
the objects do have some properties
right so the dot in HTML here is the
property of object H2 and it will hold
the value written inside the h2 tag so
the dot in HTML property holds the value
Dom manipulation part 2. so what we want
to do next is we want to change this
text to something else right so if we
want to write here something else so
let's say we want to write here
subscribe
simply code
fine
so let's say this is the string we want
to print here on clicking the button
so we want to change this text to
subscribe to Simply code all do if we
save it now we don't see any change now
that's because we want the text to
change on button click so if we click on
this button now here you can see the
text is changed so similarly we can do a
lot many things with this now for
example we can store this value inside
our own variable so what we have to do
here is we have to write here where
C is equal to and now this where c will
hold the value returned by this
statement next up what we'll do is we'll
use the
alert method
and we'll see right here
C
so what it will do is it will take the
value so where c will hold the value
Dom manipulation part 2 and next up this
value will be printed on the pop-up here
so let's save it now and if we click
here we can see here we have the pop-up
with message Dom manipulation part two
so we can use this dot in a HTML method
to get the string present inside the H2
object and we can also use the alert
method with this variable then so there
are many more ways to access the
elements the document.getelement by ID
method is just one of them in this video
we will create a website layout and make
changes in that layout using the
document object model today we are going
to work with HTML as well and a little
bit of CSS so we are going to use
multiple tags from HTML and we are going
to use CSS for styling those tags
so for now I hope you guys must have a
clear understanding of tags in HTML and
styling as well so let's move ahead and
we are going to use the div tag first we
are going to make few sections of a
particular section and then we are going
to use CSS for styling those div tags so
let's use the div tags first so what we
are going to do is we are going to
create a particular section for all the
div tags in the HTML document so we are
going to write here div
and then inside this div we are again
going to create some more sections so
we'll write here div and then we'll
write here this is section
one similarly we are going to create few
more sections inside this div tag then
we'll
copy paste it and
will change the
names for this section so we'll save it
now and here you can see we have three
sections we have section one two and
three if we go to element and if we try
to check the area covered by these div
tags so we can go here and we can see
this is the area which is highlighted
right now this is the area covered by a
particular div tag so
we have a div tag then inside that div
tag we have three more div text present
right so we have section one two and
three now we are going to use the
concept of class and IDs as well so
we'll write here class is equals to and
let's say the class for this div tag is
left
then again for this div tag let's say
the class is right
and then lastly the class will be
let's say center right so we have three
different classes here as well now if we
save it we don't see any particular
change for now but if we try to use CSS
here so what we have to do is we have to
use the style tag
and inside this style tag we have to
define the properties for particular
classes so for class left let's say the
properties background color and let's
say the background color will be crimson
fine next up we have the classes right
and for write the background color will
be
let's say dark blue
and then we have another class here as
well which is Center so for class Center
the background color will be let's say
gold
fine save it now and now here you can
see we have all the three sections with
different background colors this this is
section one so this particular section
has the background as Crimson then we
have section two with background is blue
and then we have section 3 with
background is gold right I hope you guys
are clear with this concept of class
till now next up I hope you guys are
already aware of this difference between
class and ID but let's go through this
concept quickly so whenever we want to
make changes in multiple elements in our
program we use class for example if we
want to use the crimson color as the
background color for section 4 and let's
say we want to use the gold color as
background color for Section 5. so what
we are going to do is we are going to
create two more sections and the section
4 will inherit the properties of class
left and the section 5 will inherit it
from
class Center so let's do it we'll create
here two more div
so we'll copy it and we'll paste it here
and again we'll paste it here we'll
change the names as 4 and 5 and the
classes as well so
the class of section 4 will be in left
and the class of Section 5 will be
Center so let's save it you can see here
we have two more div or we can say we
have two more sections present over here
we have section 4 and we have section 5
over here right
now if we talk about section 4 we can
use two classes here right so you can
see for now we have only one class over
here we can use another class over here
so let's say we are using a class named
size so for now we don't have any class
with name size so this is the syntax of
how we can use two different classes
within a single element all we have to
do is we have to put space between these
two classes and we are good to go so
let's define this class here so we have
to define the class size here so we'll
write here dot size and let's say we
want the font size to be
smaller so let's save it here you can
see the font size of this particular div
tag is changed the font is a bit smaller
when compared to other fonts over here
and if you want to do something more
like if you want to make it Bolder you
can do it or any other thing you want to
do you can do it with the help of CSS so
on the other hand the ID attribute
specifies a unique property or a unique
section so using the ID attribute we can
identify a unique element so as you know
we can use ID with document.getelement
by ID basically that is the only reason
we say that ID has to be unique
otherwise there is no problem if you are
using ID for two different elements if
you are using the same ID for two
different elements let me show it to you
with the help of an example so here in
this particular section in this section
4 we are going to use the ID attribute
as well so we are going to name this ID
as1
save it now and we have to define the ID
here as well so for that we have to use
hash and then we have to use the ID name
so let's say this
will change the font weight fine so it
will make it Bolder so so let's save it
now and here you can see this is section
4 is a little bit thicker than other
sections so if we want to use the same
ID for any other element right we can do
it there's no problem with that let me
show you guys so if we write a ID as 1
and if we save this program now here you
can see there is no error with that we
can use this ID for Section 1 as well so
it's not necessary that the ID should be
unique for every element of the website
but it has to be unique because we can
use ID for manipulating a web page right
we can use it with
document.getelement by ID so that's why
we prefer to keep the ID unique for
every element inside HTML document so I
hope you guys are clear with the
difference between class and ID by now
major difference is class is used for
multiple targets whereas we use ID
uniquely for each element we want the ID
to be unique so that's the difference
between class and ID
moving ahead let's talk about the
document object model so what we are
going to do now is we'll go to the
Javascript file and we are going to see
the document object model now
by now we are aware of the document
object model right we are aware of the
window object we are aware of the
document object we have already came
across these two objects in the previous
video so what we are going to do is we
are going to write here where X we are
declaring a variable X and we'll write
here document so we already did this in
the previous video
so what we are going to do is we are
going to write here console.log and we
are going to print x on a console
so save it and if we go to console here
you can see we have the document here or
we can say we have the document object
model for the whole document for the
whole HTML document we know that the Dom
is a structural representation of HTML
document so we have here HTML tag we
have head body and almost every tag we
have here right you can see we have
script here we have div here we have all
the div tags present here now we know
that the document is also an object like
any other object right we already
discussed it it also has its own
attributes and properties as well so
next up you guys can see we have here a
fundamental website right so this is a
website basically what we have here is
we have five different sections and we
have a heading here as well right so
what we are going to do is we are going
to work on it with the help of document
object model so we can use CSS to make
changes to the syntax like we used
previously while creating divisions of
our web page but for now let's focus
upon the JavaScript part more so in
JavaScript we can write code that will
help us in manipulating the document
object model so this document object
model has a tree like structure with
HTML tag at the top then we have head
and body Tech and then we have all the
tags present inside them in a branch
like structure we are aware of this
right if we see here in the console we
have a document and if we try to open it
we can see we have HTML head and many
more text present within all these
significant texts
next up if we write here document dot
all instead of document so if we save it
now here you can see we have the HTML
collection of all the tags with numbers
in front of them so here you can see we
have HTML head and then body tag and
here you can see especially we have the
classes as well here not just classes we
have the IDS as well so here you can see
we have div one here as well so this is
the HTML collection of all the text we
have in our HTML document and we can
check it with the help of document.all
property
now suppose we want to access a
particular segment in this program or in
this document we want to access elements
present within the head tag let's say or
within the body tag in that case we have
to write a statement that goes like this
so instead of document.all we'll write
here document.head
save it and here you can see we have the
head segment of this particular document
with all the tags over here so here you
can see we have meta tags and title tags
only because till now we haven't added
any particular tag in the head section
of a HTML document so let's do one thing
let's try to access the body tag
we'll write a document.body and save it
so here you can see we have the body of
our HTML document here with all the text
so here you can see we have the CSS file
as well we have background color for
each class and then we have the ID as
well so this is how you can access a
particular segment of your HTML document
with the help of JavaScript
next up sometimes it may happens that we
may include forms in our website and
later we want to access them in our
console so in JavaScript we have a
method for that also so what we have to
do is we have to write here document dot
forms so we'll remove body from here and
we'll write here forms save it as you
can see we have an HTML collection of
forms but we have no form for now in a
HTML document so it's showing 0. so
let's do one thing let's add a form over
here so we'll write here
form and so let's say our form will take
three values so it will take name H and
then we have a submit button right so
we'll write here name then we'll write a
input
type is equals to
text and then we have name is equals to
name
fine next up we have the H so we'll
write here H input
type is equals to number
and name is equals to
h
right then finally we have the submit
button fine so we'll write here input
type is equals to
button
and then we have value s
submit let's say
save it and here you can see we have
name
H and submit so let's do one thing let's
add the Break Tag or BR tag here
we'll do it here as well
save it and now you can see we have name
agent submit so this is basically a form
if we go to elements and if we go to a
form you can see we have the form
highlighted over here it consists of
three different properties it has name
it has H and then it has a button a
submit button basically so obviously it
will not work fine for now because we
haven't added any functionality till now
so we'll discuss about it in later
videos so for now our main purpose is to
access this form with the help of
JavaScript we'll go back to our
Javascript file we'll save it again and
now if we click over here you can see we
have a form present over here we have 0
and then we have form written over here
right so we can see we have input and
then we have the properties of this
particular form and all of this stuff
so you can see we have a form present
over here or we can access a form with
the help of JavaScript so now let's say
we have a scenario where we have four
different forms and we want to access
form three
from them so what we have to do in that
case is we have to write here
document.forms and we have to provide
the form number so as you know as you
can see here the form number starts from
0 so for form number three the number
will be 2.
fine so if we save it now it will show
an error because
obviously we don't have any forms over
here till now so we have added only one
form but it will work fine if you try to
do it with more than one forms so this
is how you can access forms with the
help of JavaScript next up we'll try to
access images as well so if you have
added any image in your HTML document
you can also access it with the help of
JavaScript
so what we are going to do is we are
going to add an image over here
so let's do it first we'll write here
IMG then we have the image source as
simply code.png and then we have the alt
so we'll write here
Sim
plicode
right so we have added an image here
save it and here you can see we have the
image but the image is quite large right
so what we are going to do is we are
going to use CSS in this case we'll
write a ID and we'll let's suppose the
ID is 2 right we have used one already
so we'll write here two
we'll go to our CSS file we'll write
here so the property we'll write here is
Max width and Max height so max height
let's say will be 50 percent
and then we have Max width as well so
let's say the width is also 50 save it
and here you can see the image is fine
now so we have added this image over
here the main motive is to access this
image with the help of JavaScript right
so we'll go to a Javascript file instead
of document.form so we'll write here
document dot images and we'll save it so
here you can see we have HTML collection
with image here if you notice here you
can see we have the image with the ID as
well so you can see here 2 is written
over here after the IMG so this is the
image and we can access it with the help
of JavaScript we can access as many
images as we want with the help of
JavaScript so for now we have added only
a single image you can do it with the
help of more than one images
next up just like we can access images
we can access forms we can access the
body segment the head segment everything
of an HTML document similarly we can
access the links as well we can access
scripts as well so for that we have to
make minor changes over here we have to
write instead of document dot images we
have to write either document.links or
document.scripts so the syntax will
remain same all we have to do is we have
to write here scripts or links or images
whatever we want to access with the help
of JavaScript we have to write it over
here
so I want you guys to check it with the
help of links and scripts before we look
at the Dom traversing in JavaScript
let's discuss another small yet
interesting method in JavaScript that is
the query selector method this query
selector method in JavaScript helps the
user to get the first element from the
document with a particular query as the
name suggests it will return the first
element related to that query suppose we
see here in the previous code so we are
using the previous code the one which we
used in the previous video so we are
going to use the same code
so we can see here we have an element
with class left here right so this is a
class left and the element with class
left is this div is here with class left
fine in fact we have more than one
element with class left right so this
div also has the class left now if we
want to find the first element with
class left in that case we can use the
query selector method so it will return
this div tag in the console or wherever
we want to print it it will return this
div tag there
so let's implement this encoding so
we'll go to the JavaScript file and
let's suppose we want to access a
particular element or we can say the
first element with the class is left
okay so let's remove this and we'll
write here where X is equal to document
it's quite similar to what we studied in
the last video like we did for forms and
all so what we have to do here is we
have to write a x equals to document Dot
query selector
and then we have to pass the class name
here instead of class name we can pass
the element name as well we can pass the
ID as well so in this particular case we
are going to pass the class name so
we'll write here dot left so this is our
class name
and then we'll print this X on the
console so we will write here
console.log and will print x0
so the syntax is quite simple for the
query selector method let's save it and
check the output so you can see here
that in the output we have null here
right so it may happen to some of you
guys that it will show null here in the
console every one of you or me doesn't
need to have to go through it like it
happens mostly when we try to access the
element before the document object model
is ready so you may have encountered a
similar situation earlier in the last
video when you try to access a
particular form in the document using
numbers like we were using there we were
writing there we were doing is we were
accessing a particular form
so this will give an error right save it
and here you can see it says undefined
as well so this is the problem this is
because the document object model is
still not ready so we can tackle this
problem in two ways we can use the
onload method and the other one is we
can use the Dom content load event so
for now we'll use the onload method
because that method is a bit easier than
the other one so what we have to do is
we have to create a function in our JS
file so we'll create a function here
let's say we are creating a function 1s
fine and we have the body of the
function so what we are going to do is
we are going to cut this from here and
we are going to paste it inside the
function
fine
so you can see here we have a function
1s and now what we are going to do is we
are going to call this function from our
HTML file right so we are going to call
this function along with the onload
event so we'll go to a HTML file and
we'll write here along with the body tag
we'll use onload method and we'll write
here a function name fine so this is a
function name 1s this onload event
executes the JavaScript code right after
the web page is completely loaded save
it now and here you can see we have the
output for the query selector method or
you can see we have the output for the
document.forms right we have the form
present at number one so a issue is
solved now so what we are going to do is
we are going to remove this line from
here and now we'll go back to our query
selector method so save it again and
here you can see we have the query here
right we have the output as div class
equals to left and then we have id1 so
we have this particular element here
right so this is how we can use the
query selector method in JavaScript to
access any particular query or to search
any particular query moving ahead let's
talk about traversing the document we
know that Dom has a tree like structure
with parent and child nodes right travel
cursing a Dom is important because
sometimes we need to locate or modify a
particular element but there may exist a
possibility that the code is too long or
we don't want to search for that
specific element by going through every
element present in the document so
that's where we can use the Dom
traversing method to find a particular
component so let's understand the
concept of root node parent element and
child element so here in this structure
you can see we have several nodes
present right so the first node we are
going to discuss is the root node so
this HTML tag is actually the root node
which has no parent and it has
children's right so this HTML tag is
also a parent node another example for
parent node is the body tag so you can
see here we have so many children along
with the body tag we have H1 div and we
have div ID D equals to div 2 we have
two div tags we have an H1 tag and
similarly head is also a parent node as
well as a child node a child node to
this HTML and a parent note to title
right so the HTML tag has two children
which are head and body the head is the
first child and the body is the last one
here you can see we have the H1 tag and
this H1 tag is the child node of body
Tech so these all are the child nodes we
have H1 div and then we have another div
and title they all are the child nodes
similarly these div elements are also
parent elements to these two child
elements right the document object model
in JavaScript can be traversed into two
different direction either in downward
direction or in upwards Direction it's
not necessary that traversing the Dome
should start from the beginning or from
the end we can begin traversing from
wherever we want and it can be random
all we need to know before starting is
the class name or we can say element
name or something like that related to
that particular element which we want to
find so traversing downwards means we
want to find the element while coming
towards the downward Direction so we
have two different methods in JavaScript
to Traverse the Dom downwards so we can
either use the query selector method
which we came across moments ago the
other one is we can use the children
property so which helps us in find the
direct descendants of an element so
let's move ahead and take a look at both
these methods with the help of examples
till now we were using document dot
query selector method to find something
in our document right now we will use
Query selector along with the variable
name to find a specific element inside a
parent element so let's do one thing
we'll go to our HTML file and what we'll
do we'll give this div tag a class so
let's say we are using a class here and
the class name is container we didn't
Define this class as of now but we are
using this class for this particular div
tag fine
now we want to find a particular element
inside this particular div tag for that
we have to take two variables right so
we'll go back to our Javascript file and
we'll remove this code we'll take two
variables let's say where X
and we have
where y fine
so for where X we'll use the document
dot query selector method
and we'll write here the class name so
the class name for the parent div is
container right
and for variable y
will write here x dot query selector
so one thing you might have noticed here
is we have used
the variable name right so we are
looking for a particular element inside
this
particular div tag so we have identified
this div tag with the help of class name
so the class name is container and now
we are looking for a particular element
inside this div tag so let's say we want
to find the element with classes right
here so we'll write here
dot right so this is a class name next
up we are going to print the element on
a console so we'll write a console.log y
and when we save it you can see here we
have the first element with class right
so we have this div tag here inside
which it is written that this is section
2. so you can see here we have the first
element present with the class right so
this method so far has helped us in
traversing the Dom in a downward
Direction firstly we found a parent node
and then we started looking for the
child node in a downward direction from
that element so with the help of this
method we can find any element present
within an element in the tree like
hierarchy so if we use this method for
body tag and then we want to find the
element with class right although the
element with the class right is not a
direct descendant of the body tag right
so if we go back to our HTML
page so you can see here if we are using
any class here inside the body tag and
we want to find the
element with class right so we can see
this is not a direct descendant of body
tag instead it is a direct descendant of
this particular div tag right so we can
still find it with the help of this
query selector method
but what if we want to see the direct
descendant to a particular node so for
that we can use children property in
JavaScript so we can see here that this
particular div tag has five
different sections present within it
right so we have this div tag and then
we have five different div tags
basically so you can see this is section
one two three then four and lastly 5.
so we'll try to access these five
elements now with the help of children
property so for that we'll go back to
our Javascript file and we'll write in
our Javascript file we'll copy this
statement from here and
we'll write it in another line so that
it won't create any confusion to you
guys so what we have to do here is we
have to remove this from here and we
have to find the children of
X so what's there inside X we have the
div tag the parent div tag inside this x
right and we want to find the children
of this div tag so we'll save it and you
can see we have an HTML collection of
seven length and you can see here the
length has 7 and we have all the
elements here we have div 1 and then we
have div 2 3 4 5 and then we have form
and image as well because form and image
is also present inside this particular
div tag so we have all the elements
present here of this particular parent
div tag this children property Returns
the elements only if we write here
instead of children if we write here
child nodes so let's do it and check the
output first
so we have written here child nodes save
it and here you can see it returns a
node list of 15 elements right but one
thing to notice here is this text is
printed almost after every element right
so you can see text here then we have
text here then we have text here and we
have text almost after every element
right
because this method also publishes the
new line so suppose if we are using the
new line if we are using a new line in
our code it will publish that as well
and let's suppose we want to write a
comment over here so let's go here to a
HTML file and write a comment over here
so where we'll write the comment
will write the comment here
fine so we'll write
a comment here so let's say we'll write
here this is a comment
fine so we have commented this line and
save it
so you can see the size changed to 17
right because it says there are two more
lines added to our code so you can if
you see here you can see here we have a
comment here as well and we have a text
added here as well because of this new
line so it will take this as a new line
and it will print it as text so this is
how the child notes is different from
the children so if we want to compare
them side by side what we can do is
we'll write here
console.log
and will print x dot
children right so save it and here you
can see we have a node list of 17
elements and
HTML collection of Seven Elements the
difference is the children property
focuses on elements only whereas the
child nodes property will print
everything inside a node next up we can
access a particular element from the
list of all children's so the syntax
will be the same as for forms if you
remember from the previous videos we can
access any form from the HTML file by
using numbers right form presented
number one will be
treated as forms 0 and then so on and so
on so we'll write here let's say
children at number four so save it
and you can see here we have the output
as this is Section Five so we don't know
so let's do one thing we'll copy this
line
and
will paste it here we'll print the
children's as well basically
save it and here you can see we have all
the children's here so this particular
statement will print the element present
at number four so you can see here we
have this div tag here with class as
Center so it will be printed in a
console so you can see here it says this
is sections five
fine similarly
just like we have the children and child
notes property we have few more
properties here we have the first child
first element child last child and last
element child properties which Returns
the first and last child and elements so
let's use them as well
so what we are going to do is we are
going to remove this we are going to
write here
console.log and x dot
first child
fine copy this and we'll paste it again
and again
so the next one is first element child
and then we have last tie
and finally we have
last element child
fine so we are good to go the first
child then we have first element child
then we have last child and last element
child
save it
and here you can see the first one says
text and the third one says text and the
other two are presenting the elements
present at number one and presented
number last so
the first child and last child
properties works on the child node
property and it Returns the first and
last child according to the property
only
the first element child and last element
child property works on the children
property so we know the difference the
children property focuses on elements
only whereas the
child node property shows everything
inside that nodes right so that's why
the output here is text for first child
and last child and for first element
child and last element Childs we have
two different elements present here
right we have an image element and
development we can also count the number
of child elements present within a
single node we have to use the child
element count property for doing so so
let's use it as well and we'll write
here console.log
and we'll
write here x dot
child element count fine save it and we
have the output here S7 this property is
also working on the basis of children
property fine so you can see here we
have the length as seven as we have seen
earlier while using the children
property the length is 7 there as well
so like we can find the child element of
a particular node we can also find the
parent element so the syntax Remains the
Same and we have to use the parent
element property to find the parent of
any element
so what we are going to do is we are
going to find the parent of this
particular div tag we have the parent
div tag right with class container
so we are going to find the parent for
this particular div tag so what we are
going to do is we are going to write
here
console.log and x dot parent element
so save it and here you can see we have
the parent as the body tag here here you
can see we have body on load and then we
have function name and whatever is there
inside the body tag we have it all here
fine
so this line gave us the parent element
of this particular div tag with class
container now we can use this method to
find the parent of any element or we can
use the panel node property as well the
output will remain the same in both
cases because any child node in the
document can have one parent only right
so this is known as traversing in upward
Direction
now before we end this video let me guys
take you through another Concept in this
particular topic we can also access the
siblings of a specific element so like a
parent a div here has so many children
right we have five children's for the
div Tech not five we have six and then
we have seven children so because we
have seven tags present here inside the
div tag inside this particular div tag
right so we can access the siblings of a
particular child let's suppose if we
want to access the siblings of this
particular
child right we want to access the
siblings so the siblings are the
immediate left sibling will be this one
and the immediate next sibling or the
right sibling will be this one so what
we have to do to access the siblings of
these elements is we have to write here
instead of
document dot query selector we have to
write here
Center
right because we want to access the
siblings of this particular div tag
right
so what we'll do next is will right here
console
DOT log and
then we have to write here x dot next
element sibling for the next one and
we have to write here
console.log
x dot previous
so we can find the previous
element sibling as well
and now what we have to do is
save it and here you can see we have two
different div tags present here one with
class left and the other one is one with
class right so if we go back to our HTML
file we can see here we have the div
with class left as the next element
present to this particular element and
the div with class right as the previous
element of this particular element with
class center right so I hope you guys
understood this today we are going to
take input from the user with the help
of a text box in JavaScript what we'll
do is we'll create a text box and any
value the user will write inside the
text box will be stored in a variable
and then we will print that variable in
a message using the alert method or in
the control so whatever we want to do we
can do it so let's create a small login
page with no styling because we'll be
focusing more on the HTML and the
JavaScript parts so for that we have to
go to our HTML file so here's a HTML
file and we'll write here
input
and then we'll write a type is equals to
name and then we'll write here
placeholder is equals to let's say enter
name
this placeholder is an attribute that
gives a slight hint whatever value we
write here will be printed inside the
box so this enter name will be printed
inside this particular text box
so save it and here you can see on the
browser we have a text box here here you
can see how this value is written inside
the text box you can see here enter name
is written inside a text box indicating
the user to write the name here so let's
create another text box here for the
password we are creating a login page
right so we'll be needing name and
password so we'll use the BR tag here
and then we'll write here
input type is equals to
password
and then we'll
use a placeholder here and we'll write
here
enter
password this type attribute here plays
a vital role on this input element
because we have different types of
values we can use inside a text box like
we have numbers strings week time email
password and many more so here we are
using password
to save it and you can see here we have
two text boxes over here in the browser
so we have a text box for name and we
have a text box for password
next up we need a button to perform a
task right so we'll use the on click
method along with this button we can
either use the button tag or we can use
the input tag along with type is equals
to button so we'll write here input
type is equals to button and the value
will be
say submit
or we can write here login essay save it
and here you can see we have a button
over here named as submit so we are done
with the login setup here we have a text
box for the name and one for the
password so we'll write any name here
you can see let's write here question
and then we'll write the password here
let's say any random password and
nothing will happen if we click on the
submit button so let's add some
functionality to this submit button here
so we'll go back to HTML file and we'll
write here
on click so we'll write here a function
name print fine we'll create this print
function now so we'll go to our
JavaScript file and we'll create a
function here so let's say function name
is print and then we have the body of
the function now this function will be
called whenever we click on this button
so whenever we click on the submit
button this print function will be
called now we want this button to do
something right we want it to perform a
certain task what we want to do is we
want the user to write their name and
password and we will print this name and
password in the pop-up with the help of
alert method so we'll use the
document.getelement by ID method for
this task let's give those elements
their IDs so we'll give these two input
tags their IDs so we'll write here
ID is equals to let's say you name or
username and then we have the password
for password will give the ID as you
pass fine save it and then we'll go back
to our JavaScript file now both these
elements have their own IDs we'll use
them in the Javascript file so we want
to use the values given by the user
right for that we'll create two
variables here inside the function print
to hold the reference of original value
so for that we'll write here where X is
equals to
document dot get element by ID and then
we have the IDS you name for the
username and then we'll write here dot
when next up we'll take another variable
let's say where Y and then we'll write
here
document dot get element by ID again
then we have the IDS
U pass
we'll write a DOT value now what we did
here is we use the IDS to get the
reference of those values which the user
will input you might have noticed here
that we have used the value property
here after the IDS so this value
property Returns the value attribute of
any text box
now we have the values here present
inside variables X and variable y the
next thing we want to do is we want to
print these values right so for that
we'll use the alert method so it's quite
easy to use we'll write here alert and
then we'll write here
the name is and then we'll print
X so because variable X is holding the
value of name then we'll
use slash n and after that we'll write
here
the password is and then we'll print the
value of Awesome
so we are done with it we have printed
the values of X and Y here now save it
and now we'll enter the values here
let's say the name is
quotient and the password is simply code
the moment we click on this submit
button there will be a pop-up with a
message you can see it here the name is
kaushal and the password is simply code
we printed these variables here along
with the alert method
so this is how we can take input from
the user in JavaScript so we already
discussed that we want to create a login
form here with a specific name or
password right let's say we want the
user to be allowed only if the password
is simply cool otherwise the user should
be restricted from entering the web page
so this is a simple task all we have to
do here is we have to use the if else
control statements so for that we'll
write here after this statement we'll
write here if and then we'll write here
let's say pass we are doing it for
password right so we'll write a y is
equal to is equals to
simply code then we have the body of if
we'll write here alert
login successfully
and then we'll write here else this the
statement will be
alert
wrong password
so we'll keep this line here so what
will happen is the moment will press the
submit button it will go to the if else
statement and it will check if the
password entered by the user matches the
correct password or not so if the
password matches it will print login
successful otherwise it will print the
wrong password and then finally it will
print the name entered by the user and
the password as well so let's save it
and we'll write here the name as let's
say caution
and the password let's say the password
will be different this time we'll write
here simply learn
so this password does not matches the
original password right the original
password is simply code so what we are
expecting is it will return wrong
password here so let's save it the
moment we press the submit button you
can see here we have a pop-up with
message wrong password because the
password we entered is simply learn so
if we press OK here in the next message
you can see the name is kaushal and the
password is simply learn fine so let's
do it again this time we'll enter the
correct password we'll write here simply
code
and we'll change the name as well so
let's say the name is
Rahul
submit it and here you can see we have
the message as login successful
we'll press OK and here you can see the
name is Rahul and the password is simply
cool in this tutorial we will see how we
can use radio buttons to take input from
users now HTML radio buttons are created
with the help of input text and the type
for creating radio buttons is Radio we
can use radio buttons on multiple
occasions for example we can create a
quiz question using a radio button at
one time only a single radio button will
be selected and we can use it to find
the correct answer so today we will use
radio buttons along with the ID
attribute and then we will create a
JavaScript function to find the correct
answer for a quiz so without wasting any
time let's move on to the programming
part
so first we will see how to add radio
buttons to our HTML document
in the HTML file we will write here
input
type is equals to radio
and then we have
value is equals to let's say option one
because we are using multiple options
right we have multiple options for a
single question or we have multiple
options here so we'll write value as
option one and then we'll write here the
value we want to print so we'll write
your option
one
fine save it and we have a radio button
over here you can see we can check it
and it has no functionality till now
so let's add another button first so
what we'll do we'll copy this line from
here and
we'll paste it and then we'll change the
option as option 2 and the value also as
option 2.
right save it again and here you can see
we have two radio buttons now let's add
a submit button here first so we'll
right here
input type is equals to button and then
we have value is equal to submit save it
and here you can see we have a submit
Button as well one thing you might
notice here is we can check both the
text boxes right we can check option 1
and option 2 both at the same time so if
we want to select only one check box at
a time we have to group them so we'll
use the name attribute and the same name
for these two radio buttons so the name
will remain the same for both of these
radio buttons so we'll write a name is
equals to let's say
G1 and then we'll write here as well
we'll write here name is equals to G1
now these two radio buttons belong to
the same group
save it and now if you try to check both
these boxes you can see we can't do it
now because we have grouped them and now
we can select only one radio button at a
time right
now the next thing we are going to do is
we'll move to a JavaScript file and
we'll create a function there so we'll
move to a Javascript file so here's our
Javascript file and we'll create a
function here so let's do it first so
we'll write here
function
let's say the function name is
fun one fine and then we have the body
of this function so inside this function
we'll write here we'll take two
variables again for both the elements so
we'll write here where X and then we'll
write a document Dot
get element by ID then we'll write here
the ID
so let's provide the ID to those
elements as well so we'll write here
before name will provide the ID so let's
say the ID for the first radio button is
red one and the ID for the second one
will be
let's say Red Two Fine save
and we'll go back to our Javascript file
we'll write here red one
and then we'll take another variable
we'll write here where Y is equals to
document dot get element by ID method
and then we'll write here the ID so the
ID for the second radio button is
red 2. fine we don't need the value
property here next up we have to use the
if else statement to print something
right so we'll write here we'll use the
if else statement we'll write if
and then we have
x dot checked
is equals to is equals to true
then it will return something right so
we have a condition here as if x dot
check is equal to is equals to true this
particular statement will check if the
radio button whose reference is
available at variable X is selected or
not this dot checked is the property for
a HTML element if the radio button is
checked the output will be something so
let's add the output here as well so the
output will be if the radio button is
checked
will be like we'll write a alert then
we'll write here the
option
selected
is
then we will write here
x dot
value so it will print the value of x as
well
now we have another condition here
we'll write here if white or checked
is equals to is equals to true
then it will return the option
selected is we'll write here plus y dot
value we are doing this because we have
three different conditions here right if
we select option one or if we select
option two or if we are not selecting
any of these options right so we have a
else condition for that and then we'll
write here else so here we have to write
else if
and then we'll write here else
and else part will print
alert no option
selected save it and let's do one thing
first we'll call this function with the
help of on click method so we'll go back
to HTML file and we'll write here in
this element we'll write here on click
and we'll call this function on click
so we'll write you a fun one and we have
this function here save it and here we
are good to go
so if we move back to our JavaScript
file you can see here we have three
conditions either X is checked or Y is
checked or none of these are checked so
let's
check the output now we'll select option
one first we'll submit it and here you
can see we have the output as the option
selected is option one fine press ok
then we'll refresh this page and we'll
select option 2 and now we'll press the
submit button so here you can see on
selecting option two we have the output
here as the option selected is option
two right so what if we are not
selecting any of these two radio buttons
so
click the submit button here and you can
see we have the output as no option
selected so I hope you guys got it now
the syntax will remain the same if we
want to create a quiz so next up what we
are going to do is we are going to
create a quiz
so here is the code if you want to
create a quiz on your own so we have a
question here we have a question as
JavaScript was developed in the year and
then we have two options for it we have
1998 as first option so if we go here
you can see we have the first option is
1998 and then we have another option is
1995. obviously we know the answer for
it as 1995 will change the function name
here as
fun one
and save it
the Javascript file for this code will
look like this so we have three
conditions here again if x is checked
then the output will be wrong answer and
the correct answer is why and then we
have another condition for y if Y is
checked or we can say if 1995 is check
will have the output as right answer and
then we have another condition if none
of these radio buttons are checked we
have the output as no option selected so
let's see if the code works fine so save
it
and we'll go to the browser so we'll
select option one first so we'll select
this 1998 submit it and here you can see
we have the output as wrong answer the
correct answer is 1995 right we have the
value of y here the value variable Y is
holding is 1995 so we printed it over
here and we have the output as y dot
value which is 1990
so if we refresh it and if we select
1995 here then we'll press the submit
button and here you can see we have the
output as right answer fine press OK and
we are going to do it again so this time
we won't be selecting any of these
options we'll just click on the submit
button and we have the output as no
option selected fine I hope you guys
understood it in the last few videos we
discussed the same thing right we saw
how we could take input using text boxes
and then we saw how we can take input
using radio buttons today we are going
to grab users input with the help of a
select box in JavaScript so without
wasting any time let's move on to the
programming part directly first we'll
see how to create a select box in HTML
and then we'll move on to the JavaScript
part so let's move on to HTML and we'll
create a select box here if you guys
remember we use the input tag in the
previous few videos for text boxes and
radio buttons but for the select box the
scenario is a bit different we have to
use the select element in HTML so we'll
write here
select
so we have the select element here we
have to use this for select box in
JavaScript or in HTML so this select box
is used to create drop-down list of some
elements so we can add as many elements
as we want to that list so we'll use the
option tag for each component we are
going to use so the code goes like this
will
start with the select tag and let's save
this and see if it makes any changes to
a browser so you can see it on the
browser that we have a button over here
now we'll add options to this drop down
list for that we'll use the option tag
we'll write here option
and let's say we have three options we
have three car manufacturers name so
let's say the first name is BMW then
we'll copy this
statement and
we'll paste it again and again and then
we'll change the name of Manufacturers
so let's say another manufacturer is
Audi and the last one is food fine we
have three manufacturers now
save it and you can see it over here we
have a drop down list of three different
elements we have BMW or dn4 here next up
we'll add a button so a submit Button as
we did in the previous few videos for
that we will write here input type is
equals to button and then we have value
is equals to
submit fine
save it and we'll use a br tag here
save it now and here you can see we have
a drop down list here we have a select
box here and then we have a submit
button over here
fine now we want to print the option we
selected by clicking this submit button
for that we have to add functionality to
our HTML document right so we'll follow
the same steps as we did in the last
video wherein we used the radio buttons
and the text boxes so we'll write here
inside this input tag we'll write here
on click so what we want to do is we
want to call a function on clicking a
submit button right so we will write
here a function name so let's say the
function name is
selected and we have to use the ID
attribute in the select element right so
we'll use the ID attribute here we are
not going to use our ID attribute inside
the option text but we are going to use
the ID attribute inside the select text
we will write here ID
is equals to let's say
1. fine
so we have an ID here now we have to use
the value property here as well so I
hope you guys remember the value
property which we discussed in previous
videos so the value property is used to
access these values right so we'll write
here
value is equals to
BMW and then for Audi the value will be
OD and then for Ford the value will be
food fine save it and here we are done
with the HTML document so next up we'll
create a function in the Javascript file
so let's move on to the Javascript file
and we'll create a function over here
so we'll write here
function and the function name is
selected
then we have the body of this function
right so we are going to repeat the same
steps we are going to take a variable X
which will hold the reference of Select
statement so we'll write here
document Dot
get element by ID and then we'll write
here the ID so the ID is 1
so now we have a variable X which holds
the reference value of Select element
right
now we have used the document.getelement
by ID method to get the reference of the
selected value next up we'll use some
properties for select element while
printing the value with alert method so
if you guys remember in the previous
video wherein we use the dot checked
property for radio buttons so similarly
we have some more properties here for
the select boxes as well so let's have a
look at them
so we'll write here
alert
and then we have a property which will
go like this will write here x dot
options
and then we have
this bracket send dot value
so this options property here is a
collection of all the options we have in
our selected
we have multiple options right this
property works on arrays so we have an
array of all the elements and we can
access any of them for that we will
write here the index value right so
let's say the index value is 0 we want
to print the element present at number
one so we'll save it and the moment we
press submit button you can see here we
have the output as BMW now one thing to
notice here is
it doesn't matter which option the user
chooses the output will remain BMW for
all those cases because we are using the
first element of the array so no matter
which option the user is selecting the
message will be there with the value
present at index 0.
so we can say now that we can't use
static values right we can't use 0 1 or
2 here because we want
to provide the value dynamically because
we have three different values here and
we want to print the value which the
user selected not the one present at
index is 0 1 or 2. so for that we have
another property here we have to write a
x dot
select
Ed index
and one thing you have to remember is we
have to write here x dot selected index
or any variable we are using here so we
are good to go now save it and if we
press submit now while
clicking on BMW so our first option is
BMW let's press the submit button and
here you can see we have the output as
BMW
and next up will be selecting Audi and
we'll press submit so here you can see
we have the output as already now
and finally we have Ford as well so
let's check it as well so press the
submit button and here you can see we
have the output is food
so this is how we can take inputs in
JavaScript from drop down lists next up
we'll go through a simple program as we
did in the last video wherein we'll
Create a quiz question and we'll check
if the option selected by the user is
correct or not so this is the code for
that so we have the question here is
Javascript was developed by we are using
another question different from the one
we used in the last video so we know who
developed JavaScript right so we have a
question here JavaScript was developed
by and then we have two options for the
same question the first one is Brendan
Ike and the second one is guidoven
Rossum
so then we have the ideas one for the
select element and the values are also
the same then we have a button over here
which will call function1 on clicking
and if we move to a Javascript file we
can see here we have a function fun one
and then we have a variable X which
holds the reference of value
returned by document.getelement by ID
method and then we use this value so we
have used a x dot option so what we are
doing is we are basically checking that
if the selected value is equals to
Brendan Ike or not if the value is equal
to Brandon I then the output will be the
answer is correct else the output will
be the answer is wrong so let's save it
and we'll move back to HTML file and
we'll save this file as well so now here
you can see we have a question over here
and we have a select box which has two
options Brandon I can guide you and
Rossum right
so let's select brendanite first press
the submit button and here you can see
it says the answer is correct fine next
up we are going to use Guido and Rossum
and we are going to press submit button
so here you can see the answer is wrong
we have been using the
document.getelement by ID method for the
past few videos right we know it is used
to access an HTML element with the help
of an ID which is uniquely provided to
each element
so we use that method with text boxes
then with radio buttons and then we
select boxes as well so today we are
going to use a method that is somewhat
similar to document.getelement by ID
method
so we'll be using the document dot get
Elements by tag name method in
JavaScript
as the name suggests this method is used
to access a bunch of similar elements
with the same tag so we have tag name in
our method right so we can access a
bunch of tags with similar name like if
we have a few div tags present in our
program and we want to change each div
tags style we can do it with the help of
this method
so we'll look at the syntax first and
then we'll move on to the difference
between ID and tag name method so let's
move on to the programming part directly
what we'll do is we'll create a few div
tags first and then we'll change this
style of these div tags with specific
styling properties we are not going to
use CSS for that but in JavaScript we
have other styling properties as well so
we'll be using those styling properties
so let's create the div text first
we'll write here div
and then let's say we are writing it
this is section
one so we'll copy this line
and we'll create four similar div tags
right
we have section one two three and
four
save it and you can see over here we
have four different sections present
now this is a very basic example and
here we have different sections present
right next up we'll try to access these
div tags with the help of tag name
method so let's add a button over here
and then we'll move on to the JavaScript
part
so we'll write here let's use the BR tag
and we'll write here input tag again
we'll write a input type is equals to
button and we'll use the on click method
as well so we'll write here on click and
let's say our function name is
fun2
and then we have the
value of this button as let's say submit
close the input tag and save it so here
you can see we have a button over here
submit button and you can see here
nothing is happening on clicking on the
submit button so next up what we are
going to do is we are going to add
functionality to this submit button for
that we have to move to our Javascript
file and we have to create a function
over there
so we'll write here in the Javascript
file we'll write here
function
fund 2 and then we have the body of this
function right so the syntax is a bit
similar to that of the
document.getelement by ID method what
we'll do here is we'll take a variable X
and then we'll write here
document Dot
get Elements by tag name and then we'll
write inside the brackets the name of
tag we want to access right so here we
have added four different div tags so in
this case we'll write here div and we
can similarly access any of the tags
present in our HTML document we can
access paragraph tags we can access
anchor text and any tag we want to
basically
so save it and here now we have a
variable X that holds an HTML collection
of all the div text present inside the
HTML file this means that we have an
array of references of all the div tags
here inside this variable X
so if we try to make changes in a single
array element just like we did in the
select box example wherein we use the
array index to access a particular
element present at a particular array
Index right so we can do the same here
we'll write here x and then we'll write
the
index number so this particular
statement will access the element
present at number one
or this particular syntax will access
the
first div tag of HTML document because
we know arrays start from 0 and at 0 the
first element will be present so this
div tag will be present at number 0. and
then we are going to use this style
property so we know that X here is not a
variable only actually X here acts as an
object and we know that different
objects have certain properties in
JavaScript so style is one of those
properties and next up we'll write here
let's say
font family so what we are doing is we
are doing the CSS part with properties
present in JavaScript so let's say we
are changing our font to
Courier new fine so this is a font name
and we can use any font name over here
so save it what will happen now is on
clicking the submit button the font of
this particular section the font of div
one will change to Korean so let's try
if it's happening or not on clicking the
submit button you can see over here the
change between this line and other three
div tags clearly the font has changed
the new font is Courier new and what we
did here is we changed the font family
of this particular div tag so similarly
we can make more styling changes to
other div tags as well so let's do it
here
and we'll
make changes to each of the div tags we
have in a HTML file so let's say
here we are using the color property and
we want to change the font color to
blue
fine then we'll do the same for element
present at number three for that we'll
write here x and the index number will
be 2. so then again we'll use the style
property and then let's say we are
writing here
font style fine and the font style we
want it to be italic
and then finally we have one more
property
let's say for x
for the repeats so let's say for the
last div tag we are using the background
color
fine
and we'll write here the color name is
red so we are good to go now save it and
we have four different properties over
here for section four we are changing
the
background color so three will be the
index number of the last array variable
so save it and on pressing the submit
button you can see the change over here
so for section one the font is changed
to Courier new for section 2 the font
color is blue let me Zoom it out a bit
to show you guys you can see over here
the color is blue and then we have
italic text in section three and finally
for section 4 we have the background
color as four right so you can see how
we are accessing any particular element
of the array now why we are using these
properties separately for each array
element
so if we try to make changes on each
element of the array we simply can't do
it in JavaScript at once so if we try to
write here so let's comment this out
first what we'll do is we'll write a x
dot style dot font family so basically
what we want to do is we want to change
the font family for all the div tags
present right because we know the
variable X is holding an array of all
the div text present in a HTML file
right so we'll save it and you can see
over here if we are clicking on the
submit button you can see nothing is
happening so if we go to our console
and you can see it over here that we
have an error here so it says it cannot
set property font family of undefined so
this is the problem with this get
Elements by tag name method
to overcome this problem we have a
solution as well so the solution for
this problem is we have to use the for
Loop here so how this for Loop works so
we'll write here
and then we'll take a local variable I
and the initial value will be 0. then
we'll write a i
less than x dot length because we want
to Traverse the whole array right and
then we'll write here the condition I
plus plus so we have to go then we have
this body of for Loop and inside here
we'll write X and the index number will
be I because it will keep on changing
and we are in a loop so we'll write here
dot style and then let's say the style
we want to do is font
weight and what we want to do is we want
to make a font bolder fine
so comment this line as well save it now
and you can see over here everything is
clean now what will happen is on
pressing the submit button the font will
change the font weight will change
basically so let me Zoom this and if we
click on this submit button you can see
the font is more bold right so if we are
using another property here let's say
the font
we are using here
background color and we want the
background color to be yellow
fine so save it and on clicking the
submit button you can see the background
color for all the div text for all the
four section is changed to Yellow fine
so this is how we can access all the
elements of an array at once now what we
did is we started a loop and traversed
every element in the array and applied
the same property to each element
so this is how we can do it with the
help of tag name method in JavaScript
now what if we have hundreds of similar
elements like div tag present in our
website and all of them are present at
different locations so let's try to do
it and what we'll do is we'll insert
certain different elements in between
these div tags
fine so we'll include a form and then
we'll include some radio buttons and
anything we want to do we can do it so
we'll add some more elements in between
these div tags so here you can see we
have inserted two three more elements in
between these div tags so save it and
you can see after each section we have
something else here we have a form with
two different text boxes we have name
and age and then we have a submit Button
as well
then after that we have section two so
this is our section two then after
section two we have radio button and the
value is a then we have another radio
button B and in between we have all the
dev text present so basically what we
want to do is we want to change the
style for each of the div tags right
so we will change the background color
here so let's say we'll write here red
and what will happen is on clicking the
submit button on clicking this submit
button what will happen is the
background color of each div tag
so the background color for section one
two three and four will change to red so
let's try to do it and let's see if it's
working or not so we'll click on the
submit button and you can see it over
here we have all the div tags with
background color as red so this is
working totally fine
one more thing we'll discuss before
wrapping up this video is the uniqueness
of ID attribute for each element so we
are saying this for a long time that the
ID for each element should be unique
wise although we saw in the past videos
that we can use the same ID for two
different elements when we did the same
for accessing a CSS tiling property
using the ID attribute but if we try to
do the same thing with JavaScript we'll
get an error for example if we try to
access the value of any particular
element with the ID attribute but we
have two elements in a HTML file with
the same ID so it will throw an error in
that case basically and this is the
reason why we use the tag name method in
JavaScript so that if we want to access
multiple elements of the same name we
can do it with this method because it's
not possible to use the ID method
separately for each element present in
the HTML document right because we have
certain same HTML tags present within an
HTML document like we have the div tags
here similarly a website is long enough
to have multiple similar elements
present within it so that's why we use
the document.getelements by tag name
method in JavaScript so guys in the past
few videos we use two different methods
of accessing an element from an HTML
file using JavaScript properties so we
know the difference between the ID
method and the tag name method right
today we will use another method to
access a particular element in
JavaScript that is the class name method
or we can say the get Elements by class
name method in JavaScript so before
discussing the class name method in
JavaScript let's look at why accessing
an element is important in JavaScript
so we know that the document object
model is used to change add or delete
HTML elements we saw earlier that we
could change HTML elements or the CSS
style of any element in the document
with the help of JavaScript properties
so to make specific changes to those
elements we need to access them using
particular methods so we discussed two
such methods before the ID method and
the tag name method right so let's move
ahead and look at the class name method
of accessing an element in JavaScript as
the name suggests the main attribute in
this method will be the class name so we
know the difference between the class
and the ID attribute used in HTML we
know that ID has to be unique for each
element but we know that many elements
in an HTML document can have the same
class right so we used Class to access
specific CSS properties in the previous
videos and that is the only benefit of
using classes in JavaScript so we can
say that a single class can be used by
many elements within an HTML document so
let's dig a bit deeper into this concept
so let's say we have five elements
present on our website and we want to
make changes in three of these elements
right so let's write the code here and
it will be easier for you guys to
understand so will write here in the
HTML file we'll add five different
elements so let's say we are writing
here
div and
then inside this div we'll write
this is
Section 1 we'll copy this
we will paste it here
so we'll use two div elements and two
paragraph element right so here in this
P tag we'll write this is
section 3.
and then we'll copy this line paste it
again copy this one as well and paste it
here
so we have section one section two three
four in
five so out of these five different
elements we have three div tags and we
have two paragraph text so we'll discuss
why we have taken two paragraph tags in
between the div tags
so we are done with it here you can see
we have five elements present in a HTML
document three of them are the div text
section one two and five are div text
and two text in between are the
paragraph text so now let's suppose we
want to change the style of three of
these elements let's say one four and
five so we can do it in two ways right
either we can use the ID method or we
can use the class method however we can
use the tag name method as well but we
have to use two different variables for
that right that will be a lengthy
process why two different variables
because we have two different tags
present here right we have to create
separate variable for the div tag and
separate one for the paragraph tag so
that will be a lengthy process so we'll
consider ID method and the class name
method for here so considering the ID
method the document.getelement by ID
method we have to provide unique ID to
each element so we have to provide
unique ID to this div tag then we have
to provide to each and every element
here right so because we need to access
three of these elements so at least we
have to provide the ID to those three
elements which we want to access right
so in such cases we can use the class
name method where we want to access more
than one element but not all the
elements in an HTML file so we'll use
the class attribute in each element we
want to access
so let's say we want to access section
one two and five so we'll write a class
let's say the class name is cls1
we'll copy this paste it here and we are
accessing one two and four because one
two and five are the div text so we can
access these with the help of tag name
method as well so we'll access one two
and four
fine so we have used the class attribute
here
next up we'll create a button and then
we'll add functionality to a HTML
document so let's create a button here
will again use input type is equals to
button and then we have
on click
and on clicking it will call
and then we have the value as
submit fine
so save it and here you can see in the
browser we have five sections over here
we have section one two three four and
five then we have a submit button which
will call the function on clicking so we
haven't added functionality till now so
let's move ahead to our Javascript file
and we'll add functionality to our
HTML document
so inside this JavaScript file we'll
write here
function and then we have the function
name is
then we have the body of this function
so the syntax remains a bit same
so we'll take a variable first and then
we'll use the document method to take
references of all the elements from a
HTML file
so we'll write here
where X is equals to
document Dot
get Elements by
class name right and then we'll write
the class name here so the class name is
cls1
till now what we did was we took the
references of all the required elements
and stored them inside a variable named
X in the form of an HTML collection so
now we can make changes to these
elements and what we'll do is we'll
again use the style property to make
styling changes in those three sections
so we have these three sections present
inside an array and we can access any
one or all the three elements right so
we'll write here x and then we'll
provide the index number so let's say we
want to access section one that is the
first div tag so we'll provide the index
number as 0. then we'll write Dot
tile
and this style is a property dot then
let's say we want
to change the font style so we'll write
here
font
Style
font style will be
italic save it so this piece of code
will change the font style of the
element present at index 0. save it and
on clicking the submit button here on
the browser we can see the change in
this section right so if it's not
visible so let me Zoom it a bit for you
here you can see guys the font at
Section 1 is changed to italic right so
in this case we have all the three
elements present in a array and we can
make changes to each of these elements
so let's try to do it and we'll use
element present at index 1 now
we'll copy this line and we'll paste it
here again two times because we want to
make changes to all the elements right
we'll write it two and we'll write here
1.
and let's say
we want to change the font color for
this one and the font color will be blue
for this we will change the font weight
let's say
and we want to make it
bold
so we'll write here Boulder
save it and on clicking the submit
button you can see we have all the three
sections with some minor changes the
first one is changed and we have italic
over here for the second one we have
blue color as font color and for the
third one which is section four we have
the font readers Bolder so you can see
the change over here so this is how we
can make change to each element
separately and we can also make changes
in all the elements at once as well so
for that we have to use the for Loop
just like we did for the tag name method
right so for that we'll write here so
let's comment these three statements
first
and then we'll write here
four and
it will take a local variable here we'll
write you where I is equals to 0 I will
start from index 0 and I will go till
x dot length
and then we have the condition as I plus
plus
so inside the body of for Loop we'll
write here X and
instead of index number we'll write here
I because we want to Traverse the whole
array then we'll write Here style Dot
and let's say the style we want is
background color
we want the background color to be let's
say
yellow
fine
so this is how we can use the for Loop
save it and we'll see on clicking the
submit button on our browser the
background color for all the three
sections that is one two and four is
changed to Yellow
this is how we can use the
document.getelements by class name
method to access all the elements
present in an HTML file with a
particular class next up let's discuss
the difference between the ID method tag
name method and the class name method so
we'll discuss when to use which method
so let's start with the ID method so the
ID method is used when we want to access
a single element and we have to provide
a unique ID to that element in order to
access it so the ID method is quite
useful when we want to work on a single
element
apart from that if we want to work on
more than one element we have two other
methods or we can either use the class
name method or the tag name method for
more than one element
so the tag name method is also quite
useful when we want to access elements
with the same tag name we can access all
the similar tags present within an HTML
document with the help of tag name
method the only problem is we can access
similar types of tags only at one time
we can't access two different types of
tags with this method so this is where
the class name method comes into play we
can access more than one element with
this method and the elements can be
different just like we did here we had
div tag and paragraph tag right so the
section 1 2 and 5 are from div tags and
the section 4 and 3 are from the
paragraph text so we can access two
different tags with same class name with
the help of class name method in
JavaScript so with this we came to the
conclusion that more than one element in
the HTML file can have the same class
and can be accessed with the class name
method so we all know how a calculator
works right right we can make a simple
calculator program in JavaScript with
few operators and the if else statement
so let me show you guys a simple program
in JavaScript with which we can
calculate several arithmetic expressions
and get the output so here's the code
so we have used the script tag within
the HTML document so you can see it on
the screen guys here we have four
variables where op that will take the
input from the user in the form of plus
minus and then we have asterisk and
divide and then we have remainder as
well so depends upon which tasks the
user wants to perform it will take the
user's input next up we have two
variables N1 and N2 for the numbers upon
which the operation will be performed
also we have used parse float here we
know the usage of this function right
whatever input given by the user will be
changed to a floating number with the
help of this function
then we have a variable output that will
hold the value returned after performing
the calculation so we have several
conditions here as well we have several
conditions for each operator like if the
input given by the user is plus then it
will perform addition between N1 and N2
and the value of N1 plus N2 will be
assigned to variable output right
similarly we have other conditions for
other operators like we have for minus
then we have for asterisk then we have a
divide and for remainder as well so any
choice the user will make will get the
output accordingly like if the user
chooses
to perform a division then it will write
slash and then it will perform N1 by N2
and the output will be saved in the
variable output then we can
show this output with the help of alert
method in JavaScript we already came
across this alert method it will give a
pop-up with the result let's check the
output once and then we'll move on to
the exciting part of this video so this
is a basic calculator program with two
variables N1 and N2
so let's open it with live server
and here you can see we have a pop-up
here and here what we have to do is we
have to enter the operator so here we
have to
write either plus minus or any operator
from these operators so let's write here
s trick so let's say we want to perform
multiplication between two numbers then
we press OK and here we have the pop-up
for the first number so let's say the
first number is
5 and the second number is let's say 10
so the moment we press OK you can see
here we have the output as result is 50.
so we have a pop-up this pop-up is made
with the help of window dot alert method
and the calculator is working totally
fine right so if we press OK and if we
refresh this let's use another operator
as well so let's say we are using the
division operator
click on OK and we'll enter the first
number let's say the first number is 45
and
the second number is let's say
8. okay the moment we press OK we have
the output as
5.625 the pop-up here says result is
5.625 so this calculator is working
totally fine
now this is a basic JavaScript
calculator right so we went through this
program so that you guys can revise what
we have learned till now
let's move ahead to the central part of
today's video and we'll create a
calculator like the original one so we
use calculators on phones or laptops as
well so today we are going to make one
similar to them so let me show you guys
what we are going to create
so this is the calculator we are going
to create today so this looks like an
actual calculator right we use such
calculators daily either on our phones
or on laptops or sometimes physically as
well so this looks like a calculator app
so let's try to use it let me Zoom it
for you guys so if we click on 8 and
then we click on any number so it will
be printed on the display area then
we'll use any operator then let's say we
are using 86 minus 5 so this is the
expression we want to evaluate so what
we have to do is we have to press this
equals to button and we have the output
as 81 so this calculator is also working
fine so today we are going to create one
such calculator or we can say we are
going to create this calculator only
now the question that arises here is how
difficult is it to create one such
calculator in JavaScript do we have to
write hundreds of lines of code for it
or do we have to write complex code for
it so in this video we will see how easy
it is to write code for such a
calculator
the code we saw earlier that is the one
where we used simple arithmetic
operators to find the output for simple
calculations for two numbers obviously
is not what we'll do in this one so it
will increase the code length like if we
use operators if we use if else
statement for each operator then
definitely it will increase the length
of the code so we'll try something
different and this next program for a
calculator app will let you know the
advantages provided by JavaScript in
terms of programming so let's start with
the programming part directly now we
don't need this file anymore so we'll
clear it next up we have three files
here right we have calculator.html and
then for styling we have style.css and
lastly we have script.js for adding
functionality to our calculator
right so today we will divide this code
into three different parts in the first
part we will work on the HTML file and
we'll create the layout of this
calculator then we'll move on to the CSS
part and there will add style to the
calculator and then finally We'll add
functionality to a calculator
so let's start with the HTML part then
now we have to keep a few things in mind
and we'll first add the simply code
image to our web page so for that we
have to write here inside the body tag
because we want to make a web page more
attractive right we'll write here div
we'll
use a division and then inside this div
tag we'll use the IMG tag then
the SRC will be
simply code dot PNG so this is the file
we have already saved in a folder now
we'll use the alt attribute here and the
alternate will be
simply code right
then next up this image size is quite
large so if we save this program now you
can see the image size is large right so
what we'll do is we'll limit the width
of this image so we'll write here width
and then let's say the width will be 300
pixel so this will be the default width
for this image as well as for the
calculator right next up we'll go back
to the original calculator and we can
see here we have a heading calculator
right so we'll add this as well so for
that we have to write here inside a HTML
file
will add another tag so we'll write here
div
and then we'll
provide it with a class let's say the
class is
title and
then we'll use the P tag paragraph tag
we can see so inside this P tag will
write here calculator so save it and you
can see here on the browser that we have
an image and over here we have a heading
as well right so if the heading here
says calculator we'll use CSS to style
these elements later for now we have
just added them to a web page next up
we'll start working on the body of this
calculator so let me show you guys this
is the body of this calculator this
whole area represents the body of this
calculator this display area and the
buttons as well so this is the whole
calculator body so for that we have to
write here first
right here div and then we'll use the
class attribute so the
class will be
let's say calculator fine now next up we
have to work on the display area as well
so this div tag is for the whole
calculator's body so the whole
calculators body include the display
area as well as all the buttons and this
whole area basically So This falls under
the calculators body so for the display
area we have to use input tag again so
what we are going to do is we are going
to create a placeholder type of thing so
we'll write here input we'll use the
input tag we'll write it type is equals
to text
and then we'll
use the class attribute here so let's
say the class for this display area will
be display and then we'll use a property
here we'll write here disabled
so I'll tell you what this disabled is
used for so for now let's save it and
here you can see if it's visible or not
so here is the display so this is a
placeholder type of thing so if you can
see here we can't click on it we simply
can't do anything inside it so this is
what the disabled property does so it
won't let the user to enter something on
the on this text box now you can see
here that we have a display area on our
web page and we can't do anything over
here it's disabled right that's because
we don't want the user to write anything
on it we want to take the input when the
user presses a key on the calculator so
let's move ahead and we are going to add
keys to our web page so we have four
rows here in the calculator body you can
see we have four rows starting from
seven four one and C right so these are
the four rows the first row contains
seven eight nine and plus operator and
then we have second row that contains
four five six and minus then we have
third row and fourth row as well right
so we'll use div tags for all the rules
and we'll keep all these four div tags
inside a single div tag that's because
we'll use the class attribute again to
add styling to a bunch of elements
together now we have several different
types of keys in our calculator so we
have 10 numeric keys and four operator
keys and equal key and one for clearing
the screen as well right so this key
here where we have written C so what
this will do is it will clear the
display area every time the user presses
it it will clear the display area
now so we are going to create different
classes for them so let's do it here
let's go back to our HTML file and here
what we'll do is
we'll write here
again a div tag
and for this div tag the class will be
let's say keys fine
now inside this div tag we are going to
create another div tag for each row so
for this div tag we'll write here div
class is equals to row
and inside this div tag what we'll do is
we'll create buttons so today we are
going to use the button element for it
so we'll write here
button and the first button we want to
add is
7 right because 7 is present at number
one if we see the calculator from the
start we can see 7 is at number one so
we'll write here value 7
and then we'll write here 7 then we'll
copy this and we'll create all the four
buttons in the first row so we'll paste
it again for four times then we have
button says 7 8 then we have 9 and then
finally we have
plus right so here we'll also change the
values
we'll write here
789 in plus so save it and if you move
back to our calculator you can see here
we have four buttons here we have 7 8 9
and plus all right so we'll style these
buttons later so for now what we'll do
is We'll add all the four rules so we'll
copy this whole div tag
and we'll paste it again
for all the rows so we'll paste it four
times and here what we'll do is we'll
create second row so the second row
contains four five six in minus right so
we'll write here four five six in minus
we'll change these values as well
similarly for third row
we'll write here 1
then
3 and then asterisk for multiplication
right then we have the fourth row so the
fourth row contains C 0 Division and
equal right so we'll write here
C
Division and equals right so we'll
change the values here as well we'll
write here
the same
so save it and here you can see we have
the body of our calculator we have a
display area we have all the four rows
with all the buttons so you can see
nothing is happening on clicking on
these buttons so we'll add functionality
to them as well so for now we are done
with our HTML part next up we'll use the
CSS for styling these element and we'll
style these elements one by one so let's
add the link of our CSS file to a HTML
document first We'll add it inside the
head tab
so we'll move to a head tag and we'll
add the link here so we'll write here
link
and then we'll write here Rel is equals
to
tile sheet and we'll write a type is
equals to
Text slash CSS
and then we'll write here hdf is equals
to
tile dot CSS so we have already
created this style.css here so we have
linked this CSS file to a HTML document
save it and then we'll move to a CSS
file and we'll start styling these
elements now
so first we'll apply padding and margin
to the whole HTML document so for the
whole HTML document we'll use the S
trick here and inside this asterisk will
right here
padding and will
keep the value as 0 for margin also
will keep the value as 0 so save it
so here you can see the padding in
margin are 0 and you must have noticed
the change here the calculator is now a
little bit compressed right
you can check it through the inspect
elements option as well next up we'll
apply styling to The Heading so we don't
have to do anything with the picture
although we can use the on Mouse over
and on Mouse out events with the picture
as well but I'm not doing it for now but
you guys can do it as we came across
this topic in the previous video so
let's move ahead and now we'll apply the
style to heading for that we have to use
the class attribute in a HTML file so if
we go back to HTML file and you can see
here with the heading or we we can say
with the calculator or paragraph tag we
have the class attribute here and the
class is title so we'll use this class
attribute here and we'll write here
Dot
title so let me guys first make changes
to this particular element then we'll
discuss it so we'll write here
margin bottom
is 10 pixel we want the distance between
the calculator and the heading is 10
pixel then we'll write here text align
Center so this is pretty basic then we
have
font weight is
bolder
and then we have
font size as well so we'll write here
extra large
then we have width of this particular
element and we note the default width is
300 pixels so we'll write here 300 pixel
and then we'll
use the color so we want the color to be
pure black for this heading so we'll
write here black
and we'll save it so here you can see we
have this heading in the center and till
now we haven't worked on the body of the
calculator so this calculator heading is
done we have the heading in the center
now these are the styling changes we
made in the heading part so we have used
the margin bottom as 10 pixel and it
will keep the heading 10 pixels away
from whatever is present on the bottom
side of the adding then we have aligned
the text in the center of the division
then we have the font weight as Boulder
which will make the font Bold and the
font size is extra large the width of
the section is also equal to the width
of the image we used then the font color
is black and we have seen the changes
next up we'll make style changes to our
body tag and we'll put this calculator
in the middle of the screen also we will
make changes to the font family as well
of the whole calculator now we are
making changes to the body of this HTML
document right we want the calculator to
be present at the center of the web page
so for that
we'll write here
body
so we don't have any class so we'll
write a body because we want to make
changes in the element so for body we'll
write here width
as
100 VW
height is
100 VH
display is flex
then we have
justify content
as Center
then we have align items as
Center
then we have background color so we can
change the background color of the whole
body so we'll write here
if
1 F1 F1
so this is a little bit different from
White so we'll check it then we have
font family
as
sense serif right
so this VW and VH in width and height is
the viewport width and viewport height
so this will take 100 of the viewport
width and the height as well next up we
have used the display as flex and we
have used the justify content and align
content as the center we did so in order
to keep the calculator in the center of
the web page then we use the background
color as white color to any other color
as well but let's keep it simple this
time and lastly we use the phone family
as sense serif save it and here we have
a calculator in the center of the web
page so let me Zoom it for you guys you
can see here we have the calculator in
the center of this webpage
now next up we'll work on the body of
this calculator so the body represents
the display area and the buttons right
not the buttons but this whole div tag
inside which the buttons are present
represents the calculator's body
so we'll use the class calculator to
make changes here
for that we'll write here inside the CSS
file we'll write here Dot
calculator and inside this we'll write
width so we want the width to be default
which is 300 pixel so we'll write here
then we'll write padding bottom
15 pixel
so save it
and you can't see any changes for now so
we'll see it
next up we'll write here
border radius and the Border radius will
be
let's say 7 pixel
we want the background color to be black
for the calculators body so we'll write
here background color
black
and then we have box
Shadow so we'll Define inside this box
Shadow we'll write here five
pixel
8 pixel
then
8 pixel and minus 2 pixel
so what we are doing is we are working
on the shadow of this box and then we'll
write here
rgba
for red it will be 0 for green it will
be 0
and for blue as well it will be
0 and then for
Alpha
it will be
0.61 fine so this color is a bit
different from Black
save it and here you can see we have the
calculators body so let me Zoom it out a
little bit
so here you can see we have the
calculators body so this is the
calculator's body and we haven't worked
on the display area and the buttons till
now so it will be fine after we'll work
on the display area and buttons
now we have kept the width has 300 just
like we did for the image and heading
so the background color is black and the
Box Shadow is defined for this box as
well next up we'll work on the display
area and then we'll move ahead to the
keys so let's work with the display area
first we'll write here display because
we have used the classes display for a
display
so inside this will write
width as
100 of this calculators body
and then we'll write here height so
height will be let's say 80 pixels we
can't write here 100 because we don't
want the display area to be present
within the whole calculator so we want
it to be this much only so we'll write
here 80 pixels save it and the display
area you can see here we have the
display area is 100 of this div tag the
width is 100 and the height is 80 pixels
and then we'll add another styling
properties as well so we don't want any
border so for Border we'll write here
none
and then for
box sizing we'll write here
border box
and then padding will be
10 pixel so we want the text to be 10
pixel above the calculators black part
and then we'll write here
font size is double XL so we'll write a
extra extra large
then we'll use the background color so
the background color is little bit
grayish so the code for that is
CCC e c c
so this is the color of a display area
then we have the font color is
black
and the text will be aligned we want the
text to be aligned at the right
so we'll write here right so next up
what we want to do is we want the
display to be a little bit curved from
the top left and right Corners right so
for that we'll write here border top
left radius will be
7 pixel and
border top right radius will be 7 pixel
right save it and you can see here we
have a display area perfect now we have
curves from left and right side from the
top and left and top and right side
with this we are done with the display
area as well next up we'll move on to
the button part here we have a class
named Row for all the buttons and then
we have a class as operators for all the
operators button and then we have class
as equals for the equal to button as
well right so if we go back to our HTML
file what we'll do is we'll Define two
more classes so for operators like
for addition subtraction multiplication
and division the class will be
operators
so we'll copy it from here
and we'll give it to almost each
operator as well as the clear screen
button
so we'll give it here as well
we'll give it to minus will give give it
to addition as well save it
and for equals to we have another class
as
equals fine
save it let's move back to our CSS file
and firstly we'll
use the class Row for styling all the
buttons similarly then we'll use class
operators and equals for
making minor changes to those particular
buttons right so first we'll use the
button tag so we'll write a button so
we'll make changes to each and every
button with the help of this button
element we'll write here
width as 50 pixel
and height will also be 50. so we'll
write here for height 50 pixel and then
we have
border radius as
50 because we want our buttons to be
circular right so we'll write here 50
the Border radius then we'll write here
for Border we don't want any border so
for Border wheel right here
none
and for outline also we don't want any
outline as well so we'll write a none
for font size so let's say the font size
we want is extra large fine
the background color for all the buttons
will be white
and
font color for all the buttons will be
black
so we'll write a white and black and the
font weight
will be bold
and lastly the margin
for each button will be 10 pixel
so save it and here you can see a
calculator information right so we can
see here we have all the buttons
circular in shape we have four rows and
all the buttons are circular in shape if
we compare this calculator to the
original one to the one which we are
going to achieve later in this video so
you can see here both of them looks
almost similar right we have all the
buttons here and next up what we'll do
is We'll add some more styling to these
buttons so
let's move ahead and we'll add hover
effect to the buttons to help us change
the mouse pointer when the user takes
the cursor over any button so if we go
here inside this calculator and you can
see here on taking the mouse cursor over
any button the mouse cursor is changing
here right but if we go back to this
calculator you can see there's no change
in this particular calculator right so
for that we have to write here
button and then we'll write here Hoover
so inside this
will write here
cursor as pointer
so save it and if we take a cursor to
any of these buttons you can see the
cursor is changing to pointer right
so
we are done with it
next up we'll use two more properties
for each row and our buttons are almost
done with some part left like the color
and all so we'll write a row because we
have defined the class as Row for each
row so we'll write here display and the
display will be Flex
and will justify content as space
between
so save it and here you can see both the
calculators are now of similar size
there is no difference in these two
calculators now we'll make changes to
the colors of operator buttons and the
equal to button so for that we have two
more classes operator class and equals
class
so we'll write here for the operator
class so we'll write here dot operator
and inside this we will write here
background color as so we want the
background color to be a little bit
golden or we can say it's different from
yellow and golden so we'll write here we
have particular code for this color so
we'll write here
hash FF
9500 so this is the code for this
particular color we'll save it and the
mistake is the class name is operators
save it and we have all the operators
with this color
next up we'll write here
font weight as
bold
save it and then we have color font
color as black so it will be default as
well because these properties we have
already defined in the button tag next
up we have another class for the equal
to button so we'll write here dot equals
and inside this we want the background
color to be a little bit on the grayish
side so for that the RGB code is 85 84
and
84. so save it and here you can see we
have the equal to button in gray color
next up we'll copy these two properties
from here
and we'll paste them here save it and
here you can see with this we are done
with the calculator
and we have the calculator almost same
suppose we compare this calculator with
the final one we can see we have the
exact same calculator here and the HTML
and the CSS part is done now we are left
with only one thing the next thing we
have to do is we have to add
functionality to this calculator
so we have the body of a calculator but
if we try to click on these buttons you
can see nothing is happening over here
that's because we haven't
added any functionality to a calculator
yet so let's move on to the JavaScript
part and we'll create certain functions
here to add functionality to a
calculator talking about the functioning
of a calculator we need three functions
one for the display area one for the
calculation part and the last one is for
the clear screen that will be used when
the user presses the clear screen button
this particular button when the user
will press the screen will get cleared
the idea behind the working of the
calculator is whatever button the user
will press will be displayed on the
display screen then we'll use the eval
function to evaluate the expression we
get from the display and then the
estimated value will be printed on the
screen so the last function will clear
the screen again and can be used again
for another calculation so the concept
is simple let's start with the
programming part directly
and before that what we'll do is we'll
add this Javascript file to a HTML
document so we will write here
Crypt SRC is equals to
script dot Js
type is equals to Text slash
JavaScript save it and we have connected
the JS file to a HTML document now we
are inside a Javascript file so the
concept is simple let's start with the
programming part directly so we'll
create a function for the display first
and that function will take the input
from whatever will be there on the
display screen so we'll write here
function display and it will take a
parameter as well and then we have the
body of this function so here we are and
we have a function display with
parameter value and then we'll update
the value present in the display box so
we'll use the on click event first and
we'll display the value of these buttons
on display so for this we'll go back to
our HTML file and we'll use the on click
event there so what we'll do is
will right here
on click
and on clicking button 7 will call
display function and it will display
something on the screen so we'll write
here
7 and similarly what we'll do is we'll
copy this and we'll paste it for each
button right so let me do it for you
guys
will paste it here
then we'll paste it again and again for
each button except the clear screen and
equal button right so we'll write here
eight
then for 9 it will display 9 and for
plus it will display
Plus
then we'll again paste it here for all
the buttons
what we have to do is we have to keep
one thing in mind it won't work for
equal and clear screen button apart from
that all the buttons will call this
function on clicking so
we'll write here minus for minus
operator
4 6 will write here 6 4 5 will write in
five and for 4 will write here 4. we'll
do this
okay we forgot to change the values here
so we'll change the values as well
so we'll write a one two three and then
we'll paste the on click event here
and we'll change the values here as well
so we'll write a 1
for 2 will write here 2 for 3 will write
here three
and for operators we'll write you
s trick then we'll do the same for on
click display 0 it will display zero for
division it will
display
division
save it and you can see nothing is
displaying on the display area yet
because we haven't added the
functionality to the function displayed
so before moving on to the Javascript
file let's add the ID attribute as well
to the display area because we are
accessing the display area and will
access that area with the ID attribute
so we'll write here ID and the ID let's
say will be id1 so save it and we'll
move back to a JavaScript file now here
inside this display function will
right here
document Dot get element by ID and the
ID is
id1
so we'll write here dot value
plus is equals to well so we'll discuss
it what we did just now so save it first
and if we click on any button now you
can see we have all the values in the
display area now
right
so other buttons are not working yet so
if we click on this clear screen button
it won't work or the equal to button
either won't work now because till now
we haven't defined these functions so
this statement here this document dot
get element by ID id1 dot Value Plus
equals to well this particular statement
will use the ID attribute and we have
written here plus equals to so basically
what we are doing is we are appending
any new value to the previous value
present in the display area
so if we remove this plus here
and save it now
so if we click on a button let's say we
are clicking on a button and we want to
print 89 on the display area but if we
click on 9 you can see it's not
appending right the values are
overwriting because we are using the
equal to operator only and the value
will be assigned to display screen again
and again but if we want to append the
value with the previous one so we have
to add plus here and if we save it now
you can see now we can add as many
numbers as we want to the display area
right now we have the expression present
over here in the display area so if we
refresh it and let's say the expression
is 87 plus 3 the next thing we want to
do is to calculate the value of this
expression for that we can either use
the if else statements but then the code
will go so long and complex right in
order to solve this problem JavaScript
provides its user with a single function
that can compute complex calculation in
the blink of an I so today we'll use a
function named eval so this eval
function will take any argument as a
string and it will execute it
the string can be an expression it can
be a variable it can be a statement or a
sequence of statements as well so we'll
call a function solve on clicking the
equal button to solve the expression
written over the display area so for
that we'll move back to our HTML file
and here on the equal button what we'll
do is we'll write here
on click and on clicking it will call
the solve function
so save it and we'll move back to our
JavaScript file
and we'll declare a function here we'll
Define a function so we'll write your
function
solve
and then we have the body of this
function so let me cross check it yeah
it's solve
so inside this function solve we'll take
two variables so let's say we have two
variables
let X and Y
so inside the X we'll take whatever
value present in the display screen so
we'll write your document Dot get
element by ID mail right here id1 so we
are taking the value present at the
display screen so we'll write a DOT well
and what we'll do is now we have a
variable X which holds the reference of
the value present at the display screen
so we'll write here a single function
we'll write a event and then inside this
evil we'll write X so with this we are
done with the calculation part next up
what we have to do is we have to assign
this displays to Y so the value present
at y will be assigned to the display
screen to the element with IDs id1
basically so save it and if we write
here 86 plus 4 and if we click on this
equal button
so we have to write here dot value
save it now and if we
write here 86 plus 4 you can see the
answer is 90. the mistake was here we
have written Val here instead of value
so it's working fine now next up what we
have to do is we have to clear the
display screen on clicking this C button
right
so first we'll use this function we'll
create another function for function
clear screen and then we'll use this
function with the on click event inside
the button C right so we'll go back to
HTML file we'll write here
on click and inside this wheel right
let's say CLR a function name is CLR
so what we'll do is we'll Define another
function here we'll write here function
CLR
and what we'll do is to clear the
display area we have to provide empty
space to this area right so for that we
have to write here we have to again
use document dot get element by ID the
ID is id1 for the display area dot value
is equals to
the value will be empty space right so
this single statement will clear the
display area and a calculator is finally
ready so save it and if you can see here
we'll write here 89 and then we'll press
C so you can see on clicking the C the
display area is going blank again and if
we write here let's say 58 plus 2 is
equals to 60 so we have the correct
answer as well and on clicking the C
button the display area goes blank again
right so let's start using this
calculator any expression we'll write
inside the display area will get
evaluated and will have the answer in
the same display as well
so let's try so we'll write a bit
complex equation here so we'll write
here let's say 74 into 3 plus
55 divided by 5. so the answer will be
first it will divide 55 by 5 then it
will multiply 74 and 3 and then it will
show the answer so if we press this
equal button so you can see the answer
is 233 right
so this calculator is working totally
fine you can check the answer by
yourself as well so this is how we can
create a basic calculator in JavaScript
and you guys saw it in today's video the
benefits of using JavaScript is
Javascript provides the user with so
many such functions like the eval
function making the daily life of a
programmer easy and exciting before
going deep into this topic let's recall
events in JavaScript so the simple
definition of an event states that
something that happens so when we
manipulate an HTML document in
JavaScript we try to do something on the
web page right so several events take
place on a website like the user hovers
over a specific element or clicks on an
element or pressing a key in the website
can also refer to events or we can say
submitting a form or playing a video
also refers to the same thing so we are
using the on click event for the past
few videos wherein we discuss that a
specific task would be performed on
clicking a particular button what we did
was we were just calling a function by
clicking a button in HTML so clicking a
button is also an event right and the
function that will be called upon
clicking the button is known as event
handler because that function is
basically asking the computer to perform
a particular task on clicking the button
so like the on click event we have some
more exciting events present in HTML
which helps us make a web page more
interactive and responsive as well so we
can do it with the help of JavaScript so
we'll go through two such events today
the on Mouse over event and the on Mouse
out event so the on Mouse over event
will perform a task when the user takes
the mouse cursor on that element
similarly the on Mouse out event also
performs a task when the user takes the
mouse cursor away from that element so
for example let's suppose we have an
image present in our web page and we
want to change the size of that image
when the user takes the mouse cursor
over that image and the image should get
back to its previous size when the user
takes away the crystal so what's
basically happening is when the user is
taking its Mouse over the image or
picture the picture size will increase
and on taking the mouse cursor away from
the image the size will get back to its
default size so let's do it once and
we'll see how these events work within
an HTML document so first of all let's
add an image to the HTML file we'll use
the IMG tag for that and will have to
provide the path for the image right so
we'll write here in a HTML file We'll
add an image here so we'll write here
IMG and then we have to provide the
source and the images are stored inside
the images folder in this system so
we'll write here the image name so we
have provided the path here next up what
we'll do is we'll use the alt attribute
so we'll write here in the alt we'll
write a simply code
fine
save it
and here you can see we have an image
over a browser but the image size is
quite large right so we'll limit the
size of this image using the width
property so what we'll do is we'll write
here width
and let's say the width of the image
will be 250 pixel
save it and now you can see we have an
image over here the image is in its
normal size so this is the image so we
have this image over here and next thing
what we are going to do is we are going
to increase the size of this picture on
taking the mouse cursor over this image
so what will happen is when we take our
mouse cursor here the picture size will
increase so for that we have to use the
on Mouse over property or we can see the
on Mouse over event so what we'll do is
we'll write here on Mouse
over and we'll call a function on taking
the mouse cursor over this image so
we'll write here change size
so we'll declare it in a JavaScript file
and we'll call this function on taking
the mouse cursor over this picture
so next thing we are going to do is
we are going to move to our JavaScript
file and we'll Define this change size
function there
so let's
go to the JavaScript part we'll go to a
JS file and we'll write here we'll
declare a function first so we'll write
here function change size
and then we have the body of this
function so we can do it without taking
any variable like in the previous videos
we were taking a variable to store the
reference of the ID attribute so this
time we are going to use the
document.getelementbyid but we are not
going to use a separate variable for
storing the reference so we'll write
here
document dot get element by ID and we
haven't provided the ID yet so let's do
one thing let's move back to our HTML
file and we'll use the ID attribute here
as well inside the IMG tag we'll write a
ID let's say the ID is
I am G1 I mean save it and will
right here inside the JS file will give
the ID here as well so we have the IDS
IMG one
save it and the next thing we are going
to do is we are going to use the style
property with this document.getelement
by ID method so we'll write here Dot
style and then we'll write a DOT width
and then we'll specify the width so
we'll write here the width as let's say
500 pixel the default width is
250 pixels right so save it and let's
see if it's working fine or not so here
is the image on the browser and we'll
take the mouse cursor over the image and
you can see the change in the size of
this picture so JavaScript makes it easy
to do such tasks now you might have
noticed that the image's size Remains
the Same once the user takes the mouse
cursor away from the image right so the
image size is changed let me zoom out a
little bit so it will be easy for you
guys so what we'll do is we'll refresh
this page and here you can see on taking
the mouse cursor over this image the
change in the size of this particular
picture
so now the MSI is 500 pixel now the
message is not getting back to its
original size like what we did was we
used the on Mouse over event and the
image size is changing and that's
working totally fine so the next thing
we are going to do is we are going to
use the on Mouse out event and what will
happen is the image size will get back
to its default size like which is the
250 pixel so we'll for that we'll use
another function so first we have to use
the on Mouse out event here
so we'll write here on Mouse out and we
have to create another function so we'll
write a change size 2 so this will be a
function name save it
and here we have to create another
function in the JavaScript file so we'll
write here function change size and the
function name is change size to
then we have the body of this function
and we'll use the document Dot get
element by ID method
the ID is same which is IMG one and then
we are going to use the style property
again and this time we'll specify the
width as
250 pixel so this is the default size of
our image save it so what we did is we
created a function that will be called
when the user takes away the mouse
cursor from the picture and the image
size will be changed to 250 pixels which
was the initial size of the image
so save it
and now you can see here on the browser
the image size is changing on taking the
mouse cursor over the image the image
size is 500 pixel now and on taking the
mouse cursor away from the image the
image is getting back to its default
size right so you can see the change
here so this is how we can use these
events to make a web page more
interactive and attractive as well next
up we'll go through another example
wherein we will change the image on the
mouse over event and the default image
will be shown on taking the cursor away
from the image so this image will change
on taking the mouse cursor over it and
again it will get back to the default
image on taking the mouse cursor away
from the image so guys here's the code
for the same and what will happen is the
image will change on taking the mouse
cursor over it and gets back to the
default on taking the cursor away so
guys the HTML part will remain the same
wherein we use the IMG tag to add an
image and then we have two functions one
for the on Mouse over and another for
the on Mouse out event so in the
JavaScript file we defined the two
functions here so you can see the
function one is change image and the
function 2 is change image 2. so what's
happening is we are using the get
element by ID method again and this time
we are using the SRC attribute and what
we are doing is we are changing the
source of image like we are using here
the simply learn.png so this is our
image saved in the particular folder
inside the images folder and in the next
function what we are doing is we are
again changing the image to the default
image so we have used the simply
code.png image here so what will happen
is the default image will be replaced by
this image when this function is called
and the other function here will again
replace the new image with the default
one so let's take a look at the output
and save it so here you can see on
taking mouse cursor over this image you
can see the change so this is the image
we want to change so on taking the Mouse
cuts are away from this image you can
see the image gets back to the default
one you can see the image is changing
and it's quite responsive and attractive
so this is how we can use these events
in JavaScript callback functions in
JavaScript are different from normal
functions as they are used to make a
function executable only after a primary
function is execute
so we'll understand the importance and
usage of these functions in JavaScript
before we begin make sure that you are
subscribed to our YouTube channel and
press that Bell icon to never miss an
update on programming videos
so without any further delay let's get
started functions in JavaScript are a
block of code that is used to perform a
specific task we use functions for
different purposes right whether it be a
button click or we want to zoom out our
image by taking the mouse cursor over it
we use functions for all these tasks in
JavaScript we can use functions as
objects at the same time we can pass
objects to functions as parameters right
so similarly we can also pass a function
inside another function if I take you
through the programming part of this
concept the syntax will be like we'll go
to a Javascript file and the syntax will
be like will
declare a function let's say the
function is function ABC then here we'll
pass a parameter let's say we are
passing call as parameter for this
function ABC next up what we'll do is
we'll call this function inside this
function ABC Now what we did here is
really simple we created a function ABC
right next up we passed a function call
as a parameter to this function and then
we also call this function inside the
function ABC so this syntax is valid in
JavaScript and also this particular code
Here is known as the Callback function
in JavaScript so if we talk about the
definition of callback function it
states that a callback function is a
function that is passed to another
function as an argument and that
particular function will get executed
later in the program
now you guys might have heard in the
previous videos that JavaScript is a
single threaded language or JavaScript
works over a single statement at a time
or we can say JavaScript Works in a
particular top to bottom order
so if we talk about the sequence in
which JavaScript actually works while
coding so let's take an example for this
and we'll see the sequence in which
JavaScript will work so what we'll do is
we'll comment this code and we'll start
writing our new code here so let's
suppose we have three functions in a
single program so let's say we have a
function as function1
and then we have two more functions so
let's say the second function is
function two
and then we have
function
3 as well
now if we write something inside these
functions so we'll execute the program
and what will happen is all the three
functions will be executed sequentially
so let's try to do it first
so what we'll do is we'll
right here inside the body of function
one so let's say we are using console
DOT log and inside this will print
function 1 on calling this particular
function
so we will do the same for other two
functions as well so we'll copy it from
here we'll paste it here and here as
well so for function 2 it will print
function
to
and for function 3 it will print
function 3.
so let's save it and before checking the
output so what we'll do is we'll call
these functions as well so let's say we
are calling function 1 then function two
and then finally function
3.
right everything we have done till now
is quite understandable and we have
three functions here and all the three
functions will get executed in the
sequence in which we call them so here
in this case we have called Function One
first followed by function 2 and
function three so let's check the output
save it and we'll open the console in
the browser so we'll right click here go
to inspect elements and here you can see
we have a console here so here you can
see we have the output as function 1
function 2 and function 3. so we have
the output in sequence we call Function
One first so we have the output as
function one but if we call function 3
before function 2. so we'll cut this
from here and we'll paste function 2
after function 3.
save it and here you can see we have the
output as function 1 then function 3 and
then function 2.
2 so JavaScript will execute these
functions in the order in which we call
them right now what if we use the set
timeout function with function one so
let's try to do it first
so instead of calling function 1 alone
here we'll write here set timeout
then we have to pass two parameters here
one is the function name so one is the
function name here
and we'll write here the time so time
here will be in milliseconds so 2000
milliseconds here represents two seconds
this means that the function will be
called after two seconds
wait so this set timeout function will
call function when after a specific
period of time that is in this case two
seconds
what will happen is Javascript will
start executing all the functions and
the system will find out that there is a
timer with function one so in this case
the system will leave this particular
function on execution and will move
ahead and execute other function so
function 1 will be executed
automatically after two seconds so let's
check the output
save it and you can see here we have
function 3 and 2 over here and function
1 will be executed after some time so I
hope you guys got this and here we have
used the set timeout method and function
1 will be executed after two seconds
now let's consider a scenario where we
have only two functions let's say we
have function one and function 2. so
let's remove this function 3
and we are left with only two functions
so let's say we have function 1 and
function 2 now
now what we want is we want to execute
these two functions but we have certain
conditions so the first condition is
function 1 will use the set timeout
method and it will be executed after
three seconds
and the second condition is function 2
will get executed only after function 1
executes so till now what we have seen
is if we are using these two functions
and if we are using the set timeout
method with function1 what is happening
is Javascript will keep this function on
execution and it will execute this
function till then so what we want is we
want to execute function 2 only after
the execution of function 1. this is
where the concept of callback functions
comes into play so we have to ask the
computer to execute function 2 only
after function 1 is done
so let me write this same code in
another way we'll use the set timeout
method within function1 so what we have
to do is we have to change
it here 2 1 will call function 1 from
here and inside this function 1 what
we'll do is we'll write here set timeout
then we'll pass the first argument as
function and then inside the body of
this function we'll write this console
log
fine and we have to pass two parameters
here right so the next parameter will be
in the time so time here will be
3000 seconds so here we are and we are
done with our set timeout function now
this is another way of using the set
timeout method in JavaScript so what we
did here is we have passed the function
here as an argument and then we have the
body of function 1 inside the set
timeout function
what we want to do next is we want to
execute function 2 once function 1 is
completed so before that let's do one
thing let's check if it is working fine
or not so we'll save it
and here you can see we have function 2
executed before function one right so
it's working totally fine now what we
want to do is we want function 2 to
execute only after function 1 is done
right so let me tell you a shortcut for
that guys it's not callback functions
but it's kind of same thing it will do
the same thing as the Callback functions
but it is a different concept so what we
have to do is we have to cut this
function 2 from here and we have to call
this function inside here inside the set
timeout method so we'll paste it here
and we have to call function 2 inside
the set timeout method save it and now
if we wait for three seconds and here
you can see we have both the functions
function 1 and 2 executed on time so
both the functions are executed after
three seconds
and this is not callback functions but
this is a shortcut for that what
happened here is when function 1 is
being executed the system came to know
that the function 2 is called inside the
set timeout method so what will happen
is it will first execute the set timeout
method and then it will execute the
function 2. so what we did just now is
not callback functions but the
functioning of a callback function is
also the same this is the same thing
we'll do with callback functions but the
syntax will be different now by the
definition of the Callback function that
we came across earlier it states that a
callback function is a function that is
passed to another function as in
argument so keep your focus on this word
argument and that particular function
will be executed later that function
which we passed as argument will be
executed later
so here in this definition later means
once the system is done with the first
function or we can say the primary
function it is now free to perform
function 2 or the secondary function or
the Callback function we can say
so we have kept it on hold till now so
let's take an example of that as well
what we'll do is we'll create a function
and we'll pass an argument inside this
function
the value will be provided while calling
the function so let's do one thing first
let's comment this code
and we'll write a new code here so we'll
create a function let's say a function
is function person and we'll pass an
argument here so let's say the argument
is friend fine
next up will work on the body of this
function what we'll do is we'll again
use
console.log and will print something so
let's say We'll
write here
my
friend's name is
and then we'll use the plus operator
with the
value of friend
you will write your friend
and with this we are done with our
function person next up what we'll do is
we'll write here
function
person
2 and we don't have to pass any argument
here so inside the body of this function
we'll again use console.log and we'll
write here
my name is
caution
fine
so
next up what we have to do is we have to
call these functions right so we'll
write a person
and inside this we have to pass the
value so let's say the value here is
simply code that's fine next up we'll
call person two
and we'll save this program so on saving
this program you can see we have the
output as my friend's name is simply
code so if you want me to zoom it you
can see here now here it says my
friend's name is simply code and the
second function says my name is kaushal
right so this program is working totally
fine this is a basic program wherein we
created two function and now what we
want to do is we want the function
person to
will get executed after function person
so for that we have to pass function 2
as an argument in the function person
so we'll change the code
we'll pass this function person 2 as an
argument so we'll write here
person two we don't have to use brackets
here so because we are passing it as an
argument
now
we did it we passed this function as an
argument the next step is to tell the
function person about it right we have
to pass another argument in the function
so
we have to tell this first function that
we also have another function which will
get executed after this particular
function
so we will write here
we can use any name we can use another
name for that or we can use the same
name as of function person two so we'll
write here
person two
and then what we have to do is we have
to call this person to function after
this
right now we are done with this code now
we are done with a callback function
here in this case this function person 2
is known as the Callback function
so save it now
and
okay what we have to do is we have to
remove this line from here so save it
now here you can see we have the output
totally correct we have the output as my
friend's name is simply code and my name
is caution
now we are done with almost everything
we are done with the Callback functions
but you might not see any change in the
output right to witness the change what
we have to do is we have to use the set
timeout method again because we want
this function to execute only after
function person so what we have to do is
we have to write here
inside function person we'll write here
set timeout and
then we have to write your function
and then
inside the body will do the same we'll
cut these two brackets from here and
we'll paste them here and inside here we
have to write the time so let's say the
time is 3000 fine
now what we did is we use the set
timeout method with function person and
inside the body it will print my
friend's name is and the friend's name
is simply good and it will be executed
after three seconds right so let's save
it and we'll count for three one two and
three so here is the code you can see
here the output says my friend's name is
simply code and my name is caution so
this is working totally fine so this is
how the concept of callback functions in
JavaScript works the word promise seems
a bit familiar we make promises
regularly right if I say I promise you
that will cover everything on promises
in this video now this promise that I
made can only have two possible outcomes
either the promise will be fulfilled or
resolved or we can say the promise can
be failed or rejected the promise will
be resolved if we'll cover everything on
promises in this video but if I left out
some topic or there is any sub topic
within promises which we forgot to cover
in this video that will be a failed
promise or we can say a rejected one now
there is another term in between these
terms that is pending pending is the
time in which the system works on the
promise
so just remember these terms as you may
hear them during an interview
so let's move on talking about a proper
definition of promises we can say that A
promise is an object which will produce
value sometimes it either gives us a
value or an error with the proper reason
there is no specific definition for
promises in JavaScript you will
understand the topic much better while
working on the syntax
so let's move ahead and we'll go through
a simple example first to understand a
promise in JavaScript
as we mentioned earlier that A promise
is an object so what we have to do first
is to take a variable and declare an
object so for that we'll go to a
Javascript file and we'll write here
we'll take a variable let's say a
variable name is prom and we'll write
here new
promise so this statement here is a
promise we have an object named prom
Next Up This Promise will take a
callback function we have already
discussed the concept of callback
functions in the previous video so if
you haven't watched that video yet I
recommend you to watch it so a callback
function is a function pass to another
function as an argument remember so
we'll write here
inside this object we'll write here
function
and now this callback function here will
have two arguments one to resolve and
another for the reject that's because we
can have only two possibilities in a
promise right either it can be rejected
or it can be resolved so we'll write
here
resolve and then after a comma we'll
write here reject fine then we'll have
the body of this function
so this is how a promise will look like
you can change the name of these
arguments instead of resolve or reject
you can write here anything but we have
kept it simple for now so that it will
be easy to understand next up let's use
a simple condition here let's take the
example of driving a car fine what we'll
do is we'll take a variable drive and
we'll check if the user learned how to
drive a car if yes then the promise is
fulfilled otherwise the promise is
rejected
so let's do it here we'll write here
where Drive
and let's set the value of this drive is
true for now let's say the user learned
how to drive a car
so next up what we'll do is we'll use
the if else conditional statement to
call any one of the two functions we can
either call resolve or reject right so
we'll write a if and the condition will
be drive so if we left it with drive
here it will check for if Drive is
equals to True right so we will call the
function resolve if the condition holds
true and then we'll use the else
statement for else we'll write here else
and then we'll write here
reject
fine
any value other than true will call the
reject function here so what we did here
was an easy task we know that the value
for the variable Drive is true so in
this case the resolve function will be
called if we set this value of variable
drive to false then the function reject
will be called
the next part of the program is to
execute this promise so this will be the
longer part as we have to use two
methods here so for that the syntax will
start with the promise name and then
we'll use the dot operator so let me do
it here we'll write here
prom and then we'll use the dot operator
next up we'll use the then keyword so
this then keyword or it is a method
actually
it is called when the method is resolved
or when the promise is resolved so we
have another method for the rejection of
promises that we'll discuss afterwards
so we'll write here from dot then
now this is a method so we will use
brackets here when this method is called
it means that the promise is resolved
we'll use a callback function within
this method so we'll write here function
and then we'll use
the resolve function here so we'll write
here
resolve fine
and then we'll have the body for resolve
so this is how the execution will look
like for promises and on filling the
promise there will be a statement
printed on the control
so it will be like will write here
console.log
and we'll write here something so let's
say we are writing here
resolve
and let's say
the user
knows how to drive fine so we'll write
here this
now we are done with the part in which
the promise will be fulfilled one thing
I forgot to mention here is we have to
pass this resolve here so whatever value
we'll write here will be shown in
consume so let's say we are writing here
for True Value we'll write here yes
fine now if we save this program and
check for the output we'll get the
output as yes the user knows how to
drive we can check it so let's save it
and here you can see in the console we
have the output as yes the user knows
how to drive let me put a space here so
let's save it now now it's clearly
visible so it says yes the user knows
how to drive
so this is working fine now the next
part will be for the condition if the
promise gets rejected so just like we
had the then method for resolving the
promise similarly we have one more
method for the rejection part so for the
rejection part we have the catch method
so we have to change this method here
only after the then method so we'll come
here and we'll write dot catch
and the rest of the syntax will remain
same so we'll write here function and
then we'll call reject
then we'll have the body of this reject
part and we'll write here inside this
console.log
and we'll write here reject
Plus
the user
does not know
how
to drive
fine the catch method uses the reject
function and the output will be no the
user does not know how to drive so
before that we'll have to pass an
argument here so we'll write here no
and save it now so for now it says yes
the user knows how to drive to check for
the reject method we have to set the
value of variable drive as false so
let's change the value here let's say we
are using
false here now save it and you can see
here the output says no the user does
not know how to drive fine so this is
working totally fine now you guys might
be thinking that this program we just
did is so easy we could have done it
with if else conditional statements then
why are we using promises for this the
syntax is extended and we have to
remember a lot of terms and methods for
a promise right the good part is this
was just an example to make you
understand the syntax of promises in
JavaScript
next up we'll go through an example
wherein we'll discuss the dependency of
promises as well so let's move ahead and
in this example what we'll do is we'll
create three separate functions let's
suppose we want to learn promises in
JavaScript
but for that we must know about the
concept of functions and callback
functions in JavaScript then only we can
go through promises so what we'll do is
we'll create three functions in which
the current function will depend upon
the previous function if the user knows
about functions he can go through
callback functions and if the user knows
both functions and callback functions he
is good to go for promises so let me
take you through the code guys
so here's the code we have three
functions the first one is for functions
topic so this functions is the topic
similarly we have callback and Promises
as well so the first function is for the
functions topic and if the user is done
with functions in JavaScript then he can
move on to callback functions and then
to promises so we have three different
promises for each function right so each
function here like the first function
returns a promise right similarly all
the three functions are returning a
promise here we are directly resolving
it we don't need to wait for the user to
learn functions completely otherwise we
can use here the reject function as well
for now we are just resolving it which
means that the user learned functions in
JavaScript already the same goes for
callback functions and Promises as well
next up what we have to do is we have to
execute the promise that once the user
is done with functions he can move on to
callback functions and then to promises
so for that we have to execute promise
like this only but the syntax will be
different so let me show you guys
so here is the code for that as well
what we did here is we use the first
function here so functions is our first
function and on resolving we call the
function callback with the result and we
did the same thing again for a callback
on resolving the Callback function it
will call the promises function and
finally it will print this good to go
message on the console with the previous
messages written by the resolve method
so we are basically working on the
dependency of promises in JavaScript now
let's save this program and we'll check
the output on the console so
save it and here you can see it on the
console it says good to go and then it
says learned functions learned callback
functions good to go for promises in
JavaScript
now this same program can be done with
the help of callback functions as well
but the code will be so confusing
because we have to Nest all these
functions inside a single function and
then it will be a mess right the code
with promises is clean you can see here
the code is clean all we had to do here
was to create functions then return
promises on call and then we can execute
those promises with their dependency
so this is how promises in JavaScript
actually works now we have been using
functions in almost every video since we
came across this topic whether it be Dom
manipulation or using an event in
JavaScript functions are everywhere
right
so this concept of Arrow function is
just a change in the syntax of declaring
and defining a function
so let's go through the concept of
functions in JavaScript quickly so that
it will be easy to change the syntax
later what we'll do is we'll create a
function with multiple parameters and
then we'll create another function with
no parameter at all so we know these
Concepts already so let's write the code
here so we'll go to a Javascript file
and we'll write code here so we'll write
a function let's say the function name
is
Funk one
and then this function have two
parameters A and B
now this function will return something
so we'll write here return
let's say this returns a plus b
fine now the code we wrote here is to
find the sum of two numbers right we'll
pass the two numbers as arguments while
calling the function so let's check on
the console once if the code is working
fine or not so we'll save it move back
to the browser go to inspect and then
we'll go to a console and we'll write
here
function name and then we'll pass
certain parameters right so let's say
the parameters we are passing are 15 and
25 so the output we are expecting is 40
and the output is correct we have the
output as 40. you can see here we have
the output as 40. and so this function
is working totally fine next up we'll
create another function first and then
we'll move to the arrow function syntax
so for the second function we'll write
here function let's say the function
name is function
and this function will have no
parameters at all right so let's say
this function prints something on the
console right so we'll write a
console.log and then let's say this
function prints
welcome
to Simply code
we are done with it so let's do one
thing we'll call this function here
we'll write a function calling the
function is pretty easy we can do the
same thing here as well so let's save it
and check the output here you can see we
have the output as welcome to Simply
code in our console so this is how we
were using functions till now the simple
Syntax for functions right so let's move
on to the concept of Arrow functions now
this function over here has two
parameters right this function has
parameters A and B
and what we'll do is we'll change the
syntax of this function and the new
syntax will be more simple once you get
used to it so let's write the newer
syntax just below the previous one we
don't need the function keyword with
arrow functions so all we have to do is
we have to take a variable so let's do
it first so let's say we have a variable
where
so this is our variable
this statement is simple we have a
variable named errone and this will be
the function name so Arrow 1 will be the
function name as well right when we use
the function keyword in traditional
syntax of functions it automatically
creates a variable with the function
name here we have to declare the
variable by herself next up we have two
parameters here A and B as you can see
here we have a and b
we'll write the parameters within
parenthesis now so what we have to do is
we have to write parameters so let's say
the parameters are A and B for this
function as well so these are the
parameters we have to write them within
parenthesis
now we will use an arrow that actually
makes this variable a function now this
is the main concept to create an arrow
what we have to do is we have to write
equals to and then we have to write this
so This Is The Arrow Mark which makes
this whole statement a function
and then we'll write the body of the
function so the body of function will
remain same so we'll copy the body from
here
and we'll paste it here so this function
here this function Arrow one here is the
same as function function and the output
will be the same
this Arrow function here has only one
line here so the advantage provided by
Arrow functions in this case is quite
help
what we can do is we can make this
function up one line if we remove this
return keyword and the curly braces here
so we can remove these curly braces as
well what we have to do is we have to
make this function a one line right so
there will be no difference now so this
is how the arrow function for this
traditional function looks like now both
the functions will return the sum of two
numbers the only difference is in syntax
let's check the output for the arrow
function as well so what we'll do here
is we'll save this program and we'll go
to a console so let's do one thing we'll
call func one first and the parameters
let's say are 5 and 15. and then we'll
call the arrow function with the same
parameters so we'll write a arrow 5
comma 50.
now we have the output s20 in both the
cases right so these two functions are
working similarly these two functions
are same the only difference is in the
syntax
next up we have another simple function
here and what we want to do here is to
convert this traditional function into
an arrow function right now we are
talking about function function so let
me comment this first function here what
we'll do is we'll comment this and now
we are good to
so we have function func2 here now what
we'll do is we'll create an arrow
function for this function
so we'll write here
so we are writing your where
Arrow 2
and then we have no parameters so empty
parenthesis and then we have the arrow
operator so the body will remain the
same we'll copy the body from this
function
and we'll paste it here
now we have used empty parenthesis here
because we don't have any arguments here
let's try to run this code we'll call
the function here only so
for this we have to write here
Arrow 2 and we are good to save it and
the output we are expecting is
welcome to Simply code twice because we
are calling func 2 as well right so save
it
and here you can see the output is
welcome to Simply code let's change
something here so what we'll do is for
Arrow function we'll write here
simply learn
fine
so save it now and here you can see we
have the output as welcome to simplicode
and welcome to Simply learn let me Zoom
it for you if it's not visible so here
you can see the first output for Funk 2
it says welcome to Simply code and for
Arrow 2 it says welcome to Simply learn
that's working fine now before we wrap
up this video let me tell you another
benefit of using Arrow functions so we
already discussed that we don't need to
use the return keyword if we are writing
a one line of function similarly if we
have a single parameter we don't need
any parenthesis we'll create another
function here so let's say we are
writing here where
Arrow 3
and let's say it has only a single
parameter as new name fine then we'll
use the arrow operator and then inside
the body of this we'll write here
console Dot Lock
and then we'll write here hey there
plus the name provided by us in the
argument so
we are good to go this function here
will give us the output as hey there and
then whatever name will pass while
calling the function so let's check it
let's call this function as well so
let's say we are writing here Arrow 3
and
the name let's say will be
cautious
save it and here you can see it says hey
there question for Arrow function three
so this is also working fine
and I hope you guys are now clear with
the arrow functions in JavaScript it's
not essential to use Arrow functions
everywhere but now that we are clear
with promises and callback functions it
will be good to write minimum code and
the arrow function will help you with
that if you guys remember when we came
across callback functions in JavaScript
we use the function there that we said
will call the function after 2 seconds
or 3 seconds you might have guessed that
we are talking about the set timeout
method so this set timeout method is
actually a predefined function in
JavaScript that does some task after a
particular interval of time if we say we
want a function to be called after 5
Seconds when the user presses a button
so we'll use this set timeout method and
the function will be called after 5
Seconds of the user pressing the button
so it will be more clear to you guys
when we go through the programming part
so let's move on to the programming part
directly and we'll create a simple
button first and then on clicking that
button a pop-up will appear on the
screen with a message after some time so
we'll create a button first
so for that
will write here in a HTML file we'll use
the button tag again we'll write here
button and let's say the button name is
Click me
fine save it and here we have the button
on a browser
so we have created a button here this
was simple next up we want this button
to call a function on clicking so what
we'll do next is we'll use the on click
method within this button tag and then
we'll Define the function in Javascript
file so let's do it we'll write here
on click and we want this button to call
a function let's say the function name
is star
so what will happen is the function
start will be called on clicking this
button so let's move on to a Javascript
file and we'll declare some functions
here
so we'll create a function here that
will print some message on a pop-up not
the start function but a different one
so we'll write here where message
and then we'll use the Syntax for Arrow
functions so we will write here
alert and inside this wheel right here
welcome to
simply good so this is a message
save it
we have created an arrow function here
just to remind you guys of the Syntax
for Arrow functions so this function
will print this message with the pop-up
we can check it we have to go to a
console
and we'll write here
message and call this function so here
we have a pop-up with message welcome to
Simply good so this function is working
totally fine the real work Starts Now
what we'll do next is we'll Define the
function start with the set timeout
method for that we'll write here
function
start
and then inside the body of this start
function we'll call the set timeout
method and we'll pass two arguments here
so the first one is
the function name and the other one is
the time interval
so this is how we basically use the set
timeout method in JavaScript this is the
syntax so let's check the output now and
then we'll see another Syntax for the
same program so save it
and we'll go to the browser click on
this button and the pop-up will appear
after two seconds so here's the pop-up
with the message welcome to Simply code
so this is working fine
now this syntax here is for the
understanding purpose the following
syntax we'll go through will let you
know another concept of anonymous
functions in JavaScript
so for the newer syntax we'll write here
will comment this piece of code
and we'll write here
function and the function name is start
then inside the body of this function
we'll use the set timeout method
and we'll write here
function this function is an anonymous
function
then we have the body of this function
and the time
so here we have written 2000 and inside
the body will write here alert
and let's say the message it will print
is
welcome back
I mean if you see this function here you
can see that we have used the function
keyword instead of passing another
function this concept Here is known as
Anonymous functions in JavaScript
basically an anonymous function is a
function without a name we often use
this function as arguments to other
function and this syntax will call the
start function after 2 seconds
so this function here will work as the
previous one these two functions are the
same
it will also print the same message
after two seconds it will print welcome
back after two seconds save it and click
on the button you can see here we have
the pop-up on the screen after two
seconds so this function is working fine
the syntax are different but the working
is same
now let's go through another method the
next method is used to stop the timer in
between
so we'll use the first function we
created here for this purpose we'll
comment this piece of code and we'll use
this syntax only
now the next method we are going to
discuss about is the clear timeout
method
let's say we want to call this function
after 5 seconds and suddenly in between
we realize that we don't want to call
this function so what we want to do is
we want to stop this function before it
executes so the clear timeout method
comes into picture and this clear
timeout method works with the variable
so let's create another button for that
first and then we'll declare a variable
as well so let's say we want a button
here and this button will
call a function on clicking so let's say
the function name will be stop
and the button name will also be stop so
save it
and here you can see we have two buttons
one is the click me and the other one is
stop
next up we'll move back to our
JavaScript file
and we discussed earlier that this clear
timeout method works with a variable
so what we'll do next is we'll create a
variable and we'll assign the initial
value to that variable as 0.
let's say the variable name is ID and
the initial value is 0. now why we
assign the value as 0 to this ID
variable because
we want to update the value of ID
variable with the value provided by this
set timeout method so we'll assign the
value of the set timeout method to this
ID variable so we'll write here ID is
equals to set timeout
and the rest will remain the same now
next up we'll Define another function to
stop all this from happening so for that
we'll write here
yeah
function and the function name is top
and then inside the body of this
function
will
use the method clear timeout
and this method takes a variable as an
argument so we'll pass ID here
and we are done with it
so this function will stop the set
timeout method before execution let's
check it out save it and what we'll do
is we'll press the stop button in
between the two seconds
after the function start will be called
so let's change the timing here from 2
seconds to 5 Seconds
so we'll write here
save it now
and we'll first check if the function
start is working fine or not so press
the click me button and we have to wait
for five seconds
and then the pop-up will appear on the
screen with the message welcome to
Simply good so this function is working
totally fine now the next task is to
press the stop button in between those
five seconds let's do it
click on this click me button and in
between these five seconds click the
stop Button as well
so here you can see the message is not
printing anymore on clicking the stop
button so this function is also working
fine because we stopped the process in
between before the function start
executes
right
next up we have another method in the
timing functions that is the set
interval method as the name suggests
this method is used to call the function
repeatedly after a specific interval of
time
like the set timeout method this set
interval method also takes two
parameters first is the name of the
function and the other one is the time
interval so we'll change this program
only and instead of this set timeout
here
will write
set interval
fine so we are good to go now the only
change we did here is to use the set
interval method instead of the set
timeout method now what will happen is
on clicking this click me button the
function message will be called
repeatedly after 5 Seconds
let's check it out first save it and
click here on this button so we have to
wait for five seconds and then a pop-up
will appear
so here you can see we have the pop-up
here now after pressing OK we'll wait
for five seconds again and we have the
pop-up again so what's happening here is
we are getting the pop-up constantly
after five seconds right so this is also
working fine and on clicking the stop
button
this function will also stop so we have
clicked on this stop button and we are
not getting the pop-up anymore
so that's how the timing functions in
JavaScript Works async a way it works
with promises in JavaScript now async of
it is just a syntactical sugar wrapped
around promises in JavaScript basically
it makes it easier to work with promises
in JavaScript
we already know that using promises
might be a bit tricky or we can say more
prolonged sometimes because we have to
create so many functions and Promises in
JavaScript
so before we move on to async of it let
me take you guys through this code which
has promises in it and then we'll see
how to use async await in JavaScript so
here is a code for promises in
JavaScript here in this code we have two
functions make order and process order
the make order function returns a
promise and it will resolve it if the
user enters black coffee otherwise it
will reject it on any other type of
coffee
then we have another function here for
processing the order and it will always
resolve so this function is quite simple
and it will add some extra information
to the order so here is the code for
extra information it will print this on
Console so let's move ahead and we'll
look at how we call these functions
using promises and then we'll change the
same code using a sync await let me do
it guys first and then I'll explain it
to you so here's the code now what we
did here is we call the make order
function
and we'll pass here black coffee as an
argument to make it successful then we
have used the dot then because we are
using promises here and then we have the
order that will be returned buyer
promise so which in this case is a
string that says here is your coffee
this is the string if I show you so this
is the string it will return and then we
have written here console.log order has
been received it will be printed on the
console
and then we have called the process
order function and we are going to
process the order that we received and
the reason we are returning this is
because so you can see here we are
returning this process order function
the reason behind it is because we are
using promises here then we have changed
the event here so we have used the dot
then operator again we are going to
receive the response from the process
order above in this case we have taken
it as processed order and we have logged
whatever response we will get here the
next thing we did here is to use the
catch block
to catch any type of error we get for
example if the user says he wants a
latte not black coffee then it will give
an error and it will say that we serve
black coffee only so this is the code
for error so that's all and we are
calling these functions so if we save
this program
let's say we are saving it and if we go
back to our console
so here you can see the output says
making request for a black coffee and
then it says order has been processed
then it says processing order and then
at last it says extra information plus
here is your coffee have a nice day
that's how we wanted it to be right now
if the user says he wants a latte in
place of black coffee so let's check it
out and what we'll do is we'll pass the
argument here as latte instead of black
coffee
so save it now here you can see it says
making request for latte so firstly it
made a request for latte and then it
returned the error there it says sorry
we serve black coffee only so it's
working totally fine and this is how
promises actually work in JavaScript all
the different codes here are executed
and it is waiting for the previous code
to execute before moving on to the next
one
so that's what we exactly wanted here
now if you look at all this code here
which is obviously not too much
confusing but we have to use more dot
than here right we have to go through a
lot of nesting here and it could be done
easily with a sink of weight in
JavaScript and one more issue with
promises is if you want to use the
parameter inside this first dot then so
if you want to use a parameter here what
we have to do is we have to first create
a variable and we have to assign
something to that variable which is not
an easy task right but with async end of
it we can do it more efficiently and we
don't have to worry about all the dot
thens and all so now we'll do the same
program with async end of it and we'll
do it here only below this program we'll
write this piece of code with the help
of async of it and we'll see how easy it
is to use a sink and await in JavaScript
so let me comment this first guys now
the first thing we need to keep in mind
with async and a weight is we need a
function to use these terms for example
let's create a simple function here
first so we'll write here function
let's say the function name is Funk one
and then we have the body of this
function so this is the basic function
here and we'll put all our asynchronous
code inside here in this function
but we need to tell JavaScript that this
function will work asynchronously for
that we have to write a keyword here
before function so what we'll do is
we'll write here
async and this is the syntax now
JavaScript will know that this function
is an asynchronous function and it will
handle this function accordingly now
inside of this function what we'll do is
we'll call a different methods here
so we'll call the make order method here
and then we'll call the process order
method as well so let's do it first
let's call the make order method first
so we'll write here
make order and will pass the argument
here so the argument will be let's say
black coffee
fine
now we have called the function make
order here all we have to do is we have
to write a weight in front of this
function which will make the code wait
until this make order function executes
then only the next part will be executed
so we'll write here
of it and this make order function now
will return the resolve section of the
first promise we made so we'll store
this inside a variable so we'll write
here let's create a variable here we'll
write where
order
fine
because we have all this code inside of
an asynchronous function what will
happen is as soon as JavaScript finds
that a weight keyword so as soon as
JavaScript find this await keyword
it will leave this function and start
doing other works inside of this program
remember it will leave this whole
function it's not something like the set
timeout method it is different from that
as soon as the make order function is
done executing it will come back to this
function and Returns the result into
this order variable
next up what we'll do is we'll write
here
console
.log
and what we want to log here is order as
B
received now
if we look at the promises example
previously and compare these two codes
so if you can see here we are done with
this part so this is what it looks like
while working with a sink of weight in
JavaScript
now we'll see that we have received the
order with pretty easy syntax right next
up what we have to do is we have to
process this order this means that we
have to write the code for the second
then we used in the promises example
right the syntax will remain the same
for that we'll write here where
processed order
is equals to
a weight we'll use the await keyword
again
and then we'll write here
process order
fine
and then we'll pass the argument as
order so we are passing this variable as
an argument to this process order
function
in the next line we'll write here
console.log
and we'll copy this this line is the
same so we'll copy it from here will
paste it
fine now we have used the variable
processed order to process the order and
then we know that as soon as the
processing is done we want it to log it
in here
so we are done with this and all we need
to do now is called a synchronous
function and we are good to go so let's
call this function first for that we'll
write here
Funk one
now save this program
so here you can see it says process
order is not defined so okay we have to
remove this e here
now save this and here you can see we
have the exact same output as we had in
the promises example and with this we
can say the a sync a weight are working
totally fine now the question arising in
your mind may be that we didn't do
anything for the catch block here right
what if the user enters latte in place
of black coffee so let's try to do it
once so what we'll do is we'll write
here
latte and save it so you can see the
first function is working fine it says
making request for a latte and then it
says
sorry we serve black coffee only so this
is a error and got error in promises so
we have to do something about this error
right now the async and await in
JavaScript actually has two blocks one
for resolving and the other one for
error or reject so we can say like the
then and catch in promises we have try
and catch in a sink of it so what we
have to do here is we have to put all
this piece of code inside the try block
so let's do it first what we'll do here
is we'll write here
try so what we are doing is we are
asking the computer to try this piece of
code if this is fine or not
and then we have another block catch
fine so we will write the code for
rejection here inside the sketch block
what we'll do is we'll write here catch
and we'll pass a argument here so we'll
write a error
and then we'll log this error on a
console so we'll write here console.log
hello
so we have passed the parameter here and
the moment it will find any error it
will leave the try block and moves on to
the catch block and the output will be
an error so save it and you can see it
here
on the console it says sorry Vsauce
black coffee only so this is how we can
use a sync await in JavaScript it's not
necessary to use with over promises but
the syntax is relatively clean and easy
to understand right as you can see
all we have to keep in mind while using
async await is we have to use a function
and wrap up all the data inside it so
keep this thing in mind that we have to
use a function always and we have to
wrap up all this data inside a single
function with the help of try and catch
block try and catch block are pretty
easy to use right we'll go through try
and catch Block in the next video as
well and we'll go through error only
another important thing I want to
mention here before we end up this video
is guys it may happen that you might
don't use these topics quite frequently
while working on the front end of a
website but if you get to answer these
questions during an interview and these
topics are pretty crucial if you are
learning JavaScript now errors are
something that we get at times while
working on a program generally there are
different types of Errors present in
almost every programming language errors
like syntax error runtime errors and
logical errors so syntax errors are
those errors a user can't control we are
to correct the Syntax for that that's
the only option with syntax errors for
example let's say we have a function
that will print something on the console
on calling so let's create a function
here
will go to a Javascript file and we'll
create a function here so let's say the
function name is f
fine
and this function will
print something
on the console so let's say it prints
this is
Function One Fine
now this is a function that will print
this string on the console but let's say
we forgot to put the closing bracket of
this function by mistake or let's say
the closing part was deleted and we are
not aware of it so this part was deleted
or we forgot to put it there
and what we'll do is we'll call this
function we try to call this function
let's call it first
we'll call function1 save it and
go to the console so
here in console you can see that it
returns an error here it says syntax
error unexpected end of input and the
best part is we can't do anything for it
except for we can put that closing
bracket in its place again
so if he put this closing bracket here
again
now it will work fine save it and here
you can see we have the output as this
is function1
so these type of Errors when occur in a
program are known as syntax errors
another type of error that occurs in a
program is runtime error runtime errors
are those errors through which the
system comes across during the execution
of a program for example let's say if we
have another function here so let's add
another function here we'll write here
function F2
and the body
will print something on the console
again so we'll copy this from here and
instead of function one we'll write a
function to
save it and we haven't called this
function yet so let's imagine a scenario
that you created a function F2 and later
somewhere in the program you realize
that you created a function and you need
to call that function but you are not
sure of the name of that function so
let's say you called another function
but the function name was wrong so let's
say instead of function 2 we called
another function F4 let's call this
let's try to do it save it and here you
can see a first function is working fine
but when the system reaches function F2
it encountered an error here although
there is nothing wrong with the syntax
we are trying to call a function that
does not exist so these type of errors
are known as reference error in a
program we can fix these type of error
with the help of try catch and throw
block we'll see it later these are the
different types of errors that might
occur in a program but sometimes there
are situations in which we want to print
an error to the user it might be for the
data entered by the user or for the data
we are getting from the server basically
we are talking about custom errors that
we create ourselves to make the flow of
program more smooth
we came across the try and catch Block
in the previous video wherein we used
these keywords with the async await in
JavaScript
so there we saw how these blocks were
working to print an error when the user
asks for something other than black
coffee if you haven't watched that video
yet please go through it you can find it
in this playlist
so let's do one thing here and we'll
create a small prototype of the same
program wherein we will have a function
that will print a string on the console
so let me comment this out guys now
we'll create another function here so
let's say we are writing here
function
make order
fine so this is the function we created
in the last video as well so let's say
inside the body of this function we'll
write something on the control
we will write a console.log and
right here here is your black coffee
enjoy your
day fine now we will go through the
syntax of try and catch block first
and we'll see why we use these try and
catch blocks in a program so before we
move on to the try and catch block Let
Me Clear one thing guys it's not only
the try and catch blocks we use for
these purposes we have another Block in
JavaScript that is always independent of
these two blocks and doesn't need any
condition to run so the inclusion of the
finally Block in error handling depends
upon the user you can either add it or
leave it there will be no effect on the
program
so now let's move ahead and we'll go
through the syntax of try and catch
first and then we'll move on to the
finally block because finally block is
different from try and catch so let's go
through the try and catch first so we'll
write here
try and press
so we'll write here
try and you can see this is the syntax
of try and catch block the catch
contains an argument with it and it will
catch the error returned by the try
block
so let's write the code here and then
we'll go through it we want to run this
function inside the try block and if the
function exists
the try block will execute it otherwise
a customized error will be thrown to the
user so we'll call this function inside
the try block
so we'll write a make
order
and we have called this function
now if the function exists the try block
will execute it there will be no problem
in that we are asking the computer to
try executing this line and if this line
does not exist show the user the error
we want to show not the one set by
default so the customized error will
write inside the catch block
and inside the catch block we'll write
here
console.log
and let's say it says
sorry
so this is the error we want to show the
error says sorry an error occurred in
your program
now let's execute this once and then
we'll see it again thoroughly so
this code will not show an error save it
and it will execute the function make
order and the output will be here's your
black coffee enjoy your day
right
but if we execute here another function
that does not even exist like we did for
the runtime errors so if we write here
let's say another function so let's say
the other function name is
process order fine so this function does
not exist in the entire program now the
system will go inside the try block and
it will execute the make order function
Force the make order function will be
executed without any problem but the
moment it will come across the function
process order it will find it out that
no such function exists in the program
that's when it will move to the next
block and it will throw an error to the
user so save this program and you can
see here it says here is your black
coffee enjoy your day first and then it
says sorry an error occurred in your
program so this is how you can show an
error to the user a customized error we
can say if we call this process order
function outside of the try block the
scenario will change
the error will be different so let me
show you guys what we'll do is we'll cut
this process order from here and we'll
call this process order function outside
of the try and catch block
now we have called this process order
function here and we know this function
does not exist in the program so let's
save it and here you can see it says
uncode reference error process order is
not defined so this is a runtime error
here now this is the default error you
get in JavaScript this is the default
way in which you can get an error in
Java
so there are certain things we can do
with errors in JavaScript which are
let's say if you want to print the error
as well in the console so we just have
to write here console.log
editor
and one more thing we have to do is we
have to move this process order function
from here
back again to its original position
so save it now and here you can see we
have a reference error now this
statement will print the whole error in
the form of text and the user will know
the type of error as well
apart from that we can also print only
the message or the name of them so for
that we have to write here
console.log
error Dot name for the name of error and
console.lock error Dot
message for the error message so save it
and here you can see
we have reference error and as the name
of error and the message is process
order is not defined so this part of the
error is the message and this part is
the name now we are left with the
finally block only we have already
discussed that the finally block is
independent of the two blocks and it
will be executed anyway if present in a
program
so the Syntax for finally block goes
like this
what we'll do is we'll remove
these three statements from our program
and we'll write here
finally
and inside the finally let's say we want
to print something
on the
console so let's say we'll write here
this block
will
execute
no matter what now this finally block
will be executed anyhow so save it and
here you can see we have the output as
this block will execute no matter what
let's do one thing let's take this
process order function from here and
we'll paste it here save it now and here
you can see now none of the three blocks
is executing right so what we have to do
is we have to put it back in its place
one more thing we will discuss before
wrapping up this video is the throw
keyword in JavaScript with this keyword
we can throw an error anywhere in the
program the message will be customizable
and the type will be uncut error fine
let's see an example of this type of
error handling with the help of basic if
else statement
so let's say we have a condition here in
which we have a variable so let me
comment this piece of code as well first
now let's say we have a condition here
in which we have a variable a and the
value of a is let's say 9. the condition
we have to check here is if a is less
than 10 then an error should be thrown
otherwise the system should print
something
right so let's move on to the
programming part and you will understand
it so what we'll do is we'll declare a
variable e and the value of variable a
will be 9. now the if statement will
have a condition that if a is less than
throw an error so what we have to do is
we have to write here through Nu
error
fine
and the message will be let's say this
is a
customizable error thing
this is the message and we have to
mention the else statement here as well
so inside the SLC statement we'll write
here
console.log
working fine let's say
so
the if else block does not matter that
much in this case the only thing I want
you guys to see here is the throw
keyword save this program here and we
have the value as 9.
and what we wanted to throw an error if
the value is less than 10 save it and
here you can see
we have a familiar representation of
this error different from the try catch
block the message is customizable and it
says this is a customizable error
so this is how we can throw an error in
the program wherever we want to I hope
you guys got it
also with that we come to the end of
this full course tutorial if you enjoyed
watching this video do give it a thumbs
up comment your doubts below and a
expert